bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
deuxième journée de la procece League le
plus grand tournoi par équipe en ligne
hier mon cher Kévin on a vu évidemment
ce premier match ensemble
c'était un beau match où les Indiens ont
dominé et on m'a même pas eu besoin de
jouer les quatre dernières parties donc
c'était une performance assez
impressionnante tout à fait Laurent
salut à toi salut à tous et on est
reparti là pour la deuxième journée avec
c'est vrai comme tout le soulignait la
victoire des Indiens face au Brésil et
je sais après je t'ai laissé un
malencontreusement Laurent est a fini
avec Nathan j'ai vu et t'as assuré un
technique membre c'était un premier jour
il y a eu des petits bugs mais
maintenant je sais que tu es tu es
parfaitement au point et ça va être
assez incroyable au niveau technique
aujourd'hui tu vas placer la barre très
très haut j'espère que j'espère que tu
es en bon déprimé par ce match de foot
d'hier évidemment j'ai reçu un petit
mail ce matin tu nous en diras plus tu
avais la trouille j'ai cru que j'ai cru
que tu demandais de l'argent la fin du
mail et effectivement tu demandes de
l'argent mais de manière détournée c'est
un petit peu ça
ouais tu étais dans cette liste aussi
voilà les contacts mailing list tu
devrais me lever en fait c'était
d'habitude c'est les gens qui reçoivent
les mails qui qui s'enlèvent de la main
glisse mais là je crois que ça va être
l'inverse c'est toi c'est toi qui abordé
de la main
tu iras peut-être te prendre une petite
vidéo pour progresser encore Laurent
Kevin ça y est il a un problème quoi tu
vois il a trouvé il y a un truc il se
passe un truc dans sa vie il faut que je
l'aide faut que j'aille à mon avis Kevin
peut-être on va on va regarder tout ça
alors aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui on a deux matchs mon cher
Kevin alors on a pas comme hier Magnus
Mbappé 4 sur 4 la tornade Magnus même
dans la dernière il était foutu mais il
a renversé la vapeur et il a il a réussi
à gagner il a été énorme Magnus il a
porté les chess Bry il a fait quatre sur
quatre son équipe a fait 8,5 à gagner 8
et demi 7 et demi donc
vous souhaitez regarder le replay pour
pour mettre un petit peu au courant pour
voir s'il y avait eu des petites choses
voilà que je pouvais commenter et c'est
vrai que ça c'est très très bien passé
ça a été chaud comme match quand même ça
a été bouillant mais c'est vrai qu'avec
un leader pareil ils peuvent aller très
loin les chaises bras alors aujourd'hui
c'est pas du tout la même mayonnaise on
n'a pas ils ont en fait misé alors il y
a deux types d'équipe il y a ceux qui
misent sur les têtes d'affiche Carlson
car wanna va chier La Grave gretchouk et
d'autres qui misent sur une équipe plus
homogène et donc comme les indiens ou
finalement qu'on est vidite les autres
on connaissait pas trop et bien ça a été
ça a été nettoyé vite fait bien fait
bon on voit quand même une tête
d'affiche aujourd'hui avec la présence
quand même de mon média Rohff qui est
habitué des des grands rendez-vous très
clairement c'est le premier match tout à
fait mon cher mon cher Kevin évidemment
non en deuxième match à 19 h donc on
verra quand ça se termine mais c'est
vrai qu'en à chaque rire ma média off
David par avion qui est pas très connue
mais moi je peux vous dire qu'il est
qu'il est tout simplement c'est pas une
partenaire de Daniel Duboeuf en blitz
donc bon
en fait Laurent on l'a vu au speechess
alors il s'était fait étriers par Naka
mais quand même
ridicule du tout et il s'est qualifié et
c'est déjà extrêmement dur et Naka il
arrivait des fois quand même vraiment
lui faire mal alors sur le long terme
d'accord à gagner relativement aisément
comme je disais mais c'est un joueur
hyper dangereux qui a l'habitude qui
connaît bien à la musique à 25 86
il est pas grave très clairement Laurent
c'est un joueur qui vaut sans doute 26
50 27 en partie de 10 + 2 c'est ça tout
à fait exactement donc c'est une équipe
la série qui Prusse les Vito chef Wizard
c'est il y a les vitov très connu qui a
qui a lancé sa chaîne qui a essayé qui
est aussi écrit un bouquin je sais pas
si tu l'as lu avec Eve Gunny bar et F
sur l'expérience de d'évrye en tant que
secondant de mal champion du monde pour
Vladimir cramique et notamment notamment
Vladimir cramé qui a battu en 2000 le
King Gary Kasparov donc détrôner
détrônés en quelque sorte Mike Tyson
c'est quand même c'est quand même
quelque chose donc voilà il était dans
l'équipe
barrière et donc ils ont écrit un livre
ensemble et il a lancé une chaîne très
sympa parfois c'est sous-titré et chose
très intéressantes sur cette chaîne et
là il a une équipe avec Denis lazavie
que je connais pas bien et évidemment là
GM russe très très forte très forte à
partir rapide Valentina gounina donc une
une belle équipe quand même
c'était au championnat du monde de
rapides et Blitz qu'on a commenté sur
sur la chaîne chasse comme FR et il
avait été redoutable donc à 25 29 c'est
pareil il est sous classé donc je pense
qu'ils ont vraiment une pure équipe
cisaline ça ils font ils font vraiment
peur c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout
alors en face on a les Garden State
alors ça ça ressemble plutôt à une
équipe américaine où on a tricha
kanyamara alors là j'ai pas du tout la
ref elle est quand même
woman elle est maître internationale
féminin donc
Laurent bon 2163 alors entre guillemets
je veux vexer personne évidemment dans
le chat
Hello c'est modeste pour cette compète
ça c'est une évidence
clairement on voit qu'elle rend 400
points hello on va dire à
la moyenne de l'équipe adverse
on a chacun aura elle aura les blancs
face à sacré à ma média dans la première
partie bon on va voir ce que ça va
donner ensuite on a Alexander l'enderman
alors lui est très connu un Américain
hostile très très solide voilà qui va
être probablement jouer un rôle de
stopper ici ensuite Gadir gooseynov très
fort joueur azeri et la jaune étoile
montante mon cher Kevin samsevian
un Américain d'origine évidemment
arménienne très très bon joueur bon on
est habillé nous on est par ailleurs
nous on est joueur moi je m'habiller sur
sur les vitov toi tu prends les autres
non
c'est clair que non Laurent on se fait
des petits Paris avec avec de temps en
temps aussi et il arrive qu'on soit
d'accord et là c'est facile de toute
façon c'est vite vu il y a tricha qui
est quand même beaucoup plus faible que
les autres joueurs
donc
sur sur le reste sur le reste ça va être
un match équilibré je pense donc
normalement elle elle pourrait même
perdre toutes ses parties après c'est
une expérience formidable et on va voir
à cette cadence de jeu tout est possible
mais elle est quand même sur le papier
beaucoup plus faible que les autres on
va voir on va voir tout ça on regarde
évidemment ce qu'est de l'eau alors
aujourd'hui voyez on a ça et on a ceux
qui ont raté leur logo là qui vont jouer
quand on a énormément
c'est les Espagnols les Espagnols savent
manana comme on dit en Espagne manana le
logo face au norvenox monde ancienne
équipe
présidé en fait en tout cas le directeur
c'est Yann notre vigues Hammer
évidemment celui qui est de la même
génération de que Magnus Carson mais
belle équipe belle équipe norvégienne
aussi et demain évidemment à 16h30 donc
tu seras pas là je crois demain ça sera
tout avec moi mais on aura le début de
l'équipe française avec ils ont annoncé
la compo là ça ça va être du lourd hein
demain 16h30 faut pas rater manuscrit va
chez Lagrave pardon Alexander greatchouk
et j'ai oublié mile Boyer my Litto le
petit jeune le jeune qui pousse donc
équipe très très intéressante de la part
de Blist Stream qui jouera face à une
équipe solide et avec Erica easy une
équipe indienne bon je crois que ça on
dit ça dit non et qui peut indienne dit
équipe équipe difficile pour les
le format du tournoi on a ça c'est le
format de départage non ça c'est pas
terrible ça la moyenne et l'eau ne peut
pas dépasser les 2550 on s'est trompé
hier on a été un duo en erreur parce
qu'on a j'avais les deux 2550 l'équipe
doit comporter au moins une femme un
plafonnement hello est appliqué comme
suit les joueurs classés plus de 2700
compte comme 200700 les choses classées
plus de 1350 comme de comptes comme 2350
et je vous laisse classer moins de 2002
contre comme 2002 bon écoute ça sera une
remarque Laurent hier effectivement
quand je calculé rapidement il une
moyenne élo supérieure à 2500 et
quelqu'un est fait la remarque on
n'avait pas trop relevé mais on la
mesure mieux encore cette remarque voilà
bah évidemment c'était de 1550 tout
s'explique en cas de huit partout Kevin
quand même assez improbable sur ces
matchs quoi que c'est match serré hier
8h30 ça s'est joué pas grand-chose
cadence 3 + 2 les quatrième échiquier
s'affrontent en averser les couleurs
donc c'est important de pas trop
délaisser ce quatrième échiquier parce
que finalement si on est beaucoup moins
fort sur le quatrième et bien on peut
perdre le match tout simplement
alors mon cher ça peut être assez
expéditif là dans dans ce premier match
on va voir ça peut jouer sur trois
rondes on va voir alors normalement j'ai
les tu vas rire tu vas rire tu vas rire
normalement les Wizards ont commencé je
sens que tu vas rire je sens que tu vas
pas être impressionné dans les Wizards
n'ont pas commencé c'est les gardiens
pas ça tu veux être impressionné ou pas
c'est les cames que tu vas me mettre
sans doute oh là là ça me sévère on l'a
il est là il est là ça me fait bien
alors sinon on peut je pense que pour la
première partie tu sais que si on va
prendre on va voir on va voir on va pas
s'enflammer
et on va voir on voit Sam seviane à à
l'image pour l'instant on n'a pas de
partie je pense qu'on va découvrir en
vrai notre ami
notre ami de
vous voyez ouais bien sûr bien sûr il
est chaud patate et on va découvrir en
fait on va regarder la partie entre ma
media off et la jeune la jeune trichage
je pense et salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent et oui Cyril se rappelle lui
aussi de lasavik on avait vu au cheval
du monde donc c'est c'est franchement
très très intéressant
il me dit que mon micro il est pas il
est comment dirais-je pas au niveau
sonore donc je pense que je suis en
dessous de toi Laurent voilà merci de
tous pour pour l'info c'est en dessous
de moi et ben c'est vrai mais c'est déjà
fait exprès tu vois pour donc je vais je
vais te s'il était un peu dingue il
était un peu deg je vais te je vais te
remettre et là on a la jeune tricha qui
va apparaître sous vos yeux ébahi tech
fresh ne me ne oh si vous pouvez vous
lever pour m'applaudir mais ça passe
bien parce que je fais voilà on va voir
on va repasser au mode normal et on voit
la jeune tricha qui sera là on va voir
son nom apparaître ne vous inquiétez pas
et là les les Beatles
leur stream 6 ont commencé leur stream
donc regardez hop là normalement on
était censé avoir oulala
je vais vous faire en direct
je te remercie je te remercie là je fais
un peu en direct parce que sinon je suis
en galère mais on aura chacun les Noirs
dans cette première partie
l'expérimenter évidemment oh là là
ça c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est vraiment une vidéo
un passiblement médiérophe une détente
un peu de côté
c'est la magie du direct alors c'est
sympa mais c'est vrai que
parfois
le problème c'est que si je le fais
avant avant le show ça serait parfait
faut demander aux joueurs de venir avant
mais bon ils sont pas ils sont pas
chauds pour venir avant la gestion des
cames voilà je sais pas c'est pas si mal
alors après c'est vrai quand tu vas me
demander de regarder une autre partie
parfois évidemment la vidéo collera pas
avec le nom vous avez petite nouveauté
par rapport à il se moque de moi mon
cher ami Kévin mais bon en bas on va de
nous qu'est-ce que vous avez et bien
vous avez les résultats live donc vous
avez on a chacun off vous verrez si on
regarde pas une partie on aura les
points quand même qui s'affichent tandis
qu'en bas en bas de l'échiquier donc
soit chez qui vous avez les chéquiers
avec les noms et tout ça les noms qui
sont en dessous des caméras et les temps
qui sont au dessus des caméras donc vous
voyez la 2 minutes mais c'est la partie
d'hier parce que la partie a pas encore
commencé mais surtout ce que vous avez
en bas vous avez le score global match
avec ce levitov Chase Wizards qui a zéro
évidemment et ses gardent sade-passer
qui sont à zéro ouais pas mal quand même
tu sais qu'on est on est pas loin mais
j'ai regardé en fait si quand j'ai fait
j'ai regardé show anglais hier je me
suis dit je veux pareil bon on va pas
être tout à fait pareil au niveau de la
gestion c'est pas loin tu t'en approches
perfectionniste le Laurent ouais
on s'y met parce que ça ça m'agace après
je sais que parce qu'en tant que je me
mets à la place des comme je suis à
viewer aussi on est on est tous des tu
vois avant tout des passionnés et donc
c'est vrai qu'en tant que viewer moi
c'est un truc qui m'agace et on a la
partie de ma média Rohff où il a les
noirs et vous voyez oh le temps a pas ah
non il y a pas de temps pour l'instant
voilà ça m'agace toujours en tant que
viewer quand c'est pas c'est pas au top
voilà pas clean
donc j'essaie de faire la même chose
pour vous et on va attendre les premiers
coups entre ma média off et
donc Trisha
Kanya kanyam vas-y dis-le Kevin
est-ce que c'est mieux au niveau du son
je sais pas je vois au niveau de la
jauge je suis un tout petit peu en
dessous je pense
notre ami notre ami secret voilà ouais
ça c'est ça c'est lui il peut être
dilettante sur les parties rapides il
faut qu'il fasse attention quand même
vous voyez d'ailleurs qu'il est un peu
même dans sa posture totale détente mais
c'est un génie du jeu rapide
donc bon voilà elle a fait son petit
dessin alors je te mets un peu plus fort
allez allez soyons fous
je te mets encore ça alors non je sais
pas je veux pas qu'on soit trop fort ou
pas mais voilà je sais pas je sais pas
si ça va mieux merci on fait vraiment
tes réglages secs
en plus j'ai fait un petit test avant
c'est vrai qu'il me semblait c'est
peut-être un peu plus fort mais c'est
pas sûr c'est toujours très très
compliqué
et je vois que kanyamara elle est
irlandaise en fait tricha voilà
irlandaise ouais et donc il a joué des
cinq fou G7 E4 ouais elle a pris
l'espace comme tu l'as dit mais c'est
vrai que tu donnes une cible alors
effectivement il y a pas de quoi il y a
pas de conseils avec les Blancs se font
en B7 et pas près de revoir le jour
mais il veut il veut simplement faire ça
et ça jouer aux échecs mais il est moins
bien
équilibrée on a vu vidite faire ça hier
et très bien s'en sortir
donc pourquoi pas évidemment il va jouer
il va jouer vite il va mettre la
pression au temps il sait le faire donc
il est pas pas hyper inquiet le gamin
alors attention il peut aussi il peut
aussi s'envoler ma meilleure offre il
est pas toujours très régulier mais
c'est vrai que si il est lancé il peut
gagner énormément de parties
consécutives
très mal si tu vois quelque chose
d'intéressant ou si vous voyez quelque
chose d'intéressant les autres parties
bon pour l'instant on reste sur ça c'est
que moi moins on change mieux ça
m'arrange au niveau des câbles
de quoi tu parles
mais on peut évidemment changer
[Rires]
le peuple ratapha alors
tour des stades bon ben on reste sur les
caméras alors allez un petit tour des
stades on voit par Aviane face à
l'enderman dans cette deuxième partie
donc là j'ai pas le temps de changer la
caméra on voit
une trompe au ski et est-ce que tu veux
une idée technique pour le futur Laurent
est-ce qu'on pourrait prendre dupliquer
cette scène là et mettre les cames dans
tout bon pour plus tard pour plus tard
ça c'est les streams futures ouais je
suis d'accord mais en fait j'avais pas
le le stream YouTube était pas encore
lancé mais c'est vrai qu'en fait c'est
ça qu'il faut faire
d'habitude attendez charges Laurent
elles sont déjà créées enfin quand
j'avais la scène du tata style tout
était déjà créé donc c'était hyper
simple enfin c'était hyper simple c'est
beaucoup plus simple pour toi non mais
là là où tu te rends pas compte de la
difficulté qui s'accroît c'est que les
joueurs changent de couleur
oui bien sûr si si j'ai déjà vu dans
certaines compétitions des si je vois
très très bien donc c'est c'est une
galère sombre pour le coup
donc on voit une trompe au ski
intéressante avec l'enderman avec les
Blancs bon écoute on va voir c'est
plutôt quelque chose sur le papier en
2572 pour l'enderman 2786 pour parabian
peut-être parvient un peu plus
un peu plus expert du jeu sur internet
mais bon
de plus pour les blancs mais le centre
est au noir donc vous voyez là c'est
déjà le mal de crâne pour démarrer
position très disputée hier on avait eu
des positions un peu des parties un peu
timides certaines fois là c'est le
contraire là c'est une partie une partie
assez assez chaude surtout assez cadence
là c'est très fermé tout à fait on va
faire un tour vers gouzey 9 contre
la zavik dont le jeune joueur il est
quoi il est
biélorus et on a une assez indienne
ouais ces experts de la Standard les
joueurs aériens avec d6c5 là la
Valentine métrique sur voilà on a une
symétrie parfaite à part que les Blancs
ont un tempo en plus alors est-ce qu'on
peut l'utiliser ou pas c'est toujours la
même question F4 qui est logique pour
faire cavalier E5 on l'empêche tout de
suite faut 3 P6 variante des fois des
Français 5 et cavaliers 5 avant
l'arrivée du carré en CC
on peut faire ça ce que je croyais très
fort il y a un joueur
de faire rebondir le cavalier en Détroit
et travailler de travailler sur l'aile
dame c'est quand même très sympathique
bon c'est toujours des positions ou il y
a pas grand chose mais juste la
domination fougée de Foussais 8 comme
dans une catalane toi tu aimes bien ce
style là alors de faire suer
l'adversaire bah comme Magnus qui le
fait vraiment comme personne
effectivement et Magnus a une partie
avec les Noirs ici il a joué cavaliers 8
contre visite il y a quelques années qui
était censé
résoudre plus ou moins mais pas si
facile qu'il y ait des trois on fait
qu'il y ait des 6 on va essayer de se
venger par là et pareil on fait pareil
mais oui donc c'est toujours toujours un
léger avantage blanc ça c'est sûr et il
joue cavalier H5 du coup faut f4kh 5 x 3
B6 MC1 fou B7 tout est normal et en
général quand c'est comme ça les noirs
sont plus ou moins quand même ok ils ont
réussi à
mais bon toujours légèrement avantage
blanc on va mettre les tours les pièces
sont un petit peu mieux placées et en
cadence rapide c'est un peu galère
d'être très précis avec les Noirs
franchement ce que c'est ça qui
recherche en tout cas avec avec les
Blancs donc basique et on a on a la
dernière partie entre donc Valentina
gounina qui joue avec les Blancs contre
la jeune étoile américaine ça me fait
Viane et on a une est indienne ici
avec la variante
principale tout simplement alors petit
rock et le coup principal ici à jouer
faux 3 qui est aussi qui est aussi une
variante très critique que j'ai 4 ou
j'ai 5F 6 la fois H4 et le coup normal
mais fou c'est complètement jouable
c'est vrai qu'on a affaibli les noirs
qui est ici petit rock et F5 tout ça est
très connu c'est Viane qui va essayer de
marquer le point face à Valentina mais
attention il peut il faut se méfier
parce que va-t-il elle a fait elle peut
faire des elle est un peu comme ma média
en fait un peu le même style avec elle
peut faire une journée à 4 sur 4 elle
peut faire une journée à zéro
si on compare les les deux féminines
présentes
foi championne de Russie nombreuses fois
médaillés d'or aux Olympiades avec cette
équipe russe qui n'en finit plus de
gagner enfin qui en fait là
quelque chose comme ça donc bon à 24 75
on peut dire qu'elle est pas à son pic
de forme donc elle peut jouer à 25 50
donc c'est une grand maître forte qui
peut même gêner des joueurs comme ces
viandes qui sont presque 2700 et là on
rentre dans une autre catégorie de
joueurs quand même mais sur une partie
en 10 + 2 elle peut elle peut accrocher
des points entiers et des demi points
tout à fait
alors Florent Herve qui on salut tout le
monde sur alors sur le twitch Escom fr
vous êtes là évidemment là la majorité
d'entre vous sinon on est sur on est
aussi sur chaise 24 en français la
chaîne Youtube et cheesecom en français
la chaîne Youtube donc n'hésitez pas à
nous rejoindre à mettre des pouces à
vous abonner à tout et comme ça vous ne
ratez aucun show surtout évidemment sur
les chaînes Chess.com
évidemment parce que ça sera là où il y
aura là le plus de show même si on
essaie d'en refaire toujours plus
évidemment donc on voit chaque Real et
bien c'est pas mal pour lui avec cette
paire de fou ou pas qu'est-ce qu'on en
pense il a réglé les problèmes de
l'ouverture mais en même temps il a pas
non plus grand chose il y a qu'une
colonne ouvertes et bon elle est
partagée les blancs et le reste leur
bonne pièce avec la structure fixe avoir
le cavalier l'orange je pense que c'est
pas si mauvais évidemment il faut juste
pas se faire ramasser avec un fouet F5
exactement ce que je voulais dire c'est
que potentiellement les finales peuvent
être quand même assez difficiles pour
les pour les blancs donc ça peut être
évident de contester cette colonne sans
sans échanger les dames donc je suis un
petit peu inquiet pour
de lui prendre le pion donc en termes de
oui donc ouais c'est pas mal la question
de Florence était en terme de points
précis quelle est l'équipe la plus forte
bon je suppose que il y en a qui non
mais en fait tu vois en terme de
la problématique c'est qu'on voit que il
y a beaucoup de joueurs sur la liste de
force donc finalement ça dépend qui est
aligné
ok on peut répondre mais c'est biaisé ça
dépend des joueurs qui seront réellement
présents dans la compétition et en plus
voilà on peut imaginer que par exemple
les chaises bras sur le papier vont être
vont être les plus forts parce que Manu
c'est et ramené à 2700 donc voilà on
perd on perd des points mais bon
franchement on peut pas peu importe peu
importe et finalement moi j'ai
l'impression qu'une équipe homogène
peut être beaucoup plus dangereuse que
d'autres équipes voilà c'est c'est
lévitof Wizard là il m'a l'air
ils ont une équipe sérieuse d'ailleurs
robinside nous confirme que ce sont les
Wizards qui ont la meilleure moyenne en
plus en plus elle est là Robinson il
fait des petits-enfants discrètes et je
peux te dire qui suit il t'écoute si tu
si tu dis trop de bêtises Laurent
attention il surveillance ça existe les
community managers donc il est il est
quoi exactement Robinson il est
community manager il bosse en tout cas
il papillonne autour du stream à chaque
fois c'est définir quel est son son réel
moi je suis pas dans les petits papiers
de chess com mais il est toujours là il
est toujours là alors peut-être qu'il
est en train de multiplication
normalement quand tu dis que tu es multi
casquette si tu fais pas grand-chose
quoi
non désolé c'est pas ma casquette
aujourd'hui je fais plutôt mais je fais
plutôt ça aujourd'hui tu connais pas
laisse tomber
je l'ai fait tellement mais j'arrête pas
de dire moi je fais plein de choses tu
sais beaucoup d'activités différentes et
tout ça mais en fait je fais rien voilà
et comme ça les gens les gens le savent
pas ils disent ouais je suppose avec
toutes tes casquettes super occupé
donc il est 4 attends mais tu sais quel
jour j'aime bien comment elle joue
très ambitieuse
pour l'instant ma média Rohff attention
et on a deux pièces mineures qui peuvent
travailler sur case noire en plus de la
dame et le rock de Mami garof et un peu
troué il y a le pion c'est 7 il doit
régler ses problèmes et comment il fait
tu joues quoi là
peut-être tout romain parce que j'ai le
droit de jouer tout le monde mais tu
étais pas c'est pas les couilles les
plus actif que tu as fait toute ta vie
et là peut-être qu'il va falloir que je
me sépare du
faire un petit fou G7
comme j'aime bien faire tu m'as envoyé
au charbon avec cette position assez
modeste demain média Rohff et il va
peut-être jouer 7 mais il faut j'ai 7
après ça va être très difficile de
gagner voir il va même se faire bouger
tu adorerais jouer ça avec les Blancs je
le sais alors le kiffe
en plus ma média off faut savoir il joue
toujours la gagne dans le genre de
position ce qui est bien que j'ai un
bizarrement ça a certainement te
surprendre Kevin j'ai un très très bon
score contre ma média enfin en partie
rapide je vais avoir plus trop plus 4
parce que ouais parce qu'il sait il
pousse quoi il est moins bien il pousse
et donc il joue à fond la gagne tout le
temps et moi je joue je joue quoi tu
vois je joue des coups de solides vite
tu as le bon style pour le pour lui et
donc ça marche ça marche bien ça marche
bien contre lui
bizarrement parce qu'il est quand même
bien meilleur que moi en partie rapide
mais j'ai le style pour pour l'embêter
et regarde là qui est D8 par exemple tu
vois je vais le soupçonner à faire un
coup de fou x 8 je connais par cœur
elle joue elle joue très très bien elle
joue assez vite en plus 3,05 contre 4,50
il y a pas de
c'est bien ce qu'elle fait très jolie
partie
il y a du prix du damas 5
on va montrer c'est vrai que ça mettait
la pression quand même a priori on prend
et il y a pas de damakas
mais bon on peut pas lui en vouloir de
jouer un petit coup solide vite
franchement c'est pas c'est pas une
mauvaise stratégie parce que tu prends
prends tactile tada mais tu vas où en
fait tu vas nulle part je suis pas très
inquiet sur ce genre de truc alors je
sais pas trop ce que je fais non plus
mais par exemple je peux revenir et te
forcer forcément à trouver autre chose
moi c'est un truc que je fais ça comme
ça crée ça c'est direct ce que je sais
qu'il y a pas et en fait content il veut
gagner tout le temps
faites suivre votre adversaire c'est de
la bonne méthode
ah merci merci Robinson il a mis le lien
voilà avec toutes les équipes évidemment
l'équipe française qui fera ses débuts
demain l'équipe Blitz stream on a hâte
avec Alexander gretchouco 1 au 2 Maxime
Vacher la grave au trois Maëlle Boyer
jeune ils ont une belle compo et aux
quatre diamanté delté
ou franchement c'est ça être une c'est
une grosse équipe parce qu'on a deux
stars mondiales on a quand même dans
deux premières avec avec Raichu qui est
et Maxime et Maël Boyer qui est très
très fort j'ai joué de nombreux Blitz
avec lui et alors en bullette j'ai
absolument je peux me faire adopter en
Bullet simplement parce qu'il est
extrêmement rapide mais en bide il est
déjà il est déjà aussi très fort donc se
dispute de
Maëlle
Maël très très bonne recrue très bien vu
là
toute l'équipe est très forte et c'est
ça parce que tu es obligé de compenser
tata great show qui est Maxime tu vois
tu es obligé de d'avoir un joint un
petit peu un petit peu moins fort du
coup trois mais là
ils sont pas cherché ils sont pas
cherché bretons par exemple tu vois ils
auraient pu non non ils vont pas
recruter
chez les anciens
ni Laurent tu étais occupé par les
commentaires s'occuper par les
commentaires moi je faisais pas baisser
la moyenne et l'eau assez je crois tu
vois c'est une petite je crois c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai alors c'est
ça que c'est risqué
on prend on aimerait faire ça mais
évidemment il y a Dame des échecs et ça
c'est l'accident c'est l'accident dans
cher Kevin donc comment on fait sur ces
cinq on peut pas laisser sur passer donc
on peut prendre en passant si on a envie
et ça ma foi ça niveau solide c'est dur
de faire mieux ça dur à perdre mais bon
est-ce qu'on pouvait pas jouer aussi
surpris C6 ce qu'on avait le droit de
jouer dame D8 ou pas du tout
surprise C6 vous prend Adam baby à la
fin tu veux dire
on a le droit je vois ton idée je vois
toi je peux faire 8 peut-être en fait
moi j'étais quand même inquiet quoi tu
mets un bon pressing mais regarde si je
veux être plus concret si je fais dame
B8 là je te mets aussi un bon pressing
ouais
mais j'ai le droit de faire ça là par
contre ça faut 7 et là il y a le perpète
au minimum au maximum ouais donc
peut-être dame ton dame B8 intéressant
après tu gardes la paire de fou donc
faut que je me méfie quand même mais bon
c'est pour ça que je suis pas hyper fan
pour être très honnête
cavalier
F3 ça joue ça joue très vite parce que
là il reste plus beaucoup de temps une
40 ouais elle a raison et dame B4
propose une fille un échange malhonnête
faut pas échanger ma jeune ami parce que
là on crée un pion passé potentiellement
pour passer le éloigné et trop de jeu là
elle a joué ça se fait mais pas dans
cette structure là et puis même on a
envie de garder la dame tout à l'heure
t'en parler
les petits les petits coups de Blitz
qu'on aime on est pas mal on se dit pas
mal on vibre avec ce genre de petit coup
là mais bon elle a accès à la cadence on
peut pas lui en vouloir une 40 contre 2
vins elle peut pas se laisser avec 10
secondes chacun contre
[Musique]
et du coup la finale toujours aussi
inintéressante
le petit à cinq est malin parce qu'à
tout moment il a foi assis maintenant tu
as vu le body langage de Shakir là c'est
pas le même qu'au début de la partie il
a il a compris que l'adversité c'était
elle était beaucoup plus coriace que
prévu notre ami
kanyamara si je dis pas de bêtises j'ai
une élève qui a joué contre le choix du
monde jeune des moins de 20 ans assez
récemment et elle avait été brillante
donc faudrait vérifier mais c'était
c'est assez récent c'est de
c'est octobre
dernier donc si elle fait les
championnats du monde c'est que c'est
pas une bleue quand même les
championnats du monde jeûne et que ma
mégaraf en face est très très fort
évidemment 4 jouets oui j'aime bien ce
coup cavalier au 4 sur un échec par là
on replie le Fougerat attention à ce
pion des 6 qui pourrait traîner à
n'importe quel moment
sa position est difficile
les revenus les revenus c'est chaud
c'est très chaud pour ma média robe je
crois qu'il est moins bien honnêtement
0,8 non mais les blancs sont mieux hein
et ouais mais elle joue bien et il a
pris trois la légère là et attention
pour revenir c'est pas si évident il est
moins bien autant maintenant 25 secondes
de moins et demi contre 25 alors que je
peux vous dire que moi j'étais une
fougère
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut faire ouh là là
moi j'essaie 7 qu'est-ce qu'elle veut
faire
perfecter chacun c'est pas illogique
il va faire wash 8 il va vouloir gagner
encore
[Musique]
du coup
elle va elle va ça serait beau qu'elle
fasse
ouais elle veut la nul et la bien raison
non mais regarde là non mais regarde
regarde
pour les blancs je te l'avais dit je
sais toujours la même peur
c'est je joue contre lui c'est pareil
c'est facile d'un B2 d'un B2 il veut
faire roi le
C38 c'est quand même c'est quand même
vraiment pas terrible alors non mesdames
comment tu fais nul cavalier
ce qui nous propose là alors qu'il est
extraordinaire hein ma mégarov là mais
non mais il joue à fond il est comme ça
dame 5 peut-être il va jouer dame 5
par exemple et ouais mais tu as un plan
F6 il prend des risques de folie sacréas
je vous l'avais dit
c'est lui ça je le vois bien parce
qu'elle a été un peu lente sur la
séquence et ouais c'est c'est
l'embrouille qu'est-ce qu'on a raté
l'orange je crois qu'on a raté quelque
chose en plus que dame Bedos c'était
visiblement pas le meilleur coup on va
regarder on va regarder on va regarder
sur wash 8 il fallait jouer dame B2 d'un
B2 le meilleur et sur M6
F6 il dit kc7 cavalier aussi c'est dur
ça c'est dur non et on va voir ce qui a
été joué f63g8 fois 4
on sait maintenant qu'elle a gagné en
plus Laurent on sait qu'elle a gagné
attends ouais mais attends attends faut
pas le dire quand tu le vois
mais c'est comme ça sinon on peut pas
sinon on a le chat en retard alors c'est
soit on a le chat tartare soit on a les
on n'a pas de spoiler dame 5 Fuge 3 il
faut prendre des 5 c'est gagnant pour
les blancs et là je fous prends le 5
incroyable
on va regarder au ralenti là
c'est incroyable ce qui s'est passé
c'est encore égale kg 8 pas mal joué
dame 5 ou perdant fougez trois fous
prends des 5 et là elle avait cavalier
H6 qui gagnait tout simplement pourquoi
parce qu'on gagnait la dame sur Roy f63
G7 on prend sur échec et sur Wii F8 et
bien on fait un petit échec
intermédiaire et on ramasser la dame
elle gagne la dame en deux coups oh là
là les nerfs les nerfs du du du de
chaque film sur cette première partie
c'est qu'on va voir est-ce qu'on irait
pas avoir Samse
sur cette première partie quand même il
s'est fait bouger on va aller voir parce
qu'elle va regarder ça elle est en train
de regarder sa partie et les deg parce
que
forcément c'est une joueuse donc il me
semble qu'elle est plutôt 2002 que 2100
mais bon bref toujours est-il que si
vous voulez
ben
elle le connaît mamedia Rohff c'est une
star mondiale elle fait une énorme
partie et du coup elle se fait un peu
rouler à la fin dans dans le desight un
peu à l'expérience cette première partie
pour m'amélia Rohff le résultat est
logique mais la manière c'était c'était
juste immonde quoi là elle a fait une
super partie
c'était assez incroyable j'essaie de
récupérer l'autre caméra je te laisse
meublé par un stand à la partie de 29 à
l'écran 29 qui n'est pas dans le coin
donc là je peux vraiment pas la voir
alors du coup
et on a Sam Séville qui est noir
des 4 le pion F2 et comment je me tire
de cette histoire
pas si facile mine de rien
donc si je joue
pour 4 D1 je prends dame prend F2 et
chaque suivi roh H1 et d'apprendre H2
donc là il va falloir que je trouve la
meilleure suite pour pour tenir alors je
vais te détecter peut-être qu'il y a eu
des coups je suis vraiment c'est
compliqué
et maintenant il faut résister avec avec
les Blancs parce que on a une position
si vous voulez de foot couleur opposé
avec les dames encore présentes sur
l'échiquier donc il y a une règle c'est
celui qui a le meilleur ROI qui s'en
sort même si on a du retard matériel là
les Noirs ont même pas de retard
matériel et ils ont une pression sur les
cases noires qui sont trouées à cause du
coup G4 et le roi noir ben au final il
est tranquille parce que il y a une
diagonale ouverte noire on n'arrive pas
à profiter de sa faiblesse
au roi noir donc c'est vraiment assez
logique ce que font les blancs ils
essaient d'échanger du matériel mais il
y a quoi sur
mal est-ce que c'est fini fini
ça va pas être facile cette seconde pour
21h on est sous une énorme pression et
on va lâcher F2 dans de mauvaises
conditions tout reprend F2 et il a gagné
et paravient à battu l'enderman ça c'est
une surprise non c'est pas une surprise
il nous reste ouais c'est ça et elle a
perdu une pièce et abandon abandons les
les Wizards qui prennent l'avantage mais
attention et on a cette dernière partie
entre lasavik et
Gadir Gozée 9
qu'est-ce qui se passe il a gagné non
c'est fini c'est fini vous avez une
offre à perdre et ce qu'on disait tu
vois il est sous côté à 25 Laurent il va
être hyper dangereux
grosse grosse impression quand même des
des Wizards parce que là gounina elle
jouait je pense le joueur le plus fort
de l'équipe adverse
mais petit à petit son échiquier va se
rééquilibrer et il est possible que
kanyamara là souffre quand même malgré
son excellente première partie je serai
je serai pas aussi sûr moi je me sens
que tu t'annonces beaucoup là quand même
mais tu vois quand comme elle a pas le
même niveau que les autres joueurs même
si elle a montré un excellent niveau je
suis d'accord avec toi Laurent sur cette
première partie maintenant le risque
c'est d'être un peu deg d'avoir laissé
passer sa chance ou alors elle se dit
c'est du 10 plus de on joue aux échecs
et on verra bien
mais
je suis inquiet pour pour la team des
Pacers
j'ai l'impression je sais pas on va on
va voir en tout cas clairement 3-1 avec
chaque criard qui a qui a failli
vraiment être la première surprise cette
journée il perdait la dame tout
simplement contre une joueuse qui a tout
simplement 500 points de moins que lui
mais redoutable comme tu l'as dit elle a
été monstrueuse elle a été monstrueuse
elle a tenu en haleine et chaque qui a
joué la gagne dans des proportions
mais finalement c'est dur de
c'est dur de discuter avec le résultat
tu vois c'est toujours pareil
que sur un nombre de parties il avait
plus en arnaque voilà il fallait que
l'autre sous pression prouve et il
disait que il allait en gagner plus que
5 sur 10 en continuant de la sorte et il
a sans doute raison en plus mais c'est
hyper quoi
il se dit pas du tout ce qui leur gagne
plus que 5 pour dessiner juste envie de
jouer et il y a juste envie de gagner il
prend des voilà donc en fait ce qu'il en
gagne en moyenne il réfléchit pas comme
ça chaque rire il dit j'ai envie de
gagner je fonce tant pis même si c'est
pas un truc et il fait pas ça que contre
les joueurs moins fort il fait ça quand
tout le monde donc
impressionnant il aime il aime le jeu
tu vois Laurent
parié tu vois que ça laisse finir en
trois matchs et je vous annonce que les
Wizards
auront seulement besoin de 3 matchs pour
venir à bout des
des paysers voilà comment je vois les
choses Laurent ça risque d'accord
de la de la ronde 2
est-ce que chaque rillard va jouer
gouzeynov à mon avis chaque rivière va
voir les blancs
contre merci Thomas d'avoir répondu à
yoga c'est la prochaine Ligue donc
compétition par équipe voilà qui a
démarré hier ces équipes sont engagées 4
joueurs par équipe une féminine
obligatoire dans chaque équipe
moyenne et l'eau à ne pas dépasser
2550 qui est pas mal ça laisse une
certaine marge et il y a des listes par
équipe avec plus de 4 joueurs et selon
les disponibilités
voilà les joueurs qui le souhaitent
jouent ou là on voit que majoritairement
dans les équipes ce sont quasiment tous
des grands maîtres c'est assez rare
qu'il y ait
des mètres il y en a quelques-uns voilà
ça fait n'importe quoi des grosses
donc là Laurent nous fait un petit
réglage on avait dit qu'en technique ça
allait être parfait et jusque-là c'est
pas pendant la partie alors regarde moi
je pense que qu'est-ce qui se passe avec
ce truc de brosse là mais comme quoi
Laurent tu pourrais alors comment tu
pourrais faire ça c'est quoi je vais
fermer je vais fermer ça hop normalement
ça devrait disparaître
et l'idée du petit pansement bleu pour
une prochaine pour cacher le score
pendant le match ouais tu as besoin du
score enfin c'est pénible de l'avoir
juste un petit peu avant non qu'est-ce
que tu en penses
pourquoi le truc c'est qu'elle est
déjà faire
on est pas bien je te le dis moi après
le après le fond vert le fond rose c'est
vrai qu'on avait pas c'est bien Thomas
merci à toi merci
si vous avez des commentaires
sympathiques sur la technique de Laurent
au platine je les relirai sans aucun
état d'âme j'ai pas la rêve pour le
pour le rose je sais pas d'où ça vient
c'est magnifique moi tu peux laisser
c'est cool
bon ça a caché peut-être le nom du
joueur c'est ça
c'est un peu bizarre il y a eu un truc
un peu bizarre Laurent quand même parce
que même au niveau du black eywhite on
voit David et
Denise pour pour la vie que je pense
c'est peut-être les les cames qui sont
mis derrière ou quelque chose comme ça
tu crois non
en tout cas c'est sympa
il y a Laurent qui a dit les pauses
arrête
pour vous servir pas de problème pas de
problème je suis là j'ai compris le truc
je ne toucherai plus jamais ça ok je ne
touche plus à l'autre truc donc trois
pour les 8 heures 16
withoutes
take fraise j'aime pas perdre take
fraise je peux te dire que là c'était
c'était 600 secondes avec moi tu as du
bol attention profites-en profites-en
profites-en que je vois pas dans le truc
parce que on a des très très beau pseudo
je propose nul je n'aime pas perdre
on en a il en a eu un autre mais ils
sont été créés pendant un stream alors
je sais plus qui je sais plus c'est je
propose nul ou j'aime pas perdre mais en
tout cas c'était très très beau
il doit bien te connaître
ouais c'est possible ça
s'investissements
ouais mais je peux pas les mettre là
encore mais t'inquiète je vais
m'organiser mon grand
et je joue Malou qui a été très bon
Laurent David Guetta c'est pas mal
la petite rêve bon pour Laurent platine
très très bon j'ai mal au regard des
résultats voilà take fraise board 1 donc
Shakir va lui dire la quatrième
échiquier des Gordon state pasers David
parviane qui a battu le troisième
échiquier numéro 2
Alexander l'enderman 2016
Lola ce contre Gadir gozenhov et Sam
c'est bien à
Réduit un petit peu le score et
entretenu l'espoir un 4-0 aurait été
difficile donc voilà 3 1 et tu es là à
Laurent quand même il y a quand même
parti aujourd'hui et bien on va rappeler
c'est voilà ça va être un petit rappel
un petit rappel format mon cher yes
c'est important voilà le gros match
aujourd'hui deux gros match aujourd'hui
cadence 10 + 2 donc on a déjà dit c'est
2550 les compositions d'équipe ne
peuvent dépasser une moyenne et l'eau de
550 chaque joueur affronte tous les
joueurs de l'équipe adverse pour un
total de 4 ondes sauf que si au bout de
trois rondes il y a une équipe qui a
atteint les 8 points et demi ben elle
remporte le match si c'est au bout du
quatrième de la quatrième ronde ça
marche pareil 8 et demi c'est clair
c'est le gainage en cas d'égalité 8 8 il
y a les départages et les départages
voilà la technique Laurent parfait ben
les quatrième échiquier s'affrontent en
inversant les couleurs cadence de 3 + 2
ils peuvent encore faire nuls dans ce
cas là les joueurs rejouent couleur
inversée
en cadence de 1 + 2 et voilà après ils
veulent un résultat décisif qui continue
d'inverser si besoin au bout d'un moment
il devrait se décider à
gagner quoi tout à fait et c'est un peu
bizarre qui est pas de système armage et
donc quand même mais on peut jouer
jusqu'à la nuit en fait et nouvelle
question est-ce qu'il y a une équipe
française
qui rentre en jeu et on nous a donné
toute l'équipe avec mvl griffe shook
on a aussi my Boyer et de l'idée
tout à fait et donc j'ai réduit encore
un petit peu ça sature un peu parfois ça
le fait assez pénible c'est l'histoire
de son on va regarder j'ai récupéré tout
de suite les caméras sous vos yeux
ébahis pendant que tu nous choisis une
partie il y a Florent herbe qui m'a
régalé avec c'est qui le logo Licorne et
ça nous obligerait à connaître tous les
logos
et du coup tout à l'heure il y a
Robinson qui est intelligemment ami tous
les descriptifs d'équipe dans le chat et
si j'avais été bon je l'aurais ouvert
dans un nouvel onglet pour pouvoir
répondre facilement à toutes les
questions et je le fais
donc chaque toit voir les blancs contre
à mon avis vous avez une offre donc je
vais aller prendre cousinov ce qu'on va
voir si tête fraise
ça bosse à la pause je pense qu'on a une
belle partie là entre gosener va voir
les blancs qui va avoir les blancs c'est
ça la question
alors il est peut-être deux licornes
mais en tout cas il y a une licorne
c'est les Gotham Knights avec avec
[Musique]
Naka qui dit pas de bêtises
online car Wana Naka évidemment Magnus
Carson il y a deux il y a deux il y a
deux licornes donc ça dépend de quelle
licorne tu parles voilà c'est ça c'est
beau l'histoire des licornes c'était une
très très bonne question parce qu'il y a
une autre Licorne qui est emmené par
goût cache échancland voilà les
unicornes roster voilà donc
t-il
équipe NBA voilà avec les petits logos
on va voir ne rigole pas et alors vous
avez une offre c'est pas c'est pas un
décodeur non non on n'a pas pas trop
envie de de lui faire des petites
blagounettes sur sa technique à
goussain-nov ah non
qu'elle est blanc en fait contre
Alexander lenderman que je vais trouver
de ce pas
ok bon je te laisse un début goût et
Beach avec une sorte d'ongleteuse et
associée à ce petit ce petit E3 on va
peut-être B3 arrivée bah non ça
transposer donc là on est plutôt dans
les dans les mérons et puis chez banane
co avec A6 une semi avec E6 A6 voilà
avec l'idée B5 pour demander aux blancs
de se décider sur la
la tension centrale puisque là vous
savez que normalement dans ces positions
là D5 prend C4 ça donne le centre on va
jouer avec C5 et là on transpose encore
donc c'est un schéma un peu hybride qui
va jouer ici qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
et du coup je suis comme vous le voyez
Laurent est il a trouvé que je disais un
petit peu n'importe quoi donc il m'a
enlevé l'échiquets
je te raconte pas j'ai fait une boulette
de chez boulette c'est fermé Laurent
alors
ah j'ai dit en plus je m'étais juré
depuis toucher à ce truc bon mais je
vous inquiétez pas je retrouve ça tout
de suite tu peux parler de la partie
s'il te plaît les cames on voit que
c'est un petit peu galère donc Laurent
nous fait vraiment des petits réglages
sur mesure à la mano et des fois bah
arrive des des petits des petits bugs
celui-là est pas mal en tout cas la
scène elle est nickel mais on a plus les
chiquer vous le voyez mais arrête pas
s'il te plaît ça suffit
à l'aide des deux joueurs qui sont
souriants imaginez qui se passe avec
petit plus blanc on va pouvoir sans
doute jouer pour le pion isolé ça
pourrait être intéressant de prendre du
cavalier pour isoler pion des 5 vous
prend des cartes sauvegarde aussi mais
qui avait prendre des cartes avec plus
de deux sens et on va travailler
vraisemblablement autour du pion isolé
oh non
un véritable régal
je suis désolé cette partie
il y a les gens disparu
[Rires]
alors j'ai voulu faire un truc
intelligent mais c'était pas visiblement
c'était pas brillant
et du coup on retrouve la partie on a
perdu un petit peu Mamette qui s'est
décalé Laurent pour te faire du mal ah
ouais terrible
c'est au début de partie on est toujours
toujours un petit peu mais je te laisse
ouais on a on laisse le plus résolu
c'est une position théorique on va
travailler le pion isolé on a un
problème c'est le foussen il va falloir
le gérer est-ce qu'on peut jouer E4
facilement c'est pas dit il peut y avoir
des fousser 5 D4
en tout cas voilà on a un petit plus un
petit plus blanc c'est connu c'est connu
cette position je crois que c'est
galfunnel dans un match champion du
monde où un ordre avait montré comment
régler tous les problèmes dans cette
ligne vous êtes d'ailleurs je pense pas
que c'est faux sept mais bon l'enderman
il est quand même assez bien préparé
c'est son truc très solide et
c'était plus naturel de jouer fou c'est
ça que Laurent
moi je crois tu sais naturel ou pas
naturel en fait en vrai c'est hyper
concret un ce genre de trucs faut
analyser avant et ce qu'on dit
normalement c'est qu'on met un peu la
pression quand on a un pion isolé on
essaie d'avoir les belles pièces donc
fous c'est 5 avec plus de sens moi qui
ne connais pas la position je connais
bien les principes d'option isolés mais
pas la position la position réellement
du coup j'étais très tenté par
pousser cinq d'accord
non mais bon c'est l'enfer
je suis obligé tu vois alors parce que
je pense que si j'étais à la technique
ça me
tirer l'histoire non mais parce qu'en
fait dans le zoom c'est pas du tout de
mon je sais pas ce qui se passe dans le
zoom mais bon
il va falloir qu'il trouve une autre
solution parce que c'est pas possible
dès que
dès que l'orange je vois il y a un petit
qui a un petit bug de caméra en fait je
te regarde et je vois ta tête et
franchement à chaque fois je te je te
vois et ça me fait forcément sourire et
je suis pas le seul je sais que dans le
chat vous régalez bien aussi de ces
petits phénomènes et du coup bah je
comprends moi je fais comme le chat
salut Hugo chef
salut
salut à tous ouais
des gens ah ouais je peux peut-être
épingler en fait
t'express en petite forme quand tu
techniques oui alors François François
Jacques disons mais ils ont du bol je
sais pas modo franchement c'est super je
suis d'accord avec François pour
l'instant il avait très très bien
démarré mais il a démarré un peu au
dessus de son niveau et vous savez dans
ce cas-là quand une équipe surjoue ou
quand un technicien sur technique bah
c'est pareil au bout d'un moment je vais
quand même expliquer à notre ami que au
Binky qui nous demande sur zoom tu peux
épingler des gens et alors il bouge plus
mais le problème c'est que j'ai capture
pas sur zoom parce que c'est pas moi qui
fait ça et j'ai capture sur Youtube et
oui imagine la technique donc je peux
pas les épingler malheureusement
qu'est-ce que je vous dise mais bon on
va retourner aux échecs là ça a l'air
d'être à peu près stable à moins que tu
as fait un petit tour des stades mon
petit Kevin et bien non non en plus
c'est assez logique de le faire en tout
cas de normal on va essayer de bloquer
le pion isolé on avait dit hein on se
développe on bloque et on presse le pion
en essayant d'échanger
bah le le foot case noire des des noirs
on laisse à l'adversaire les pièces qui
peuvent être esclaves du pion isolé
particulièrement le fou aussi on va le
laisser tout le temps comme ça on pourra
massacrer le pion isolé et toutes les
pièces adverses vont être à la défense
de ce pion alors ouais tout à fait je
vais aller faire la manif tu sais il y a
une manif demain moi je veux la retraite
à
42 ans voilà
franchement c'est la pénibilité je
trouve que la pénibilité le seul job qui
bouge toutes les 10 secondes pour les
nerfs tu sais c'est dur
ici il veut faire faux 5 et Tours C8 on
va voir on va voir on va voir l'enderman
il a bien raison
on peut aussi envisager des dames C7
pour chatouillage de comme tu le disais
et en fait donc tu te disais pas mais il
faut jouer actif on est d'accord on est
d'accord on va c'est quoi on va faire un
petit tour des stades mais pas un petit
tour des caméras voilà bah oui
en plus regarde chaque Hélène normal
franchement pour l'occasion et tout là
ils sont fait tout beau alors il y a un
moment distant de sa caméra et un
Enderman vraiment très présent au niveau
de la cam voilà
alors on va voir
notre ami cagnard
triche face à part Aviane et on a une
position de si c'est une classique pour
pour les experts mcilienne donc
clairement à double tranchant pas à
Vienne
donc il met la pression ouais on met la
pression sur le petit pion de case
blanche
exact et MP3 le petit guili le petit
gilet est-ce qu'elle serait pas déjà et
dans le dur dans les cordes voyez un
deux pièces mineures qui peuvent aller
sur les cases blanches donc vous voyez
le grand mètre par Aviane il travaille
sur casse blanche et il y a même les
pièces lourdes qui peuvent arriver mais
en tout cas il pourrait amener le
cavalière en E24 e2f4 et faire mal aussi
par ce biais là au pion E6 plus d'un
match 3 c'est trop c'est trop ça va
s'écrouler on sent on sent que ça va
être un point là pour pour les vitof
Wizards on va voir en plus et on se
grand qu'il y a damage 3 et fou aussi
donc du coup malheureusement ça ne va
pas du tout
voilà et là il y aurait des jackpot et
on va voir c'est bien un qui est
peut-être le meilleur finalement qui
pourrait porter à lui tout seul cette
équipe mais le problème c'est qu'on peut
pas être complètement tout seul non plus
une catalane
et voilà cette petite finale il a 10
minutes 12 hein tu as vu il prend ça au
sérieux il a plus de temps maintenant
qu'au début de la partie
vous voyez la domination la Catalane
c'est la domination du Fou j'ai deux
qu'on ne le foutait 8 et il a fait des
concessions pour obtenir cela avec une
structure bizarre oh oui mais avoir le
pion c'est trois c'est souvent une bonne
nouvelle Laurent pour m'aide à toi en B1
alors ce qui m'étonne un petit peu et tu
vas peut-être me l'expliquer j'aurais
mis ma tour en B1 et la tour F en D1 et
il a fait l'inverse il reste sur la
colonne F alors que on tape finalement
un peu sur du dur ça ça m'étonne un
petit peu ce que Laurent tu peux nous
expliquer cette décision qui me choque
un petit peu alors
c'est c'est concret je sais pas toi bien
peut-être pour C7 suite cahier des 7
tours B8 B6 est à
tour finalement à l'air un peu bête
alors que ici elle peut être pas mal et
en F on sait jamais il peut avoir par
exemple j'ai l'impression qu'après toi
D1 c'est qu'on crée aussi je m'inscris
au 5 là déjà tu vois sur pion j'ai
tourné 8 ce qui serait pas c'est
vraiment le côté concret avec cavalier
E5 ah ouais évidemment parce que tu as
envie de mettre comme tu le dis hein tu
as envie de mettre ta ta tour sur la
colonne B mais après il y a aussi le
problème des échecs c'est que c'est pas
on peut pas les grands principes c'est
bien beau mais à un moment où ça devient
quand même assez concret et c'est 4 3 F2
ce qui est important je pense à
transmettre ici c'est de voir que le
fousset 8 c'est le problème majeur mais
les Noirs vont essayer de se débarrasser
de cette problématique là donc on a
envie de jouer vite et fort avec les
Blancs donc d'où le tour d'un menace
concrète alors portish 2 qui nous dit
les noms sont faux en fait il aurait
pouvoir raison mais en fait non ce sont
les ce sont les caméras qui sont fausses
les noms ne peuvent pas être faux c'est
pas ça n'arrive pas parce qu'ils sont
ils sont raccordés à l'échiquier donc
nous en fait pas c'est juste les caméras
là je peux pas franchement
c'est une galère je peux pas changer à
chaque fois qu'on on bouge d'échiquier
honnêtement c'est c'est juste injouable
on va aller voir la dernière partie de
cette ronde avec ventina gounina qui a
les
Noirs contre goûté 9 ouh là là ça joue
ça joue cette cette ligne de la
carrocane dont on a parlé
très très bien en fait là pour le coup
c'est une partie de référence de Heavy
je pense à le thème fouder 2 je pense
que c'est ça qui a été joué fou des deux
c'est un des
très bon système Laurent avec F4 F5
c'est la super idée que yvitch avait
joué contre blueborne dans la base de
données
tu prévois un retour à la compète ou
quoi j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien
Laurent mais c'est pas du tout pour ça
c'est parce que bah tu sais bah comme
j'entraîne quand même voilà et du coup
j'aime bien regarder la théorie j'aime
bien regarder la théorie alors je
travaille pas avec Magnus comme toi mais
voilà j'ai mes petits élèves on fait nos
petits trucs on regarde et c'est Mathieu
Mathieu cornette qui est calé en théorie
champion de France 2016 Mathieu qui qui
vient régulièrement sur chess com faire
des commentaires il avait joué une très
très jolie partie soit contre Google
soit contre Prague un des deux il
l'avait bien massacré dans cette
variante
le gain malheureusement
salut amicale Mathieu cornette
évidemment
MG4 et ouais c'est vrai que ça craint là
le roi est déchiré puis on a rien de
bien dans cette position
tomate quoi on a rien de bien ça peut
attention attention par
exempleina bravo
après ça le problème ah si ça me Lassure
prend en fait donc on peut pas prendre
ici parce qu'on fait ça si on prend ici
c'est pas max exactement mais bon
on peut se faire enfermer la dame G3 au
minimum admettons un truc comme ça tu
bouges le roi je t'encaisse ici je vais
encaisser ici et j'ai du matériel en
place donc ça c'est ça serait pas
terrible et on menace quand même de
prendre donc il faut quand même qu'il
réagissent vous avez une offre
clairement
tout à fait
alors
c'est Fontenoy 56 bonjour à tous sur le
chat twitch n'hésitez pas à vous venez
poser des questions proposez des coups
venez nous parler
facile
qu'à 5 c'est extrêmement joli et attaqué
défense en même temps bien sûr
et beaucoup plus douteux dans ma chambre
de consolation mais tu auras la guerre
plus et évidemment évidemment ensuite
tout ici bonjour aimerait Aymeric Martin
sur la chaîne Youtube de
cheesecom n'hésitez pas attends
excuse-moi je réponds à la question
ouais vous savez quand notre team Blitz
joue oui c'est demain et ensuite tout le
monde ensuite tous les matchs sur sur
cheesecom FR
et puis je me demandais pourquoi la
jauge indiquais égalité dans la position
que tu avais là après dans machin
cavalier prend F4 vous prend puis on
prend il y a pas de fou C4 ici pour
taper le Pione F7 et menacer 6 ah ouais
mais toujours
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais alors pour
faire nul faut faire ça
on asper on doit faire ranger 7 et
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y avait sur fou C4
il faut jeter H5 c'est le meilleur coup
ici donc damage 5 et prend F4 le
meilleur coup de caviage 5 et sur tous
ces quatre il y avait
dans ma fuite et dames G7 bon des coups
d'ordi de repli toujours
toujours compliqué alors on va revenir
peut-être vers chaque criard contre
contre l'enderman c'est peut-être pas la
partie la plus excitante tu me diras
pour
un petit pressing depuis isolé c'est
intéressant de voir si si Mamette va
réussir à passer
en général ça suffit pas surtout quand
les Noirs ont la colonne comme ça
et le roi un petit peu affaibli quand
même on a donné des tu vois tu as joué
H4 tu es un petit peu lui ton roi le fou
qui va revenir en G6 ça paraît très très
solide pour la Norman on conteste la
colonne évidemment faut que si ça serait
une enfilade mais on a le petit tour
principe échec qui est très important
une bonne chose sans doute d'éliminer
les pièces lourdes dans ce type de
position pour les Noirs il devrait pas
il ne devrait pas trop souffrir
il jouera à y jouer chèque et cavalier
F6 coupure landerman archi solide dans
cette partie F3 chaque il rigole pas tu
veux faire cavaler au 4
il va remettre certainement le fond F1
mais attention attention
ça existe au pire j'ai cavalier 2 qui
est pas trop compromettant ouais c'est
vrai
tout à fait du coup ça reste très solide
attention les joueurs même dans les
positions stratégiques qui trouvent les
coups d'amélioration très rapidement
c'est ce qui va faire l'enderman dans
cette position il va rien faire il y a
tout simplement attendre
de rien faire dans certaines positions
je sais pas non je dis pas je dis pas
qu'il faut rien faire je dis que
l'enderman va c'est ton style dans les
positions défensives je le sais et c'est
non mais c'est pas facile de rien faire
aux échecs c'est assez intéressant en
fait comme conseil c'est mais c'est pas
un conseil c'est ce que j'adore ce je
connais les joueurs je connais le normal
déjà qu'il aime pas jouer active alors
en plus il y a une position où tu peux
ne pas jouer actif donc il va il va
jouer passivement il faut 4 ça ne me
laisse absolument rien donc on peut
jouer fou 2 tranquillement et ensuite il
va reculer voyez blenderman c'est pas du
style à balancer ses pions de la dame et
faire des gros B5 parce que ça
affaiblirait donc les pions de les pions
de reculent pas donc quand vous prenez
une décision avec vos pions
très clairement ce sont des décisions
compromettantes
donc à éviter donc chaque il veut mettre
son cavalier en C3 en F4 il veut taper
le pion des 5 mais comment le fouet F1
va réussir à le faire
il va sans doute pousser un jour les
pions mais c'est pas si facile pour
l'instant sur G4 faux projet 4 et 3 vous
êtes en contrôle est-ce qu'on je crois
qu'il y a un moment il faut changer
d'améliore les pièces il améliore les
pièces il va essayer de passer après
aucun risque pour pour les blancs donc
on peut jouer ça de manière très
tranquille attention t'inquiète pas
t'inquiète pas il va en prendre des
risques à chaque fois
on l'a vu dans la partie précédente il
arrive pas à gagner il peut il peut tout
tenter et on a toujours pas de résultats
dans cette ronde qui est serré on fait
on fait un petit tour bon là chacun il
va pousser ouais pas des caméras les
caméras restent donc regardez le nom des
joueurs là on garde ici on avait gros
avantage blanc après fou B3 et le
éventuel damage 3 elle a pas réussi à oh
mais il a peur de plus ça paraviane et
il menace
et à finir plus vite cette partie on va
voir
elle souffre kanyamara là mais elle joue
très bien parce qu'elle joue des forts
grands maîtres donc c'est pas évident
pour elle elle a failli battre mamedia
offre première ronde qui aurait été très
très belle exploit et on va aller
regarder 21 qui comme souvent ah quand
même la partie la plus elle a un style
très dynamique qui plaît aux femmes tout
simplement parce que
ça donne toujours des parties
au minimum à rebondissement toujours pas
sa caméra donc on va pas pouvoir
la mettre à la caméra à la 4 28 contre
2,50 et en plus elle joue sans complexe
avec beaucoup de temps à la pendule il y
a eu le meilleur coup trouvé par Gadir
gozeynov mais ça lui a coûté quelques
minutes à la pendule et le jour où fuite
ma foi j'aime bien ouais vite moi
pourquoi pas
quelque chose pour éviter de se faire
prendre un FC sur échec dans les
variantes chaudes
et maintenant on peut se demander
comment finir le taf
avec les Blancs
on a envie de tout ça qui est faire du
cavalier prend F6 du Fou prang G5 mais
attention de pas faire n'importe quoi et
sans flammé
ouais ça c'est vrai Hero Saito merci
pour tous vos commentaires un truc très
cool dans cette prochaine cycle c'est
qu'on voit beaucoup plus de parties
mixte entre mes femmes trop souvent les
femmes jouent juste entre elles et ça
c'est vrai c'est un peu papa une volonté
finalement mais là c'est le système qui
fait un peu ça ou c'est toi féminin où
on peut gagner des titres finalement
comme les grands prix voilà il y a un
cycle de championnats du monde et donc
ça incite évidemment les femmes à jouer
entre elles et donc là cette compétition
est mixte et voilà on n'a pas on n'a pas
les femmes qui jouent contre elles et
donc voilà chacun joue contre tout le
monde joue contre tout le monde et ça
permet par exemple ça permet à malboyer
ça se trouve peut-être comme elle boitée
dans un match il va jouer comme Magnus
Carson tout simplement donc ça ça peut
être
ou d'élementé contre manuscrit
va jouer comme manuscrit donc voilà ça
belle compet
idée assez sympathique je sais pas si
elle marche d'un F3 avec l'idée de faire
de faire j'ai trois faites d'un F3 je
dégage le cavalier G6 et je fais G3 et
pour faire H4
c'était peut-être
elle est compliquée cette position je
sais pas trop ce qu'il faut faire B4
j'ai pas la réfe pas compris ouais c'est
bizarre c'est en mode il dit en gros ce
qu'il dit c'est que
ben je peux faire ce que je veux je fais
ce que je veux c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
qui est ce qui est vrai mais d'un F3
menaces concrètement le cavalier G6
suivi de G3 je voyais pas comment on
jouer cette d'ailleurs toujours
d'actualité
de faire un petit je vais faire un petit
cadeau 7 mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
mal
je sais pas j'essaie de faire un truc
l'idée c'était agh4 quoi c'est ça que je
voulais faire agh4 pour tout dégommer
que j'ai envie d'aller chercher le roi
ça commence à être chaud ouais
intéressant il y a plein mais lui en
fait il est en train de il est en train
de dire en gros ben je te fais B4 C4
c'est 5 et puis je vais te prendre un F6
de progresser à l'aile dame et alléluia
on va aller voir ça tout de suite et il
est oh il y a tout donné
il y a tout donné Enderman
la petite combinette dame de qui est vu
évidemment par les deux joueurs
et de plus en plus pour chaque rillard
ça va être gagné
ça va être gagné pour chacun de plus
c'était quoi la gaffe on sait pas on va
on va regarder quand même
il s'est fait il s'est fait bouger petit
à petit
ça ça fait mal ok donc c'est c'est
terminé on va voir allez la partie de
Gozée nov qui est quand même très très
marrante on laisse quand même des
damages de échec toujours ça pourquoi
pas
comme position
ça sent je crois que tu vas avoir raison
parce que là et parviennent à battu
tricha
kanyamara donc ça fait un très très gros
score regarder 4 ans avec ma meilleure
offre qui est gagnant
lasavik sévi on sait pas trop mais ça
ferait déjà 5 ans et il a gagné chaque
alarme et que vous avez une offre
faudrait faut absolument qu'il gagne
pour essayer de ouh là c'est maths ah
non je suppose
voilà là ça sent mauvais
c'est fini là je crois on va voir elle a
joué cavalier 4
ok qu'est-ce qui se passe après cavalier
F4 et chaque créateur qui se lève
cavalier F4
est-ce qu'il va il va prendre non il
prend du cavalier voilà ça c'est un peu
étonnant alors peut-être
alors peut-être qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
coup on fait de me prendre des canons
d'âme prend des quatre il y a
trois donc on doit on doit reprendre
clairement si laser ne perd pas
et bien il fallait faire quoi je sais
pas certainement
[Musique]
ouais certainement faire ça parce que la
jauge aime pas du tout peut-être quelque
chose comme ça je sais pas et attaquer
ici c'est vrai que ça mettait
les questions
retour direct puis on prend F4 et d'un
prunch 4 et là les carottes sont cuites
j'ai l'impression
le roi
on va être obligé de faire un coup droit
en G7
c'est important ce point là
je crois qu'il y a pas trop de ce qu'on
pourrait aller voir peut-être lasavik
pour voir s'il arrive à
on était dans cette position avec un
petit pressing blanc est-ce que le
pressing a continué ça continue mais
apparemment c'est nul voilà là il
devrait pas perdre avec les Noirs c'est
très solide il vient de donner son
cavalier
mais pour récupérer c'est peut-être un
cavalier qui avait en D6 ou un pion je
sais pas un pion serait logique mais
maintenant va y avoir
des crémage naturel dans cette pose
faire peut-être un petit peu
non pas un petit peu gaffe en fait
peut-être qu'il faut faire un petit peu
attention pour pas se faire avoir
on fait une assez facilement avec des
règles des règles d'opposition mais
attention il faut pas faire avoir au
niveau des tempos de de réserve
on aura toujours
à l'image je vais essayer de retrouver
notre ami
laservic mais quand il a déchiré sa
finale malheureusement
la vie qui apparemment au niveau de la
jauge mais c'était pas si facile de
trouver il fallait avoir la même type de
position
de la tête alors c'était là c'était nul
encore d'après la jauge
donc
bien sûr H5 1 peut-être H5 avec un F5
dans le meilleur conditions
si tu fais ce F5 je pense que tu vas te
faire enfermer en fait j'ai pas le temps
de ouais c'est ça terrible je te
souhaite et là je te fais ça
3G 2
e6h3 on va le montrer
non c'était pas facile du tout qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé il a fait F5 non il y a
eu apparemment donc il était gagnant
vous voyez pour les deux joueurs
toujours gagnant et le 3 et n'est pas
bon
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il va pester
H4 est une gaffe ah oui
c'est bizarre
oh là là
et la roue F3 il avait aussi gagné voilà
c'était la festival de Bourges
c'est très du difficile à jouer et là ça
aurait remis quand même peut-être les
Pacers dans le match et maintenant ils
ont encore perdu le minimat donc ça fait
cher
quel écart pour laservie qui s'en sort
bien et les vitov Chase Wizard
ils perd directement après ils ont
encore un petit un petit espoir un petit
matelas alors contre qui joue chaque
criard à la prochaine il va jouer il va
jouer le numéro 2 de l'équipe c'est ça
peut-être la chance donc ça va être
goûté une offre c'est ça vous avez une
offre qui a les blancs donc chaque
arrière aura les blancs a priori donc
moi je dis ça pour les caméras tu sais
le reste bien sûr
il est bien bien entamé
alors c'est pas fini c'est jamais fini
mais c'est vrai que ouais effectivement
je suis je suis d'accord avec ça jamais
fini mais on va se retrouver
vraisemblablement avec 7 et demi 8 ou 8
et demi je vois pas mettre moins de deux
points avec avec ma média Rohff qui est
quand même présent par aviande c'est
fort ouais ils sont enfin ils ont
vraiment une grosse équipe en allemand
très très grosse équipe clairement
clairement est-ce que on va faire un
petit break évidemment mais est-ce que
avant tu nous parles pas de la grande
nouvelle que j'ai reçu par mail c'est ce
matin j'étais hyper inquiet je vois mail
de Kevin bonjour tu l'avais reçu le
matin
et donc j'ai la trouille aujourd'hui
j'ai jamais eu la trouille de ma vie
mais aujourd'hui j'ai la trouille je me
suis dit mais quand il va me demander
encore
c'est vraiment c'est la dernière minute
certaines personnes ont déjà reçu ce
mail pour la plateforme de cours en
ligne que j'ai mis en place voilà et du
coup ben je vous remettrai comment ça
marche comme à chaque fois
comment ça marche tu veux savoir comment
ça marche
sur la plateforme déjà ils ont un cadeau
à l'inscription un cadeau de pack vidéo
pour choisir leurs ouvertures aux échecs
déjà ça c'est une bonne nouvelle et
derrière en plus de cela quand
ils sont inscrits sur la plateforme ils
ont accès à la bibliothèque qui leur
permet d'acheter d'acheter les vidéos
tout simplement
il y a pour l'instant on va dire trois
packs en vente et chaque mois il y en
aura en plus puis après je ferai des
collaborations avec avec des forts
joueurs voilà
c'est quoi ton budget ah bah ça va être
non mais ça va être énorme ça va être
astronomique de toi c'est normal ça
c'est quand tu fais des parcs avec les
stars faut avoir un gros budget
mon cher Kévin il faut pas que je donne
mon prix en premier parce que sinon tu
vas en profiter tu vas me dire c'est
plus je la connais cette histoire tout
ce que tu vas dire
attention je suis très je suis très dur
à négo
j'imagine j'imagine l'expérience
l'expérience
donc c'est quoi le lien
chercher votre cadeau voilà aller
chercher votre cadeau moi aussi j'ai
droit aux cadeaux ou pas bien sûr tu bah
tu peux aller voir voilà comme ça si si
ça te plaît tu pourras recommander la
plateforme quand même Laurent
n'hésitez pas à en faire autant Kevin
qui a une expérience assez longue
d'entraîneur et assez longue et beaucoup
de succès vu que ça vient les stages
sont toujours remplis moi ce que je vois
les gens sont ravis à chaque fois donc
voilà n'hésitez pas c'est quoi Wim nous
dit Kenzo Zorro c'est mettre
international féminin woman était à
cheval Master et winsky avait répondu
d'accord donc parfait écoute mon cher
Kevin on va faire une petite pause je
vous mets la musique alors attention
pour les gens
la musique attention attention la
musique on baisse un petit peu alors
j'ai j'ai essayé de travailler le la
différence de son mais je ne garantis
pas c'était exprès c'est ça tout se fait
un petit peu vous voyez on sait pas
c'est familial je veux pas de plainte
après allez à tout de suite
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour léger
contre-temps et j'ai problème au son
est-ce qu'on t'entend bien Kevin moi je
suis un peu inquiet vas-y parle moi je
suis parfait je t'entends très bien en
tout cas Laurent et après je sais pas
j'espère que l'on entend et du coup
est-ce que tu peux reconnaître
l'ouverture de chacun veut dire Rohff
c'est aller très très vite oh là là
du coup normalement vous savez on
regarde les squelettes d'option mais là
c'est si j'ai pas beaucoup d'indices
malheureusement
c'est un des trucs l'espagnoles ouverte
et j'en vois beaucoup au niveau mais
autant en espagnol fermé bien sûr c'est
facile à reconnaître je manquais depuis
je manquais depuis
une Espagnole dite
j'ai passé du temps à essayer de trouver
un avantage
ouais jusque là tu vois j'avais d'accord
des cartes hop non mais bon c'est trop
trop loin trop loin pour moi et cette
petite finale où on essaye de pousser
gentiment avec les blancs mais on arrive
jamais à rien donc qui décide
entre guillemets de pas prendre de
risques
mais bon la situation du match à mon
avis
oui
donc bonne config en fait pour vous
ils sont copains ils sont copains
en fait d'accord
enfin
ils sont ouais à mon avis ça va faire
nul voilà
gentiment quoi ouais donc on va passer
sur un autre échec un petit tour
de des caméras on a bien compris que
Laurent et voulait pas en entendre
parler
mais il fait déjà beaucoup alors
aujourd'hui alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est pas ravial contre ça me sévient en
fait c'est ça qui paraviane vient de pas
perdre contre ça me séviants ils sont
mal les paysers donc ça me fait Vian est
là du coup je vais quand même les mettre
en parce que je sens que cette partie en
train de riz tu sais quoi j'ai
appréciement moi mon avis elle est finie
elle est finie bientôt
et d'ailleurs tu sais quoi
nul nul nul nul
déjà je suis mauvaise langue
c'est un peu ce
bon ouais c'est bizarre de faire nul là
bon pas trop d'intérêt c'est un peu
dommage ouais mais entre les certaines
nations il y a toujours un
pack de non-agression oui et puis en
plus soit pas forcément d'ailleurs pas
forcément tu vois
tu vois arranger c'est juste c'est un
peu tacite tu vois
c'est ils vont pas ils vont pas se faire
de mal quoi bon c'est regrettable mais
c'est comme ça
je t'envoie parviennent sourire à la
caméra non les gens ne le voit pas les
gens pour l'instant il va arriver il va
arriver il va arriver
donc qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire
un petit peu
précisé mais d'où n'hésitent pas à nous
dire quel est le micro qui sature est-ce
que c'est le mien est-ce que c'est celui
de Laurent voilà comme ça on va être on
va être très bien sur ce sujet là
alors il s'est barré ça me sévit
ant
on va jouer sur les cases dans cette
partie
ça me séviant il veut un petit pressing
après faudra toujours attention dans ses
positions là l'idée B5 qui peut qui peut
survenir surtout avec une dame en B3
voilà on a récupéré les deux joueurs
est-ce que d'ailleurs je peux faire
baisser 5 c'est parti c'est jouer
ravians il relève le défi ça l'air
excellent dans cette position ça a l'air
plutôt agréable pour les Noirs j'aime
bien les noirs
mais c'est pas suffisant il y a une
emprise noire sur sur l'elda maintenant
alors ça reste raisonnable quand même
pour les blancs parce que finalement
d'un MC2 était une belle solution je
trouve sur B4 on va venir là bon
effectivement ça casse pas des ça casse
pas trois pattes à un canard pour les
blancs mais ça reste jouable et ça me
Servian qui est clairement il y a 6 3
déjà peut-être qu'on va pas voir le
dernier set c'est vraiment pas sûr ta
prédiction pourrait se révéler tout à
fait exact peut-être même s'il y a 8
vous voyez il faudrait un 4-0 ce qui est
archi improbable sur le dernier match
alors qu'on a pas gagné
pas gagné en 7 ou même si ils font un et
demi
quoi il faut il faut absolument que les
pays sœurs gagnent gagnent ce match là
et de façon assez sèche pour se laisser
des chances dans le dernier match on va
aller voir à pas de vélo qui nous
demandent des belles parties aujourd'hui
et ouais il y a
cany-marla qui est pas la caméra qui est
noir contre la zavie qui nous a fait une
superbe partie quand le chakra armée des
Rohff à la première mais malheureusement
malheureusement la pas su conclure dans
les dernières secondes c'est toujours
c'est toujours le problème live joue une
catalan face à laservie qui aura à cœur
d'apporter
sa pierre à l'édifice des des levitov
Chase Wizards et voilà qui va jouer C4
peut-être des cavaliers à 5 des faux 3
alors c'est final travailler et un petit
plus c'est un petit plus exactement
exactement ça va être compliqué
j'ai mangé ce midi
tu as mangé avec un padelo d'accord
c'est ça nous dit le tunes 1 quand
Laurent s'excite pas vous seriez presque
normalisé c'est-à-dire
le micro le micro qui sature il y a deux
micros donc dis-nous le micro je pense
que c'est toi alors au vu de ce qui a
écrit le tunes donc je mets moins fort
alors je baisse encore
je baisse le son c'est pas tant que tu
es fort mais c'est vrai que quand tu
montes quand tu montes plus haut là ça
sature je pense que c'est quelque chose
comme ça ouais j'ai ma voix ma voix
change qu'est-ce que vous voulez j'ai
déjà j'ai des émotions donc j'essaye de
faire de faire au mieux pour contrôler
mes émotions
allez on va aller voir
on va aller voir Valentina gounina
[Musique]
voilà ça va être long en tout cas
qui joue contre l'enderman et l'enderman
il doit aussi absolument gagner
maintenant c'est c'est mustwin dans
toutes les parties pour les Garden State
spacer on a une mère en comme tout à
l'heure avec ce pion isolé qui lui avait
pas porté bonheur mais bon ça joue c'est
des positions quand il reste pas mal de
matériel on peut gagner avec les Noirs
clairement tout à fait
on peut imaginer que laserait cette
partie même si la pas encore et du coup
il faut vraiment que ça me séviant et
Hélène derman gagne sinon ils sont hors
jeu
alors on va aller on va revenir on va
revenir chez Samse vient pas vient de
qui est quand même la partie la partie
phare de cette ronde avec Sam qui a les
blancs
et ma foi est paraviane qui est très
proche de la caméra
ça on peut
est-ce qu'on joue
F5 E4 en force où est-ce qu'on échange
tout pour
simplifier la position
c'est la question qui doit être en train
de se poser mais bon c'est ton jamais ce
genre de truc ça peut être moins bien
pour les peut-être un BK voilà qui
pourrait avec elle aussi après il y a 4
à regarder toujours pareil bien sûr
ou alors l'autre option que tu as donné
c'est de faire F5 et effectivement on
essaye de fermer tout ça sur foug2
on fait 4
ça ferme le fou G2
ça pose une question plus OK et 5
très intéressant
comment on va faire ici
ouais merci le tout c'est pas évident à
gérer je te le confirme il y a des gros
progrès là quand même je crois par
rapport à hier
on sent la montée en puissance alors
ouais demain le micro marchera
parfaitement faut que je fasse d'autres
tests alors je sais pas il y a un truc à
ces histoires de micro toujours
compliqué
c'est pas évident et ces vidéos bon je
crois qu'il y aura pas tellement de
problèmes au niveau de la vidéo ça va
être ça va être compliqué je crois
enfin on y travaille la vidéo on n'est
pas trop mal
donc il a joué il a choisi de faire et
tout va bien finalement joué par sable
et pas bien
du tout
qui est terrible
on peut peut-être
toi
jouer pour pousser trois quelque chose
comme ça mais il faut faire gaffe
oui
faut faire ce qu'il est comestible dans
certains cas ou non avec des idées de
fous des trois
se méfier légèrement
on essaie de remettre le fou sur cette
diagonale parce que au moins là il
protège le pion C4 alors qu'avant il
faisait absolument rien sur cette grande
diagonale bien stoppée par les pions F5
E4 qui travaille donc voilà
ça reste très solide et je pense que il
va il va il veut tenter quelque chose ça
c'est sûr mais c'est une bonne position
pour qu'on traîne en Laurent avec les
Blancs ouais c'est pas mal et regarde la
pendule 7 minutes compte 3 30
peut être très rapide mais là c'est pas
le cas
donc attention à prendre dans sa
position plus agréable des fois vous
avez une position plus agréable mais en
10 + 2 c'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle ce que vous allez vouloir la
valoriser des fois c'est pas si facile
l'incrément est pas assez passer large
pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir se permettre ce genre de
choses Magnus ne joue pas aujourd'hui je
réponds à une question YouTube est-ce
que Manu jouera la semaine prochaine et
bien
ça c'est toujours
c'est toujours un choix des équipes et
il m'a bougé la caméra il y en a qui se
barre du truc non mais bon il a pas le
droit de faire ça non
toi
évolution et merci à tous la progression
est en marche
je suis quasiment associé comme tu me
l'a proposé
ils sont plus que deux avec puissance de
partout aujourd'hui pour Laurent ben
ouais avec
58% des parts c'est quand même
[Musique]
alors c'est toi qui a fait tout le
boulot c'est quand même très généreux de
ta part
et je préfère et je préfère déléguer à
des gens incompétents donc tu rentres
pas dans cette catégorie là déjà
incompétent comme ça les gens tu manques
aux gens comme ça tu vois
c'est quand même beaucoup plus agréable
la cam de part à Noël elle est bien il a
mis le chiffon il a mis le chiffon sur
la cam Parian
ils sont plus que deux dans le colle
alors là ils sont complètement alors
normalement les arbitres qui qui
vérifient dans les deux les deux sont
noirs là ils sont en galère de caméra
mon dessin que ça paraît obligatoire de
prendre pour les blancs c'est marrant il
réfléchit sur ce coup là
alors qu'on a envie de faire un peu en
mode automatique c'est prendre des 5
pour éviter des cartes Laurent
exactement ça fait peur après je peux
jouer fousser 3 éventuellement ah c'est
ça c'est ça exactement
tu prends et là je fais un truc un coup
d'infiltration je mets un sache j'ai pas
envie de faire ça du tout
alors comment on fait sur ton petit coup
pour réagir
au minimum si j'ai envie si j'ajoute
petit bras admettons je suis un joueur
tu vois et maintenant il faut prendre sa
carte là c'est petit bras ça va faire il
va avoir des échanges j'ai l'impression
remarque là il y a un petit un petit
souci non
parce que sur fulpron G7 il y a fou
point F1 qui va te faire mal oui mais on
n'est pas obligé
trois tu veux claquer
ces trois je veux claquer sur ça ouais
je veux claquer et après pour éviter
dame Descartes mais c'est vrai que je
crois il y a du jeu
attention attention
je peux je peux aller les deux côtés
j'étais content
parce qu'il m'a flagué moche tu vois
c'est à dire que j'ai plus de temps et
en plus sa position était vraiment archi
nul
et ma flingué très très moche
il s'est fait aussi quoi je
retiens
on va pas toujours l'occasion de se
venger
malheureusement mais si j'ai l'occasion
j'oublierai pas
même dans longtemps tu sais c'est les
gens rancunier ça
même dans le temps j'aurais pas oublié
ça reste c'est dans un coin de la tête
et la variante qu'on va donner qu'est-ce
qu'on est bon
on a vu
alors est-ce que par avion est revenu
dans toujours pas donc il y a pas de
came de paradis désolé on va aller voir
sur les autres équipes parce que ce
match pour être terminé incessamment
sous peu avec lasavik à lasavik
qu'est-ce qui fait le job et ouais il
fait le job il a gratté le purin et
ouais la belle technique ça pousse
la fourchette
ça va faire 7 à 3 pour les pour les
lévitops chez swears il faut faire
attention léger contre le jeu qui
pourrait y avoir elle va jouer le tour
ces deux bien évidemment mais on peut
même faire faux F2 à mon avis et Tours
imaginer on peut tenter un échec mais on
peut tenter ça mais la remettre
on est largement en retard et alors
Valentina gounina qui pourrait plier le
match si elle venait à bout de
on doit pouvoir
on doit pouvoir presque mater
directement dans situation alors comment
font le travail c'est vrai qu'elle est
très irrégulière avait gagné un très
fort tournoi à Londres en 2016 en
battant battant notamment
des joueurs comme smiri de machines
David awell avec Bacro
fait un gros tournoi mais c'est pas des
jours
comment on mate c'est quoi le
toujours l'histoire du mec qui dit bah
ouais mais c'était mal au temps c'est de
ta faute et en même temps c'était
cadence ultra rapide donc c'est toujours
compliqué cette histoire ou là qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé là alors la variante
qu'on avait vu avec tout reprendre à me
prendre un psychiatre et dame 5 et dame
prend ces trois très jolie sur pion
français 3 on fait tour reprend B1 mais
il a le dame aussi intermédiaire et
apparemment c'est difficile pour pour
paraviane qui s'est fait avoir là dans
les complications clairement
la victoire de l'enderman ça va faire
deux points ça va faire un premier
minimal gagné par les passeurs
yes avec un score de 2,5
normal donc ça fait 6 4 si c'est viande
gagne sa faveur 6,5 et il y aura 7 5
avant le dernier match écoute deux
points d'avance mais ouais on est en vie
ça permet de vibrer un petit peu sur le
dernier match tant mieux
il se défendent après on a une à
pas très en forme qui n'a pas assez aidé
son équipe c'est pour ça qu'il est que
cette équipe qui est très compétitive ne
gagne pas au bout des trois rondes comme
je le pensais et là c'est la dame va
faire du bien
parce que tu as pas ta prédiction et pas
rentrer pas
je me dis gouninor est pu être plus
efficace plus performante plus
performante voilà alors comment on fait
là pour terminer c'est pas complètement
terminé
est-ce que je suis dans ma salle dans
cette position pour contrôler
deux et à 4
et je pousse mes pions
très compliqué il a joué il a joué dame
de 6 ça marche pas de pain quelques
petits échecs pour replacer la dame
j'aime bien faire ça aussi alors bref 7
Dame des cinq tours aussi et voilà
maintenant qu'on a cloué on peut pousser
plus facilement ouais super c'est une
façon de faire mais
alors toi de fou quand même protéger
espion si on perce le pion ça va être
très délicat à gagner
encore faire peut-être un petit
échec ou pas mal le truc qu'on avait
indiqué c'est un peu plus safe alors ça
doit être il semble mais bon
client quand même
maintenant faut trouver pas évident pas
évident
j'aime pas trop
parce que tu me laisses sûrement que tu
veux faire ça ouais ce soir et surtout
c'est de après tour ces deux quand même
B3 il y a tous deux d'un imbé 6 et C4
mais il faut Florent herbe qui nous
demande dans quelle situation et de
Tours sont mieux que la reine bah dans
des situations un peu moins un peu moins
ouvertes parce que là la dame elle se
balade et puis en plus
il manque des pions c'est surtout ça
ouais tour à deux et on préfère jouer
avec les deux tours les deux tours sont
très complémentaires si elles s'infiltre
en deuxième rangée
il revient donc là il fait tout ou deux
c'est pas qu'il veuille pas la nulle
part Aviane mais il sent bien que c'est
Viane a pas très bien joué les derniers
coups C6 il va simplement venir avec le
roi essaie de ramasser ce pion bien
écoute il y a quand même des problèmes
techniques ici c'est bien qui c'est pas
si facile
j'aime bien
il faut essayer de mettre cette dame ici
possiblement en espérant de faire un
échec pour prendre à trois pourquoi
c'est pas possible
et peut-être qu'il y a madame j'essaie
de me prendre H7 et on va se on va se
jeter sur la sur les lois c'est vrai que
si on peut ramasser toutes les droits
c'est aussi un bon deal
S avec les Noirs c'est bien joué la part
de paravient mais il est sous grande
pression autant et cette position avec
la pression au temps a peut-être ça pour
passer le roi sur dame 3 et de faire roi
des 5 donc je suppose qu'on va faire MC4
mais comment on fait ensuite pas évident
pas évident du tout
il faut être vraiment très précis et
c'est important donc les invite à bien
gagner Laurent contre trichera kanyamara
bon on aura quoi qu'il en soit un
dernier match mais c'est vrai que s'il y
a 8 4 c'est plié même 7 et demi c'est
plié il faut absolument que
on le rappelle le tout à fait parce que
le format ça veut dire qu'il y a besoin
d'un trois du coup pour les Garden State
Passos 3 1 qui est imaginable
pour faire pour faire un timer attention
3 1 c'est pas gagné c'est juste un
taille-break entre les deux joueuses
toujours favoris pour les vitov l'équipe
de l'éditeur avec Valentina godinand
mais qui a montré quand même aujourd'hui
qui a été pas en grande forme donc on
sait jamais tout à fait
alors ils font ça avec le roi mais là
c'est Viane chaud c'est chaud c'est très
chaud la petite chance de gain quand
même
avec ce roi qui est parti chercher les
pions
où là
il a plus de temps il a plus de temps F4
là il va se prendre un échec et d'un
point F4 si c'est possible non peut-être
pas il y a pas d'échec
c'est ça c'était plutôt sympa il y a
peut-être simplement non pas je vais
prendre F il y a tout reprend H4 échec
ouais je prends un FC tourco H4 échec
c'est pas facile et attention il a
rejoint autant alors il est rapide c'est
Viane je vous garantie
de jouer très vite
c'est bizarre il y a tout reprend H4
il veut garder ses tours connectés et
franchement
ça peut toujours un peu vriller ce genre
de position
tu vois c'est pas simple tour G4
préciser
avec si peu de temps c'est une galère
c'est une galère ouais ça va être fini
il va faire dames au prochain coup bien
calculer de la part de céviane qui s'est
repris au bon moment là ça me prend B4
va être joué ou dames on sait pas
cherche mieux là
il fait dame
ok il prend les tours G4 mais on le
perce le pion
game
galère la tour contre la dame la dame va
étouffer le roi voilà regardez ça a été
ça y est et du coup c'est une galère
quoi c'est une galère
je vais essayer de garder évidemment
le plus longtemps possible au minimum
c'est assez ça fait attention les 50
couilles il y a pas besoin de réclamer
là on est sur internet ça se fait
automatiquement
il va aller avec le tandem roi dame gêné
ton adversaire et maintenant on ramène
le roi
voilà une certaine progression et ses
exemples
terrible et vous voyez là
on sait on a vu en plus on le savait
hyper la tour s'il va H4 c'est dames des
8 qui va ranger 3 et
très mignon surtout G5 on peut pas
s'accoller puisqu'il y avait ma tante
il y a beaucoup de choses la mecs c'est
5 abandon de David parvient
bonne position de contre première
victoire des pasers qui relance
légèrement le match ils auront quand
même un 3 Laurent
à coller pour ils n'ont pas le droit de
perdre un et demi
pourquoi pas mais pourquoi pas
il faut déjà que c'est Viane battent ma
médié
non non que c'est bien il aura les Noirs
donc les Noirs puisque
vient d'avoir les blancs avec la petite
nulle et c'est Viane vient d'avoir
les Noirs il a eu les Noirs aussi
mauvais
peu importe en tout cas oui tout à fait
j'essaie de le récupérer
et Florent avec les deux pions de moins
c'est à dire voilà s'il y avait eu deux
tours voilà qu'on a dame oui ça serait
égal en fait mais oui on préfère avoir
les deux tours
la dame est très utile quand il y a un
rond en danger en fait je conseille une
partie
c'est la première partie du match entre
les co et cramniques de 2004 le match à
Brice sago ou notamment Vladimir
cramique a gagné une pétrole avec les
Noirs dans ce format là de Tours contre
contre dame très intéressant pour manier
les manies parfaitement il arrive à
échanger et la dame s'en sort pas et
très très intéressant pour la technique
technique parfaite de Vladimir dans
cette partie
c'est noté voilà si vous voulez une
partie une partie de référence ou les ou
les deux tours
dominent la dame n'hésitez pas à aller
voir cette belle partie merci Laurent
pour la ref tu notes sur le sujet j'ai
noté
super
alors n'hésitez pas à vous poser les
questions sur ce que vous voulez sur la
nouvelle Académie du jeu d'échec online
par exemple Pro Évolution échec Pro
Évolution pourquoi je prononce en
anglais moi qu'est-ce que je peux faire
toi moi j'ai pas ce souci là alors toi
évolution Pro Évolution échec voilà
n'hésitez pas à aller voir ça à vous
poser à nous poser toutes les questions
allez retirer votre petit cadeau sur sur
Kevin tu vas m'obliger à le remettre
dans le chat mais je remets le cadeau
pour ceux qui l'ont pas vu tout à
l'heure voilà allez si vous voulez du
cadeau
ton avis sur le match d'hier sur le
match de manuscrite éblouissant 4 sur 4
il a été impérial
j'avais
du foot j'ai bien aimé le dernier quart
d'heure
j'ai créé devant ma télé
on se fait encore on se fait avoir mais
j'ai vu qu'il enfin j'ai eu un gros
doute donc ça m'a évité de de célébrer
un gros doute ah oui oui il est en jeu
un centimètre tu sais pas justement le
le doute est énorme parce que tu sais
que c'est pas loin quoi
ça devrait être ça devrait être je sais
pas moi tu vas avoir une règle ouais
il est très fort mais il a fait une
belle boulette quand même hier il a fait
une énorme boulette de naruma ça m'a il
a fait un bel arrêt après de folie
grande classe quand il la met sur son
poteau mais bon
dur dur mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont mis
une intensité incroyable mais trop
tardivement quoi malheureusement mais
bon ça laisse des espoirs évidemment dès
qu'il y a c'est un peu comme les chaises
bras sans Carson
l'équipe adverge ou moins haut voilà ça
ça crée ça crée une tension après je
crois qu'ils ont été assez modestes
tiens ils ont oui
ils auraient pu mettre plus de pression
ils ont voulu attendre justement bon
c'est bizarre il y a quand même des très
très beaux jours de foot ils auraient pu
faire mieux mais franchement
quand tu viens de sortir de par exemple
de deux défaites consécutives aux échecs
tu vas pas pareil la 3e témoin
conscience et tu vas peut-être jouer
plus avec le frein à main voilà c'est
aussi un problème de confiance le seul
moyen de de rétablir la confiance mais
c'est de gagner des matchs c'est pas
pour cette fois ça sera peut-être dans
trois semaines ou avant
oui mais gros calendrier à venir gros
calendrier à venir
et ben
est-ce qu'on peut dire que Hansen est le
Neymar des échecs c'est pas mal ça
il fait une petite vraie à ton chaise
bras et l'équipe de Magnus non mais je
veux même pas
il a pas suivi le match du coup pas de
l'eau tu vois ouais
tu es sérieux jusqu'au bout bon en tout
cas pour revenir à nos moutons on va
regarder ça on va voir
on voit mais pour une fois ils sont un
petit peu revenus
c'est pas fini c'est pas fini donc
c'est pas possible ça fait 18 fois que
tu nous dis avec Richard kanyamara elle
fait pas mieux hein
elle a été plus performante alors qu'on
pensait que c'était le point faible
mine de rien cette partie qu'on ne
m'avait dit à Rohff ça aurait pu être un
tournant quand même
donc elles ont toutes les deux zéro
Hélène Dorman modeste aussi un sur trois
simplement donc c'est un peu lui aussi
qui fait défaut au passeur effectivement
la différence c'est Viane impériale de
admis sur trois ma meilleure offre avec
pas mal de réussite de nuit sur trois
mais la zavie qui fait le taf 2 et demi
par Aviane aussi 2 sur 3 voilà pour
l'instant les lévitov Chase rusards qui
domine mes dominés n'est pas gagné 7 5 3
demi-heure et demi et c'est gagné pour
les pour les passeurs bon on en est pas
là on va vous rappeler évidemment le
programme de la semaine demain on a
l'équipe de Blitz stream l'équipe
française qui arrive on sera là à partir
de 16h15 même pour encourager évidemment
l'équipe française avec Alexander
gretchouk machine à graves my Boyer et
démantèle une belle équipe qui sera
opposée à ergy et une équipe indienne
aussi très très forte un choc des titans
on a dit il y a quasiment que des grands
maîtres des fois mettre voilà mais
globalement le niveau est hyper hyper
relevé
le format du 10 + 2 non c'est pas
celui-là
du 10 + 2 mais on peut pas dépasser
25050 voilà il faut au moins une femme
dans la la composition de l'équipe et en
cas d'égalité on le verra peut-être les
quatre échiquiers s'affrontent en
inversant les couleurs le quatrième
chiqué pardon les quatrième échiquier en
3 + 2 ça pourrait être très sympa de
voir un timer avec je sais pas ce que tu
en penses mais moi j'ai j'aimerais bien
ouais tout à fait mais
je reste assez
sceptique sur ce match là mais ça
viendra ça viendra de toute façon mais
ouais là pour l'instant on a vu quand
même une domination d'une des équipes
c'est pas encore assez assez serré les
prix tout à l'heure les prix on voit
l'équipe gagnant de bascule dans la
division 1-0 alors ça je sais pas mais
en tout cas ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'il y a 150 000 dollars de prix et
effectivement voilà il y a des il y a
des divisions comme comme vous pouvez
jouer certains d'entre vous ou même
beaucoup d'entre vous j'en sais rien je
joue certainement les interclubs si on
joue bien on monte enfin là c'est
divisions donc si on joue bien en des
Champions et si on joue mal on est
rétrogradé et s'il y a une division 2
aussi ou si on joue bien évidemment on
se qualifie pour la Ligue 1 Étienne
Macron ne joue pas de main et oui ça
ferait trop de l'eau effectivement un
gritchouc et mvl ça fait une beaucoup
trop ouais mais bon là c'est pas c'est
pas possible évidemment
ça serait trop beau pour être vrai
on va voir s'il est parti on vient de
commencer on a chacun
envoie tout le monde qui se rassoit
chaque il est tranquille avec son
téléphone
on voit que c'est mis en mode
haut-parleur on voit et
rester à la fin de ce match parce qu'à
19h on a
on a les autres on a un autre match que
je vais je pourrais montrer la presque
attends donc on va dire que c'est les
Espagnols contre les Norvégiens peut
peut vous dire un petit peu qui sera
présent vas-y fais John Ludwig Hammer
tout à l'heure
dans dans cette dans cette équipe donc
[Musique]
du coup
il est le dirigeant évidemment donc il y
a ça les salam donc c'est UAE je crois
les Émirats David hawael donc le joueur
anglais Garonne Jones le joueur anglais
prana V il doit être indien il est après
je ne connais pas les autres joueurs à
part ni au bad salvili qui est
émergement
voilà qu'on connaît aussi la Grand
Maître féminine allemande et ensuite on
a allemande
moi je
j'ai fait une bêtise peut-être je contre
là elle est slovaine
et on a goupeta aussi donc ça c'est le
grand maître indien ouais j'ai confondu
ou non qu'avec quelqu'un d'autre mais
j'arrive pas à retrouver qui avec pet
non non
peu importe autant pour moi Laurent
tueur rectifié et du coup présentation
de l'équipe espagnole qui n'avait pas de
logo
je l'ai je les ai pas niche maniaque
shreams
avec ben voilà des des donc le grand
maître espagnol James Santos la tassa
Alan pichotte qui est lui argentin
edwardo rizzaka qui est Vénus il est à
colombien c'est quoi voilà Venezuela
Miguel Santo joséibara José cuenka donc
ça doit être de l'équipe espagnole qui
passe pas des Cubains dans l'eau non pas
du tout mais principalement espagnol et
donc on la lance Anderson de la Fuente
et en féminine il y a un
qui doit être aller je dirais Casa
quelque chose comme ça
et Vega Vega bah là l'espagnol c'est
facile mais là je sais pas quelle est la
compo exact mais je l'ai je l'ai donc
dès que ce match fini je vous donne la
composition exacte mais comme tu l'as
dit il y a que des beaux joueurs et là
on va se concentrer sur chacun va me
dire en face ça ça me fait Viane une
vente archite théorique de la défense
mais en après foudre on prend et on joue
à 6 fou B7 et le coup vraiment le plus
joué ici mais ainsi c'est très
intéressant pour jouer ces cinq directs
sans jouer fou B7 et là ça devient un
bazar ça s'est joué énormément
et c'est la ligne de bonne la ligne de
bonne qui a été inventée par Vichy à
Nantes contre Vladimir cramique au match
de bonnes en 2008 où j'étais secondant
de
Vladimir cramique ça a donné gros effet
de surprise et deux points il a marqué
deux points il a gagné ce match sur
cette ligne la ligne de bonne c'est fou
B7 vous prend V5 et tourger 8 c'était à
nouveau tel à l'époque alors les noirs
peuvent aussi jouer fois si ces bécales
j'ai passé des nuits endiablées sur
cette position mon cher Kevin à l'époque
où les ordis étaient pas tu vois 2008
ça laissait de quoi faire des erreurs
pourquoi je prends F6 c'est pas du
cavalier c'est vrai que ça serait
logique de prendre du câlet mais là on a
un problème tactique faut prendre mes
cinq échec et ensuite on perd le pion
des donc voilà sur gprp F6 au moins il y
a pas faut prendre les 5 parce qu'il y a
Damas 5 échec et de nous on n'a pas fait
échec donc ça c'est un gros problème
donc
qui a permis de gagner ce match assez
facilement mais elle est objectivement
maintenant quasi réfutée on va voir mais
il le fait quand même ok normalement
c'est censé être très mauvais en
Vladimir on a la première partie il a
joué il a il était sur une prépa mais il
a joué le tour des un tour G8 je crois
qu'il a fait qu'il prend des quatre
ce qui était non pas là
c'est après
G2 et c'est chaud et c'est chaud mais en
général les ordinateurs j'ai regardé ça
il y a pas si longtemps que ça
et les ordinateurs
disons modernes donc 15 ans plus tard
sont pas très optimistes pour les Noirs
tu vois ce que je veux dire
les joueurs ont un tel niveau de et de
capacité de mémorisation qui retiennent
ils peuvent apprendre par cœur on évite
de dire ça aux amateurs mais eux peuvent
le faire et après calculons plus dans
les parties connaissent aussi
l'évaluation qui est énorme avec une
bonne fiabilité et du coup c'est
c'est sûr que ça fait ça fait mal et là
ça a l'air pas mal mais en fait c'est
pas terrible A4 et en fait on va dans
plein de variante on va faire comme ça
on va juste pousser
et c'est alors ça a l'air hyper
dangereux pour les blancs parce qu'il y
a quand même comme on l'a dit tour G8 le
fou B7 mais en fait il y a pas
ça marche pas c'est comme ça c'est les
échecs modernes donc ici ici attends je
vais vérifier avec la avec l'ordi de
cheesecom je crois que la 4 est le bon
cours et bien non tu vois c'est faux F4
plus 1,34 tu vois il faut F4 d'abord et
ensuite on joue à 4 effectivement c'est
logique pour pouvoir
certains moments est-ce que c'est pas
toi simple
tu vois ça me tu vois je me souviens de
rien c'est ça le problème ton problème
je sais qu'il y a un sacrifice de
qualité comme ça qui est pas clair du
tout
ça fait peur hein vous voyez la colonne
g Le Fou B7 et même si l'ordi dit qu'il
y a rien si vous ne connaissez pas la
position avec les Blancs il faut pas
déconner c'est intéressant c'est
position aussi que l'ordinateur n'aime
pas trop et tout ce qu'il a fait Sam sur
tour D1 il a fait tout à 5 donc il
connaît aussi l'idée évidemment et je me
alors là alors là il y a la nul comme ça
pour prendre les 4 dam prend les quatre
alors ça c'est même en 2008 on l'a
trouvé
et là je sais qu'on fait nul avec les
Blancs comment on fait on doit faire la
m2 quelque chose comme ça mettre la dame
sur case noire et là en fait tu as pas
mieux que de répéter les coups
on l'avait trouvé en 2008 donc c'était
une des idées principales des pièges de
Vichy à Nantes bon il y avait d'autres
il avait d'autres à son son répertoire
des pièges on n'est pas inquiet pour lui
mais est-ce que au vu du match
pas mal nul
tu fais nul contre l'adversaire le plus
dangereux de la part de mamedia off mais
c'est pas son style comme tu me l'a dit
ouais mais quand même il a joué à 4
et à 4 qui apparemment un mauvais coup
ici alors pourquoi
il y a tout reprend B5 et maintenant
c'est pas avec le foin F4 c'est le
gâteau en dehors et là c'est très très
mauvais pour les c'est très très mauvais
pour les blancs tout de suite
et si tu fais foudre
lui jouer des tours ça pourrait jouer
des tours alors peut-être et c'est jouer
tu reprends mes 5 à B ke5 qui connaît ça
me fait bien c'est logique
il est quasiment foutu il est dans les
cordes en tout cas dans une petite comme
ça avec l'avantage matériel
ultra dangereux on va voir les autres
échiquier pour voir si ça peut tourner
au vinaigre pour pour les vitres
paravient ne changent pas ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est normal
là beaucoup plus molle enfin molle non
mais il se passe moins de choses quand
même
mais positions jouables pour les deux
clairement c'est pas passé grand chose
ça joue ça joue il peut tout se passer
dans cette partie 3 résultats possibles
la zavie contre l'enderman ouais
l'enderman c'est pas le rigolo de la
bande hein il joue il joue serré contre
contre
là pour l'instant il peut tout se passer
à battre son adversaire elle est moins
sûr elle a film variante des charges de
la slave
et elle va jouer tranquillement
et bien écoute tu sais quoi viens jouer
à les blancs bons choix peut-être on
peut avoir un gros retournement oui oui
là
finalement sur cette dernière ronde et
on peut avoir ton départage hein que tu
avais annoncé
on peut avoir un 3,5
si tu veux moi je suis pas
mignon et 4 joué par samsian avec qui
s'est fait avoir dans l'ouverture on
sent que il déguste son petit jus c'est
Viana là et ma mère c'est pas la tête
des grands jours
il est pas en train de vibrer et c'est
fait avoir comme un bleu là
moins concentré que d'habitude chacun
aussi s'élève c'est le premier match il
est pas décisif alors effectivement on
peut être éliminé assez rapidement mais
une une défaite aujourd'hui une élimine
personne c'est le c'est tout le monde
joue tout le monde donc là attention sur
ce dernier match
ils sont en danger à ce moment-là du
match après
goussain-nov Paray glenderman il y avait
rien de fait et même chez gounina donc
tu as été un peu optimiste en annonçant
des Pacers qui nous vend du rêve
l'orange j'ai l'impression pas du tout
c'est pas mon genre un peu moins de rêve
avec sa caméra d'un coup
pas du tout alors pas des lois pas de
l'eau et il nous fait travailler il nous
dit j'ai pas suivi le départage on a dit
il a pas il a disparu
il a cassé la cam ah non
[Applaudissements]
il fait quoi là de 50 et des trois
joueurs tempo pas ça me sévère qui
connaît son histoire d'un H5 maintenant
et là il y a un gars pour les Noirs
ton début ça l'a beaucoup intéressé et
pour le départage c'est du 3 + 2 sur le
match de échiquier féminin là
aujourd'hui puis si elles font nulles
j'ai deux Storm alors là tu as ouais
mais alors je peux pas remontrer tu vois
c'est compliqué priorité au direct
et aller voir après les choses sont
enregistrées
donc c'est vrai que les choses sont
enregistrées si vous voulez appuyer sur
pause et vous le repassez au ralenti
c'est vrai qu'on est obligé aussi un peu
d'aller vite c'est des parties rapides
donc on est obligé on est obligé aussi
de de faire place au direct donc désolé
du coup il est un peu
j'ai l'impression qu'il a plus même un
coup tout simple comme ça
tu vois je masque F3
mais là j'aime pas tu vois c'est marrant
est-ce qu'on pouvait jouer fou C5
autrement pour moi
je n'aime pas je pensais que j'ai 4
aussi est-ce que c'est bien que j'ai 4
ça c'est pas mal
ça
m'était contenté ahfousser 5 et prendre
les trois mais qui épreuves de fait très
très mal c'est une horreur c'est une
horreur
donc on est obligé de prendre et qui
prend deux ans aussi d'ailleurs au
passage mais ouais le cavalier H3 le
joli qui avait les H3 on le connaît ce
mat ce mat on a même pas besoin il peut
même pas reprendre de la tour ah oui
sinon il y a pas de matériel tout fait
d'ailleurs non c'est du mat tout court
donc il va jouer que j'ai évidemment qui
va jouer un tacticien comme lui
évidemment
on fait comment du coup là
bon quand même hein
tu sais
notre idée on l'a fait quoi qu'il arrive
voilà
et là on s'amuse et là on sait pas mais
on sent que ça va bien se terminer quand
même cette histoire
est assez simple et complètement gagnant
pardon tu voulais faire le moulinet
d'accord
il y a de bonne chance parce que c'est
pas difficile pour son niveau il avait
du temps quoi en tout cas pour le
trouver il est pas sous pression il
aurait eu moins d'une minute là il peut
tout verrouiller comparer les coups et
calculer les suites forcés les coûts
concrets donc avaler G4 ça coûte très
concret c'est très difficile de défendre
dommage 4K F2 c'est facile car il prend
des trois faut juste valider cavalier
prend F2 là encore que tu as montré
Laurent ou normalement ça devrait pas
poser de problème et tu sais quoi
breaking news il a joué
comme prévu on l'avait dit
s'enfonce dans son siège c'est pas c'est
pas moi c'est pas la caméra c'est pas
c'est pas moi qui l'ai bougé c'est lui
qui bouge tout seul là il s'enfonce là
marrant
le langage corporel
de plus en plus perd ses cheveux
tu arrives déjà très bien Kévin
je savais comment ça allait continuer tu
as vu que je m'étais retenu là j'étais
pas du tout soutenu je me suis dit ça va
me retomber
à apprendre la tête on se donne quelques
amabilités avant le stream
Kevin me dit que je suis grisonnante
est-ce que j'ai dit que au moins j'ai
des cheveux ça se voit pas trop
d'ailleurs sur le stream tu fais là
la lumière fait que ça se voit pas les
gens sont surpris quand ils me voient en
vrai après il dit ah bon voyons ta tête
à morflé je t'ai vu la semaine je t'ai
vu une semaine sur le stream t'avais pas
un cheveu blanc mais là tu as morflé
qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu as des soucis ou
quoi enfin bon bref damage 4 et là qui
est épreuve de jouer par Sam c'est bien
c'est très simple pour un joueur pour un
joueur comme ça c'est terminé ça va
faire du 7 à 6 et je crois qu'on peut
passer même une autre partie où on
regarde la fin de cette magnifique
partie ou pas
il lui reste une 24 donc il doit pas
être loin de de l'abandon en fait ben je
crois je crois qu'il va abandonner parce
que là qu'est-ce qui peut jouer même
trouver un coup c'est pas évident
attends il y a eu des coups faut 3 dame
prend le 3 et d'un point F2 ok ça se
tient
pas mal mais ça sent tellement mauvais
là c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
c'est bien joué
alors est-ce qu'on peut faire pousser
cinq
d'apprendre
et des deux et même
j'ai vu roi donc évidemment c'est pas la
bonne idée ok même dans les deux cas
donc ça c'est
alors comment on finit le job
c'est encore un quad
peut-être
de la caméra pour comparer mamène oui
vas-y
j'avais pas vu ce qu'il avait écrit dans
mes cartes avec des fous prends un
ouais ouais c'est bon ça j'aime bien
j'aime bien j'aime bien bravo bien joué
je crois que ça va être joué et c'est
jouer mais décidément trouve tous les
coups dans cette partie dans le 4 jouer
menace vous prendrez pas de G3 possible
c'est maths
peut-être le coup d'air et à
peut-être tourner deux mais bon non
seulement on a dû on a moins de matériel
mais en plus on a une attaque contre
nous la plus esthétique enfin que j'ai
pu voir depuis le début de cette
compétition là avec les Noirs il a fait
le choix d'une ouverture risqué ça a
payé c'est bien
magnifique
tour des deux a été joué et là il dit
non je prends même pas je joue ton G5 je
veux faire tout F5
quel formidable professionnelle se
Servian il laisse aucune chance à ma
manière
de se faire rouler dessus comme ça
oh là là qu'est-ce qu'elle est bonne
qu'est-ce qu'elle est bonne cette partie
à chaque coup c'est de plus en plus dur
mais il s'accroche
tu fais un coup comme moi je vais
simplement faire ça tu vas faire ça je
vais même encaisser ici tu vas encaisser
ici et je vais encaisser ici à la
tronçonneuse on termine cette partie
et après
c'est bien
et trouve tous les coups de défense
quand même pour faire éventuellement
craquer ses Viane
qui est complètement gagnant ton F5 doit
pas être mal là
ok intéressant
comment il termine le travail oui ils
sont là ces jours ils sont très très
durables
bon j'ai fait une partie dégueu il le
sait hein bon ouais Foussais 5 tours 4
je me dis que sur ça je vais avoir ça
on va voir je suis sur son
et maintenant il va faire a priori
prendre
ouais
il faut vraiment
sur qu'il prend des trois G2 tu fais roi
et fin je crois que j'ai
et si tu reprends donc on reprend G2
Laurent
faut baisser j'ai trois pions passé lié
compte 2
et H2 qui traîne tes pieds sont pas
beaux
et il a joué quoi en 4K
mais là je peux jouer ça ça gagnant
c'est pas si sûr
il y a juste fou point F2
la finale de pion est terminée pour
ranger deux rois 3
tromper c'est jouer c'est jouer mais
c'est fini 3 c'est mal joué son truc
choisis pas un bon truc pratique on a
tout ça
hyper hyper sympa et c'est gagné pour
samsian abandon on va aller voir tout de
suite gusée inoff contre
paravient des gousses et une offre voilà
c'est très chaud entre gouzaïneuf et
non je vais pas revisiter mes souvenirs
merci pas tout de suite peut-être que on
peut on peut faire un petit tour des
échiquier donc là c'est la partie entre
paraviane
c'est pas mal pour la zavik
il fait mal ce laser
qui a obtenu le meilleur là un pion de
plus contre ouais non ça va être dur
quand même pour les Garden State
spaceers finalement le dernier mais pas
suffisamment il doit regarder ses
collègues ça me Servian mais même sa
victoire contre Mohamed il ne va pas
suffire
par exemple on va voir que vous avez une
offre face à
ça donne quoi cette position Kevin
ça donne que c'est chaud donc je
regardais un petit peu quelle était
l'idée derrière sa crise d'option on
avait envie de jouer des choses comme
fois 5 pour travailler sur le cavalier
F3 mais pour H5 c'est peut-être
Dame des cinq l'idée voilà et là ce
qu'on peut à tour Eiffel
énorme gave de Gouze Innov qui se prend
la tête dans les mains il y a d'un
prince 5 et dame G5 Sud maths
là c'est vraiment grosse bêtise
et surtout j'ai 7 ans
allez encore ouais je suis là pardon
c'est un peu plus précis
et là et là je crois que les carottes
sont cuites il faudrait il faudrait un
de 0 sur ses positions et là zavik est
mieux qu'on
endermanina est mieux contre son
adversaire aussi bon là c'est les
carottes sont cuites
simplification comme dame 5
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a un
prochain match qui commence bientôt à
19h tu te rends compte on n'a pas le
temps de souffler
c'est le travail de la chaîne ici
c'est dur
bon après ça enchaîne direct il faut que
le problème c'est que tu Express là faut
que je remette tout tu vois ce que je
veux dire et tout ça
jouer pour simplifier et maintenant les
Noirs font au moins nuls et ça va être
terminé
je crois que les joueurs ont le droit de
regarder les autres le score et tout ça
on va voir je crois que même
pour les Noirs ils travaillent bien
laser on voit que la position avec les
Noirs en train de
doucettement s'améliorer avec des
perspectives à très jolie F4 pour
essayer d'endiguer un peu l'attaque noir
c'est ça mais bon
on reste quand même un peu sous pression
cette dame achète qu'on pourrait voir G4
avec
les noirs pour essayer de faire du mal
au pion H3
ouais mais quand même tu vois il peut
c'est dommage parce que sur cette partie
peut se passer un truc tu vois on sent
que n'importe qui tu vois les blancs
peuvent gagner mais dans l'autre c'est
ça c'est ça qui est terrible c'est que
là
hypothétique Roissy c'est le coup du pro
et après
c'est tout de suite tout de suite foutu
tout à fait et ça va faire une victoire
au final plutôt large quand même pour le
lévito de chasse Wizard du
peut-être d'ici
des parties ça représente bien ce qui
est le scénario du match qu'on a vu on a
vibrer un petit peu sur ce dernier match
en se disant
ça pouvait être résultats inverse il a
fait une grosse gaffe et là tout était
encore possible qu'est-ce qu'elle
fabrique un encore une fois bref
c'était pas le coup du professionnel que
tu avais proposé qui était beaucoup plus
simple
j'aime pas du tout donnez pas au pire en
finale de tour surtout quand vous avez
deux mois c'est un conseil
c'est un conseil vous pouvez retrouver
sur sur Pro Évolution échec à mon avis
un moment faut s'arrêter non là c'est H6
c'était très mal joué ce qu'il fallait
faire la chance pratique c'était ça elle
voulait faire washi je suppose ça ça
et ça par exemple typiquement
typiquement c'est nul
probablement
donc là c'est cette partie ça sonne la
fin
la fin des chances pour les
passeurs ce qui était clairement un
crans dessus en dessous pardon bien sûr
bien sûr tranquille
victoire assez assez logique mais grosse
équipe les Wizard parce qu'on a vu un
petit média Rohff quand il sera bien
chaud dans des matchs importants
l'équipe elle va pas être facile à
abattre et je pense que gunnina peut
faire aussi des meilleurs matchs donc du
coup
regardez je me suis dit tiens on va voir
si si je lui la refais est-ce qu'il va
réagir et j'ai vu que oui
avec le petit coup proposé tranquillou
roi Chisse et là on a vu un quelque
chose qui laissait du contre jeu les
caméras je les enlève ça sert plus à
rien ils sont en train de se barrer
toute préparer attention vous voyez non
mais je vais juste exactement il est
dans les starting blocks pour le
prochain match avec nos amis espagnols
mais bon nos amis Espana comme ils vont
avoir un quart d'heure de retard moi je
les connais ça va être bon on va voir le
temps de s'organiser
on va se faire un petit break après mon
cher mon cher Kevin je vais mettre tout
ça en place
à toi bonsoir gaillard 07 05 n'hésitez
pas à vos commentaires sont toujours les
bienvenus vos propositions de cours aux
questions
sur les échecs du coup à 19h le nouveau
match entre
Norvège on a cité on n'a pas eu les
compos encore Laurent bien sûr
c'est officiel d'ici pour les vitop chef
Wizards face au Garden State pasters on
revient ouais non et non c'était mon
équipe mon équipe quand j'ai joué cette
projectile elle va jouer tout reprend H5
et elle se prend tout reprend V5 et tu
reprends le 5 et le purifier
donc sur ce mon cher Kevin on a vu une
on va regarder ça scorboard
très fort 3,5
et un petit Mama diarraf à 2,5
et Vian très fort mais les autres
joueurs ont eu plus de mal
tri chaque année a failli bat mamedia
Rohff vraiment petite forme aujourd'hui
il va revenir c'est clair tout à fait on
va faire un petit break histoire qui est
un petit tu vois ce que je veux dire
un petit un petit réglage
[Musique]
merci à nous suivre restez il reste un
match Espagne Norvège allez
à tout à l'heure enfin tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour ce
deuxième match de la soirée de cette
proxessie qui n'a pas encore commencé et
vous voyez donc en bas à droite léger
souci j'ai pas réussi à mettre Nord
magnum dans devine le Père Noël on le
voit ici aussi le fameux Père Noël et on
a les paniers mariage maniaque stream
Kevin avec
crimes
les crevettes les petites crevettes de
de d'Espagne donc non marrant et on a
Eduardo et torizaga le joueur
venezuelien très très dangereux en
partie rapide
espagnol aussi très belle équipe et
Kahina abourde samova qui en tout cas je
sais pas c'est peut-être qu'elle vient
en Espagne maintenant
mais en tout cas
russe je sais pas ce qu'il en est voilà
depuis les événements que l'on connaît
tous et que l'on regrette évidemment
face à eux donc on a les Norway gnoms on
voit le Père Noël donc des Norvégiens en
fait une équipe norvégienne sans
norvégien c'est ça donc on a Laura
unique la
mettre internationale allemande d'après
Kevin thérieux et selon selon la police
selon la police elle est slovène mais
bon on sait pas
prana V donc un grand maître indien très
connu un anglais
archi connu qui lit un bouquin là il
sort du on le voit on le voit comme beau
avec un beau polo et Salem salé le
meilleur joueur des Émirats arabes très
très dangereux
match YouTube mise sur qui toi dans ce
match
ah c'est partager
mais
je mettrai une petite pièce sur les les
faux norvégiens voilà moi je mets une
pièce sur les Espagnols parce que Gary
Jones je sens pas je sens pas en rapide
je sens pas je le connais
son meilleur polo là ah il s'est fait
plaisir
il s'est fait plaisir notre ami Gawen
mais non
voilà on va voir alors moi j'ai un
problème Nathan si tu nous écoutes
Nathan si tu nous écoutes je suis en
galère avec le
avec le truc alors j'ai fait le alt il
vient pas me dire que alt d'accord je
suis agacé là donc s'il te plaît
fais-moi un peu mieux que le halte s'il
te plaît essaie de faire alt non ça va
pas me ça va pas m'aider
donc j'espère que vous êtes certain
d'entre vous en tout cas sont toujours
là et voilà Ouaga je vois il est actif
sur chaise 24 en français cheesecom
YouTube n'hésitez pas à vous abonner aux
chaînes YouTube surtout la chaîne
cheesecom ou il va se passer beaucoup de
choses et à mettre des pouces bleus
n'hésitez pas et à poser des questions
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'était le break
entre les deux rondes
pour notre ami mm sur
jescom est-ce qu'on est toujours en
direct oui je crois qu'on est toujours
en direct
Judith fush ah oui un peu
il y a un petit air
tu l'as bien prononcé
ton nom terreau quoi
je pense que c'est à peu près ça quoi ce
que tu viens de prononcer
son nom là
des joueurs ne correspondent pas sur
l'écran on sait gaillard 0705 merci mais
on attend la partie commence
et dès que la partie va commencer ça va
ça va correspondre ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est la c'est la magie de la technique
mais avant je peux pas les faire
correspondre parce que j'ai pas les
parties
je peux pas on peut pas être partout je
vous le dis
on peut essayer d'être partout mais en
général on se retrouve nulle part bonne
remarque ça se suit c'est bien
on va voir là ça va pas tarder à mon
avis a commencé mais toujours plus
elle s'est mise dans le noir notre ami
oh ils sont tous dans le noir ça c'est
la
la dans le noir qu'est-ce que je vous
dise
pour l'instant mais ça c'est pas
en train de faire une petite sieste une
petite sieste effectivement on va voir
on va voir je sais pas ce qui va le rose
écarlo sibara mais je sais pas je pense
qu'ils sont vraiment pas mauvais en
rapide
nos amis nos amis espagnols
il a fait des tournois en France me
semble-t-il zopen
je vois pas faire une grosse con
aujourd'hui c'est marrant
tu vois il y a des gens comme ça vu la
tête au départ tu te dis fou
il a pas un fou de joie quoi
on verra on verra on verra je pense que
tout est possible tout est possible ça
va être envie que ça démarre comme les
joueurs et c'est pas trop pourquoi
pourquoi ça bloque j'ai soucis je
suppose je vais aller voir dans le slack
si j'espère que vous voyez pas l'écran
non vous voyez pas l'écran très bien
ça briker hop hop quand c'est que ça
commence on ne sait pas
ce link to follow
ou non je vais pas faire ça je vais pas
faire ça on va rester comme ça parce que
si je mets un nouveau lien je te raconte
pas
remarque allez on sent est-ce qu'on est
ambitieux là sur le sur le setup ou pas
vas-y fais-toi plaisir tu as le temps en
plus moi je mets une petite veste tu
vois tranquille
par contre je sais pas pourquoi ils ont
disparu nos amis espagnols
sont pas tout à fait prêt
ils sont on voit un gars one assez assez
figé
voilà il y a vraiment un problème de
caméra chez les 4 espagnols donc je sais
pas je sais pas ce qui se passe mais en
tout cas ça va pas ça va pas débuter
tout de suite c'est la magie et le
problème de de l'internet c'est toujours
pareil
[Musique]
c'est toujours la même histoire
et là Laurent n'a rien fait ils sont
revenus regarde
ça y est ça y est ça y est ça y est
alors
concentré donc ils ont peut-être
commencé mais on le rappelle ce petit
il y a un petit truc anti-triche voilà
il y a eu 30 secondes 1 30 40 secondes
de délai bon ça nous est différent vous
voyez ça ça nous ça nous change pas la
vie et
bon franchement il faut faire les petits
efforts parce que notamment online
certains joueurs ont confessait on
va pas on va pas mentir c'est à jour on
confessé avoir avoir déjà triché sur le
site
donc pas que sur chase.com sur chaise 24
on avait aussi des gens je peux vous
dire que
malheureusement on a attrapé pas mal pas
forcément des bons joueurs d'ailleurs
d'être très forts joueurs mais voilà
c'est dommage donc ne le faites pas
c'est nul de tricher ça n'a aucun
intérêt en plus on se fait toujours
attraper ça vous fait toujours attraper
les logiciels sont très très bien fait
moi j'ai eu accès à Chase 24 et je peux
vous dire c'est bien fait ça se trompe
jamais donc ne le faites pas
c'est clair que c'est un peu la gangrène
de notre jeu donc ça ça pourrait le jeu
c'est pas pour pour jouer aux échecs
bien sûr on fait ça d'abord évidemment
par plaisir on espère que et voilà
évidemment qu'on préfère gagner on
préfère tous gagner mais gagner comme ça
c'est nul et donc voilà ne le faites pas
il y a des
jeunes aux jeunes surtout aux petits
jeunes tu vois c'est tellement tentant
tu es tout seul dans ta chambre et puis
voilà donc faut pas
[Musique]
en un claquement de doigts mais c'est
pas la vraie vie et en plus
ça reste ça reste ne le faites pas ne le
faites pas ça reste dans une carrière ça
reste dans la réputation donc faut
absolument et puis pour toi-même avant
tout ça mais bon c'est vrai que c'est
pas en plus de
c'est pas bon d'en rajouter pour les
pros c'est vraiment c'est une bêtise
astronome quoi tu sais quoi j'ai un
miracle
j'ai un miracle ça a commencé alors qu'à
une Jones on va le voir avec les Blancs
il est pas du tout au bon endroit face à
Ibara ah ben oui mais c'est les joueurs
vous imaginez ah non et non c'est
parfait
croire
j'ai mis deux joueurs random
complètement par hasard et il se trouve
qu'il joue ensemble et qui sont en bon
endroit ça va aller quoi comme code
et j'aime pas perdre ça arriver tu vois
on était on attendait nous aussi tu vois
normalement ça devait reprendre à 19h un
petit peu en retard mais rien de méchant
et Tourer écoute
Ibara qui joue vite et solide contre
gawei ouais propre bien bien le début on
pense quoi
mais c'est chaud de faire en H3
parce que vous n'avez pas assez de
pièces ce qui arrive à la fête voilà et
par contre défensivement c'est tout
l'inverse
et gawei il est évidemment trop
exprimementé pour passer beaucoup de
temps sur le coup comme ça qui est BK
donc on a un problème ici comment on
fait
comment on fait
Kevin pas évident X4
on a on a le petit
tour 2 et là ça sera rigolo pour deux
maintenant il faut toujours surveiller
d'ailleurs le fou prend H3 qu'on disait
pas bon maintenant ça marche toujours
pas mais c'est plus dangereux
plus intéressantes il faudra être précis
on voit la Jauche excité mais
on n'a pas toujours pas cette pièce avec
le noir qui arrive c'est ça la
problématique
mais ça devient plus intéressant et
c'est forcément à surveiller côté blanc
même si ça ne marche pas surveiller donc
on va avoir peut-être ce tour aux deux
il faut A4 mais tout au 2 j'aime bien
comme ça le four est assez souple
et à chaque fois 4 bon ok
on peut menacer éventuellement de faire
ces trois alors faut toujours faire
attention au cahier des trois mais c'est
à double tranchant aussi skyrd 3 qui
pourrait être enfermé plus tard donc
intéressant on va voir ce que fait Gawen
on fait un petit tour des stades mais
pas un tour des caméras donc ne venez me
faire dire que ça ne venait pas me dire
que ça ça correspond pas je le sais
pertinemment il tourisaga face à Laura
unique une Benoni pour commencer et ben
dis donc
et on a cette grande variante avec
damaka Dame B3 pour affaiblir ce pion ce
pion des 6
c'est déjà c'est déjà pas mal pour pour
les blancs avec ce fou qui est un peu
bizarre bon sur H3 il y a encore
cavalier 5 pour l'instant
sinon c'était la défaite mais ça sent le
roussi déjà
je sais pas j'aime pas du tout ça
c'est vrai que tu peux avoir les
beignets il faut faire attention
j'aime pas du tout
en l'air tout à fait bon donc on va voir
il tourise AGA qui a les blancs contre
alors il prend ah non il a les Noirs
contre
unique pardon
il tour Isaac elle est noire donc ok ok
H3 cavalier 5 jouer ok donc intéressant
belle position pour pour le règne là
dans cette première partie
même foi F1 est pas mal foie fin ensuite
on joue fou des 7 et fou et deux quoi
que maintenant ça joue quand même pour
les noirs
peut-être qu'on peut faire F5 ici
bon très intéressant on va voir et les
Noirs mais qui va essayer de marquer le
point entier ça c'est sûr ensuite on a
prana avec les Blancs le jeune joueur
indien là on voit
ça me tente mais quoi une pétrole
et ouais mais une pétrole bon pas la
meilleure des pétroches comme tu l'as
dit pénible mais quand même ça reste pas
de faiblesse pour les Noirs donc ça
reste difficile
donc ça fait quand même plusieurs petits
soucis à régler
la colonne E la case 5 ouais je trouve
que c'est difficile à jouer côté noir
je vois que la jauge s'excite pas plus
que ça mais j'ai du mal à peut-être il
faudrait proposer l'échange d'armes par
dame G7 ouais mais j'ai eu proposé mais
du coup ça va pas du coup que jouer à la
place qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici avec la
noire tout recette il y aurait tout
reprend et pour eux un petit coup de
repli de remplacement un truc comme ça
mais bon je te laisse
très très compliqué
très très compliqué et il a joué ses
cinq
je me demandais c'était pas finalement
le seul choix mais à fou B5 c'est très
pénible et on va avoir bon cavalier
contre mauvais fou ah non on n'aura pas
oui
mais là il y a donc c'est pas un coup
bref
j'ai l'impression que je vois toujours
quel futur c'est pas très beau mais au
moins ça tient ça tient la baraque comme
on dit hein faut pas faire KFC qui a un
couteau c'est
bien joué par contre on peut
on peut presser ici c'est certain
pression pour Paname dans cette pour
prendre œuf pardon dans cette première
partie on a encore une autre partie
allez voir pour jauger des forces en
présence c'est Salem salé qui est gros
favori avec les Blancs contre eux non il
est noir contre abarths
quasiment
400 300 points et donc il va essayer
aussi comme il tour isaga de marquer le
point dans cette partie il a une
position déséquilibrée
qu'on connaît bien et là j'ai
l'impression que les noirs sont ok
puisque les pièces
comment ça compenser ce centre perdu ou
donner plutôt pour être exact dans le
début de partie
tout à fait donc position prometteuse
pour pour les Noirs tout à fait tout à
fait un bon jeu de pièces déséquilibré
déséquilibré on va retourner vers kawin
Jones face à Ibara qui est certainement
la partie en termes de vélo en tout cas
la puce serrée avec 2563 pour Ibara et
2617 pour Garoua une Jones donc bon
c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez serré tout ça et
une position intéressante vous C2 ok il
baraque qui s'enflamme pas il cherche
pas à prendre de risques parce que si on
prend en D2 il a pas grand chose notre
ami je peux tout échanger
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait c'est ce
qui fait Gawen et il va prendre des deux
facile à jouer pour les Noirs moi j'aime
bien moi tu mets la dame à t'échange
tout tu mets la lame en aussi tu mets tu
essaies de doubler sur la colonne des
alors après il y a des il y a des
scénarios où ça ça pousse par là mais
bon
ou dame 6 il a joué le tour des 8 et
plus saine
c'est un bon coup
amélioration lente alors c'est pas
incroyable ce qu'il a mais il a une
bonne pression avec les Noirs c'est
plutôt lui qui joue pour le gain sans
doute
voyez un juste sur la structure de pions
les blancs sont défaillants c'est pas
une position très sympa je vais pour
Ibara
tout à fait
ouais elle est pas grave elle est pas
grave du tout on va avoir des faiblesses
on peut prendre par exemple jouer tout
simplement jouer dans le 6 menacer
doubler on peut pas tellement contester
la colonne parce qu'il y aura toujours
des pions prises sont en C4 soit 5 donc
il sait qu'il baraque il va un petit peu
souffrir dans cette position au niveau
du temps 5-6 minutes gawani cherche les
meilleurs coups pour mettre la pression
bon c'est pas la position la partie la
plus rigolote il se lève et bien il n'y
a pas cherché gawei il est pas à mon
avis
on va regarder la fin de la partie mais
les deux joueurs se lèvent
dû au délai on a un petit spoiler là
mais à moins d'une gaffe alors gaffe ou
pas non nul nul accepté par Gawen un
petit peu étrange quand même
tu as envie de
tu as envie de la jouer pourquoi pas
franchement
puis ensuite ça bon évidemment c'est pas
gagné
mais bon c'est bizarre qu'il est pas
joué je suis d'accord on est d'accord on
va voir qui tu vas voir qu'il a pris 9
contre Santos la jauge était d'accord
avec la lune mais nous on avait envie de
jouer c'est normal
ou unique autorise
pas
intéressantes
Laura unique ça va être ça va être
compliqué pour elle je vais essayer
d'aller à chercher sur
en bas
[Musique]
le jeu de pièces n'y est plus
on va mettre une tour en 8 et après il y
aura des problèmes
non ça va pas du tout
elle est en grande difficulté
tout à fait
agréable on va se faire taper notre sang
notre droit derrière des idées trois et
tout regarde si on a mis une tour en 8
du coup du coup c'est quand même très
très embêtant cette position on est sous
pression
alors il y a juste le couteau C1 où il
faut faire un petit peu gaffe
qui peut y avoir des motifs de cavalier
prend B5 suite cavalier B6 dame prend B4
pour essayer d'ouvrir le rayon laser je
suis à toi et on a les caméras comme par
magie il aura unique la joueuse donc
souveraine tour huit trois F3 oh là là
c'est terrible et dame c'est évidemment
menace vous prend ces quatre et dame
prend le 3 ouais bon sentez le coup
arriver à envoyer la colonne E le centre
le centre i éclate et le roi blanc qui
est derrière donc ça va faire un point
très certainement pour nos amis pour mes
pour finalement mes poulain
j'ai parlé sur eux j'ai parié sur eux
pas tout mais je gagne finalement une
partie qui était normalement
presque gagné d'avance en termes de
stats il y a 350 points lo quasiment
entre les deux joueurs
il y a pas de quoi faire au nez c'est ça
que tu es en train de me dire ça dépend
de ça même salé mais bon si ça allait
faire le taf contre
en barre sous Mova ben pas de souci pas
de souci on sera à niveau et prana
vimaeler d'avoir une petite poussette
donc je vois bien Denis et demi
comment elle s'appelle la joueuse la
juste
maniaque j'ai oublié son nom en bas
bravo superbe superbe
il prend même pas le matériel son cadres
et beaucoup trop beau il veut il joue
pour le match 10 secondes et surtout
joue le temps contre Laura
Laura qui est en difficulté la cavalier
4 jouer attention
attention comment on fait ici pour
terminer le job de manière propre c'est
pas si évident
on peut mais il a 5 vagues en 10
secondes rendez-vous compte
comment on fait ici
qu'est-ce qui va jouer tu reprends un
cadre peut-être et
après j'avais du mal à finir proprement
parce qu'il y a toujours le cavalier des
trous en l'air
vous serez peut-être j'ai pris un F5 du
coup mais bon c'est bizarre un petit peu
c'est bizarre
qu'on fait juste
[Musique]
et qui prend des 6
on a vu en fait
bien sûr
d'être si clair en fait ce qu'il a joué
c'est juste qu'il a joué très vite et
qu'elle s'est fait avoir avec le temps
on peut pas prendre c'est gagné donc
pour pour nos amis espagnols on va aller
voir si Salem rend la monnaie de sa
pièce
au bon là encore aux Espagnols c'est
beaucoup plus équilibré comme comme
position que ce qu'on vient de voir mais
petite avantage noir majorité propre à
l'aile d'arme alors que côté côté blanc
on a un centre qui commence à s'effriter
puis avoir le centre dans ses positions
là c'est moins intéressant
parce qu'il y a plus de pièces quasiment
sur l'échiquier
tout à fait
on va voir
pourquoi pas
je vais chercher sur
sur un peu galère
une décision il faut prendre des deux
peut-être oublié cavalier B3 derrière ça
va être le pion A4 de moins et
du coup ça va être super vous voyez
un terrible
c'est trop dur
il y a déjà eu deux générations de
grands joueurs genre casse par Orff père
et fils
est-ce que tu as une idée par rapport à
ça il y a évidemment
des Français les petits les petits de
grève les petits bacros ça joue pas mal
hein directement mais à l'échelle
internationale est-ce qu'il y en a qui
ont percé ça c'est dur quand même
ouais c'est trop dur
dans ce cas à l'échelle nationale
évidemment j'ai pensé à Rémy de grave et
Alexandre Bacro qui
suivent les traces de leur papa mais bon
c'est dur on voit où sont arrivés
leur père respectifs ben c'est c'est dur
de
d'aller au-delà en fait ouh là là elle
perd elle perd une qualité elle est
terminée cette partie ouais elle est
terminée égalisation
et
du coup
il se réveille un petit peu là bon c'est
pas grave de nuit et demi pas un drame
nous montrer un petit replay de prana
pour voir comment il a réussi à on va se
faire le replay alors A4
tranquillement
et maintenant je fais des petits guilis
un peu partout
en me disant de mieux en mieux
il vous montre qu'il peut tourner dans
sa position et un moment il a fait jouer
les pions ok
j'aime pas du tout
il a tourné en rond et puis
la combiné et la combinaise pourquoi on
peut pas prendre ici parce qu'il y a
Adam en prise et dame j'ai 5 tours
et l'attaque de maths voilà victoire
facile de pranafla ou Santos Miguel je
voyais je voyais plus beau que ça moi
enfin
on va voir quels sont les appareils de
la ronde 2 mon cher mon cher Kevin
est-ce que tu est-ce que tu peux m'aider
alors les appareils
pour les Norways norme
qui est le numéro un chez c'est Eduardo
et torizaga je pense qu'il y aura donc
les blancs contre le numéro 3 pranaf
est-ce que ça a du sens
en tout cas il va poser des soucis
je crois que Eduardo et toi
va
avoir les blancs
ça finit très vite cette première
partie et ça va reprendre dans un
instant c'est étonnant même
il y a pas eu de notes endiablé ou des
choses comme ça
assez direct ouais avec cette nulle un
petit peu surprendre de Gawen mais bon
pourquoi pas
il aurait pu pousser pas voulu
travailler
et donc à mon avis il va jouer de pranaf
notre ami
notre ami et
toi
mais c'est pas facile c'est pas
important
niveau important
s je suis au courant c'est pranaf en
haut contre Ito isaga en bas c'est mon
je pense le 1 je compte de 3 maintenant
c'est marrant prana il a tourné un petit
peu
bizarrement je voulais voir une
démonstration technique de pranave j'ai
pas eu le droit à cela j'ai le droit à
tourniquer digne d'un tournoi rapide en
Bretagne et du coup il s'en est quand
même bien sorti
le jeune grand maître indien et on va
voir s'il va poursuivre et en tout cas
ils ont fait le taf
les Nords
clairement
on va voir ce que ça donne
on va prendre
c'est le petit moment alors est-ce qu'il
reprenne dans la foulée ou est-ce qu'il
y a des des horaires définis je ne peux
pas vous dire
mais il y a des petites pauses à chaque
fois ils sont pas là le speechasse c'est
c'est mieux à ce niveau là ça reprend en
direct mais c'est des matchs en duo donc
c'est beaucoup plus facile
logistiquement pardon
parce que ils finissent à partir il s'en
va voilà l'autre l'autre vient
mais
restez on va peut-être avoir un beau
match ou pas on sait pas on sait pas on
sait pas tu le sens serré quand même tu
sens la victoire des gnomes mais c'est
vrai ou comment
déjà je pense que là les filles sont pas
bien parti et elles ont forte à faire
donc ça va vraiment je pense qu'elle
vont elles vont souffrir mais ça va
équilibrer le match dans certains sens
donc
mais je trouve vraiment l'équipe
des Noirs un peu au dessus donc on va
voir on va voir je reste je reste sur
sur mon choix Laurent je suis bien
content que tu choisis les crevettes ça
te va bien de choisir les crevettes je
trouve
et tu sais j'ai pensé à
père et fils non mais mère et fille mais
alors pas complètement parce qu'il y a
il y a anacramlink qui est très connu
avec sa mère évidemment puis il y a
quand même qui a une carrière absolument
extraordinaire
juste elle est toujours dans les top
joueuses alors que ça fait ça fait c'est
pas 30 ans 30 ans parce qu'elle est un
top 5 mondial ou quelque chose comme ça
enfin un truc complètement incroyable et
sa fille c'est vrai qu'il est très
connue en tant que stream US mais qui
est finalement je crois pas qu'elle a un
gros vélo quoi elle a 2100
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est dans dans
l'univers du stream extrêmement connu
extrait beaucoup de succès bien sûr mais
finalement tu as fait penser à la fille
fois or ah oui c'est vrai aussi mettre
un arsenal et
ça jeune fille Sabina enfin jeune jeune
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas elle est
elle est peut-être maître et le
printemps aussi le papa c'est une
famille
bien sûr bien sûr c'est une famille de
joueurs donc oui des fois il sort
peut-être que c'est le l'exemple le
finalement le si on fait une moyenne élo
entre oh non on marque pas trop déjà
dépasse ça
honnêtement c'est très c'est tellement
dur pour les enfants de passer
c'est tellement qu'on parlait
comme Zidane Zidane je crois que son
fils il commence à faire une petite
carrière pro va tous et tous enfin pas
mal de ses fils en fait
joue au foot mais avec des succès
limités bon voilà on a vu on a vu Marcus
Thuram en dernière Coupe du monde quand
même qui a été rappelé dernière minute
mais titularisé en finale de Coupe du
monde quand même donc c'est pas en fait
non pas de titularisé en tout cas il est
rentré en cours de match mais il a été
il a été très très bon c'est rare que
les les fils ou fille dépassent il y a
un exemple j'ai un seul exemple en tête
au rugby rugby on a vraiment
des fils de qui sont très très forts
ils sont très très fort donc
peut-être pas le piquélo doit être à peu
près similaire
donc ouais ça existe c'est vrai ça
existe mais effectivement c'est pas
c'est pas une majorité clairement
alors cette deuxième partie
ils attendent
peut-être avoir
pour battre son père c'est une idée
Laurent nous l'avait pas sorti ce
spontanément comment battre vapeur aux
échecs qui marche pas avec tout le monde
sont prêts à Laurent on devrait avoir
ils ont pas de même
recommencer là oh non il a l'air un peu
détente là il tourne saga que vous savez
il y a le léger délai donc c'est
vraiment quand l'échiquier apparaît
sur le stream qu'on peut se lancer
en tout cas ils ont l'air moi jaloux ils
ont l'air tu vois d'avoir chaud
il est au Venezuela il fait 35 degrés
dehors tu vois il en peut plus
mon pauvre mon pauvre Kevin qui a pas vu
un rayon Kevin qui est en Bretagne qui a
pas vu un rain de soleil depuis 3 mois
et demi rendez-vous compte de soleil
aujourd'hui c'est limite le temps aller
en terrasse le problème c'est plus 95%
du temps si si c'est les stats j'ai vu
j'ai vu la météo j'ai regardé la météo
ce matin temps extraordinaire
malheureusement il fait un peu frisquet
comme on dit par chez nous
rendez-vous compte et il tourise AGA il
a pas vu il a pas vu un pull depuis 3
mois et demi pendant Kévin
tu sens qu'il a un endroit il fait chaud
quoi c'est ça ça ça c'est très agaçant
c'est bon
ouais mais il a pas des chics
ils sont là les mecs importants ils sont
un bloc il fait moins le malin
on va voir on va voir faut être
patiente parce que c'est un bazar absolu
dans les parties
pour les voir mais je crois qu'il y a
rien qui est pour l'instant on n'a rien
en tout cas j'essaie de regarder mais
malheureusement
pour l'instant c'est calme
très très calme
est-ce que j'ai des messages de quand ça
va commencer et bien non
gaillard j'ai du soleil en Bretagne il
faut pas écouter l'or en fait aux échecs
vous pouvez l'écouter en dehors
vous pouvez vous pouvez sans problème
mais effectivement j'aurais du soleil à
la montagne à Gaïa je vois que tu
m'envie mais c'est vrai que je suis bien
content de partir à la montagne la
semaine prochaine
idylliques
aller à la neige comme ça pour un petit
breton alors ces adultes là c'est ça
il y a combien
de personnes environ et si tu veux
là ce qui est top c'est que je vais
pouvoir ma donner à mon sport favori
le ski parce que tu imagines bien que je
suis un skieur comme Luc alpha un petit
peu ce que j'ai appris à 30 ans et ma
monitrice une certaine Aurélie LD que tu
connais j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de
progrès grâce à elle
je fais imaginer mais les séances de ski
où elle t'apprend à faire du ski dans ça
doit être beau tu veux pas filmé
en fait maintenant ça va maintenant mais
c'est vrai que la première fois je peux
te dire que ça a été assez modeste
d'autant plus que la monitrice a eu un
accident après 15 secondes de
démonstration
donc du coup c'était assez c'était assez
modeste
les scores les scores bonne question non
ça c'est les scores de la ronde à ce que
vous avez en bas là c'est 00 pour cette
ronde par contre vous allez escorte tout
en bas du stream donc à droite là ça
doit être en bas en bas de l'échiquier
vous avez le score global un ennemi deux
et demi pour les
Norway nommés parce que là c'est le
score de la ronde donc voilà rentre par
ronde et score du match logo mais vous
pouvez
et ça je sais pas ce qui se passe ça
fait toujours que ça me fait le coup
alors nous je ne fais pas qu'appelle la
grande c'est un tournoi que j'aimais
beaucoup
le joueur qu'on voit à l'écran
malheureusement bah je jouais comme j'ai
dit j'ai ça à la montagne et
la la problématique pas c'est que
Capelle la grande était très très fort
et là ils sont en train de recréer leur
tournoi hyper fort je sais qu'il y a de
plus en plus de monde parce que
qu'appelle la grande c'est le plus gros
open français en termes de niveau avec
une palanquée de grand maître il y avait
théorie Zaga avec ses 26-50 il y a eu
camski il y avait déjà presque 2700
certaines années et surtout une densité
de Grand Maître hyper importante donc
c'était génial
et ça avait commencé en fait mais c'est
bizarre les parties comment je fais pour
voir que les parties en cours tu vois je
suis pas je suis pas à l'aise avec le
avec le site parce qu'en fait moi j'ai
une liste de parties je te raconte pas
bien sûr après tu peux les enlever tu
peux les mettre à la poubelle
et je peux les mettre à la poubelle
d'accord et comme ça je vois ok c'est ce
que je vais faire parce que sinon
en Bretagne on dit on dit ça je peux te
dire
ouais donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce que tu veux nous raconter sur
cette sur cette ouverture mon cher
Kevin
pas grand chose on a la structure fixée
c'est pour ça qu'on a le droit de
balancer un fou comme ça et on va
travailler autour de du pion des 5 qu'on
va pouvoir fixer c'est prendre des
cavaliers F4 à un moment on aura les
bonnes pièces
et ce qu'on rock dans ces positions
c'est toujours un
choix à risqué oui et non parce que à
chaque H4 qui pourrait être intéressant
pour pour essayer de balancer sur le roi
blanc puisqu'on a bloqué le centre il y
a attention il y a la petite poussée F3
en contre qui existerait on a cavalier
F4 comme on l'a dit et on pourrait
travailler j'ai pensé une potion de
française inversée avec un fiancéto
voilà très intéressant très intéressant
cette partie on va voir on a Laura
eunuque qui joue face à Miguel Santos
Ruiz on va voir c'est peut-être pour
pour les noirs elle est noire Laura elle
va essayer de tenir j'ai pas changé la
caméra évidemment mais tout roue 3 voilà
tu auras
maintenant on va voir tout le monde
c'est ok pour tout le monde mais très
très tranquille on a
Ibara contre
alors là j'ai pas vu le temps ouais oui
c'est vrai qu'elle est beaucoup moins
bien au temps attention alors ça c'est
connu c'est une fille d'or
avec un dessin assez rapide
c'est un très bon coup pour mettre la
pression qui est V5 double
et là on n'a pas de porte de sortie
exactement donc ça c'est fini
double chaque très esthétique ce que
nous montre
pour justement
bien empêcher cette petite arnaque et
fou bécaque ouh là là ça ça ressemble à
une prépa de notre ami barala alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe Kevin sur dame
prend B4
il faut trouver quelque chose de concret
donc est-ce que ce serait pas dame G2
parce que il va falloir faire quelque
chose
ouais parce que attention il faut que tu
restes là pour pour protéger ton donc
proposer l'échange dames
et maintenant on va voir ça c'est de la
théorie
donc faut faire gaffe il faut vraiment
voilà
c'est juste un petit peu de précision on
avait les idées il faut les mettre dans
l'ordre et un petit truc comme ça
attention ça peut aller vite aussi
ça fait très très peur
Ibara très bien préparé face à Salem on
les voit pas à l'écran mais là c'est une
mauvaise surprise pour Salem qui a 5 20
douteuses on connaît bien à ce niveau là
parce que bon la fille d'or quand même
jouer
bon il va peut-être essayer d'égaliser
ouais mais alors c'est déjà
pris tu vois un mauvais moi direction là
ça peut ça peut se terminer très vite ce
genre d'histoire attention Salem et on a
aussi Gabin Jones qui doit être quelque
part par là il est là kawayne fasse ça
avant ça vous va
je suis mal prononcé à la Bretonne il a
les blancs en kawaii il joue pas 4 j'ai
fait une bretonne
voilà position ici
en tout cas sauf qu'on n'a pas mis notre
pion des 4 ça y est c'est fait on peut
pas on peut jamais prendre parce qu'il y
a ces 6 qui traînent petit rock autour
des 1 à 5 ça c'est délicat pour les
noirs
pour toujours au cavaliers en B4
je trouve ça un peu hâtif A4 très
honnêtement mais bon la position blanche
est quand même très agréable
parce que finalement il faut jouer tout
refs pour pouvoir jouer cavalier à 6
il faut jouer ouais si alors ou calculer
ça
je peux le prendre en force
un peu bizarre à l'oeil
mais bon pourquoi pas
ça peut être délicat pour les Noirs ce
genre d'histoire on va voir
on va voir en retourne chez chez prana
vous allez jouer cette partie elle me
plaît bien entre cette fille dehors là
un peu romantique
un supporter acharné toi en fait non non
pas du tout qu'est-ce que tu as vu sur
X3
pour que faire en sorte qu'il se passe
quelque chose
qui est important
je sais pas pour être fait ça par
exemple je fais ça voilà
bon faut 3 quand même
je t'avais promis je vais pas me dire
que je n'ai pas vu hein je l'avais
annoncé
on a dit qu'on calme le jeu au calme le
jeu
ouais
je sais pas quoi faire
exceptionnel vous avez vu
non mais je voulais mettre mes tours au
centre tu vois un truc mais je suis un
peu lent là pour le coup
ok non il faut faire quelque chose de
plus de plus concret mais j'ai pas
trouvé parce que faut 3 ça attaque la
dame et j'ai le temps de tirer
du coup je calme l'initiative des Noirs
après
ben voilà peut-être un coup de damage 5
tu vois on peut bon de toute façon
maintenant ça à peu près égale cette
position Laurent sans doute je refais
une arme
fougère petit rock il faut vérifier
cavalier E5 autour des 8 d'abord
je sais pas tu vois ça peut être un
travail
peut-être là juste
F3 c'est toujours pareil on a pas trop
envie de le faire
est-ce que tu menaces vraiment quelque
chose en fait où est-ce que c'est juste
parce qu'il faut faire gaffe des
cavaliers F3 tours je crois pas sinon je
joue tout rade1 on va mettre en place le
mode anti jeu si c'est possible ou H3 si
vraiment on avait besoin bon tu vas t'en
sortir en étant précis tu vas t'en
sortir on est on est d'accord c'est
peut-être pas là finalement c'est une
partie prometteuse mais il a mis un coup
un gros coup de frein salam salaire on
va les voir ce jeune prennent avant qui
m'a l'air d'être un joueur très très
intéressant face à autorisaga
qu'il est en train de faire je trouve
c'est jeu simple il y a une petite
pression avec ces deux tours
très très bien placé ça donne pas trop
envie de jouer ça avec les Noirs non
c'est vrai on n'a pas réussi à comme tu
le disais on est un peu pacifié par là
et protéger spiant là si on arrive pas à
faire vraiment du contre-jour à le roi
finalement on est moins bien avec les
Noirs j'ai l'impression que ça se passe
pas très bien pour pour prendre
c'est très chaud quel est le temps ouais
4 minutes chacun tu me diras bon
et tous
de trouer le genre noir mais faut jouer
assez pratique je pense
et quand on voit comment prendre lui a
tourné dans une position il y a
peut-être encore moins de choses il va
falloir s'en inspirer et on se rappelle
de Laura qui était très très mal au
temps face à
Miguel est-ce que ça s'est améliorer
elle a toujours 5 minutes de retard
rendez-vous compte
que c'est intéressant quand même
affaibli le roi adverse en échange du
pion de moins mais
le Time est dangereux quoi ça sent la
pression à un moment
et bien sûr ce genre de jeu joueur à
2300 c'est pas du tout les mêmes quand
ils sont sous pression autant il y a
moyen de les faire craquer plus
facilement qu'un joueur à 2005 2006
donc attention chargée de vraiment
se dépêcher de pas être trop rapidement
sous la minute en tout cas parce que
sinon on pourrait assister à un drame
qui prend des quatre et là devine ce
qu'elle a joué voilà je tombe de ma
chaise quasiment cavalier F4 alors si ça
ça marche c'est énorme mais ça a l'air
de pas du tout marcher puis on prend un
FK dame prend F4 jouer très rapidement
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
elle s'est crue là ça marche pas ça
marche que dans les films ce genre de
truc bah surtout que cavalier
tout simplement une pièce de plus
légalisation quasi certaine là des
Espagnols
alors une nuit qui passe ouais deux
points partis ou elle a pas eu sa chance
il va perdre
c'est
pour l'instant
le maillon faible de cette équipe alors
c'est normal aussi la moins de points et
l'eau mais elle n'a pas été très
dangereuse autant
tout à l'heure
on avait vu la loisirlandaise défendre
contre ma mégaraf crânement sa peau elle
avait été vraiment forte et là
Laura unique est un peu lente et en plus
là la gaffe
on a pas trop compris ce qu'elle a voulu
faire non craquage c'est plié un tour
H20 pour arriver on a vraiment tout
sécurisé on va voir si
mauvais ça sert mieux ou pas comment tu
dis là
OK
c'est pas si simple enfin cette position
pour les noirs on est un peu
on a un peu bloqué
ça peut pas être bon
il faut toujours est-ce que j'ai moyen
de retrouver facilement je crois pas
je crois pas honnêtement
il a une bonne avance au temps il va
pouvoir travailler la pose il y a quand
même le fouet 8 qui est toujours bien
embarrassant
en mètres carrés
AGA qui se comportait comme si c'était
ou pardon mais j'ai oublié de mettre le
studio
la technique de Laurent
perçoit pas tout ça on le voit pas ça se
voit pas
quel aisance
et
Ibara et Salem Sala on fait match nul
Laurent on vient de voir
cela s'afficher et ouais ouais on
l'avait dit il a serré le jeu il a senti
l'expérience aussi fait que voilà on
joue une prépa adverse c'est une
position très très compliqué ben voilà
il met un énorme coup de frein et il
essaie de faire nul ce qu'il a réussi
sans
bien vu en pratique ouais ouais bien sûr
le bon choix pratique et en équipe
encore plus
donc on a gaven Jones avec les Blancs
contre eux à votre samova du coup il y a
une hulule il y a une nul il y a trois
deux pour les normes mais
l'aura eu une pièce de moins face à
Santos donc ça serait une égalisation on
a ces deux parties qui restentitorisaga
contre pranave et gaming Jones qui est
très très bien là on va pas se mentir
contre ça on va et en plus
beaucoup de du temps en plus salut
carabistouille qui est là qui nous
rejoint sur sur twitch
le retour et oui
ils m'ont fait un truc
pour la première intervention de Take
fresh vous m'avez fait c'est une caméra
cachée franchement
bien sûr
préparer je t'avais dit c'était c'était
assez long quoi
donc voilà et encore c'était un petit
peu mieux que les scènes que tu as parce
que toi tu dois travailler par zoom
alors que là ils avaient fait le travail
assez propre au niveau des caméras mais
cependant il y a des choses à faire
bon là on voit domination cavalier E5 le
fou qui va peut-être revenir à manger 2
on travaille le pion C6 faible sur pour
tout la partie et ça va être une galère
avec les Noirs d'ailleurs elle a plus de
temps elle a 4 Caran 0,40 contre 4,40
non on peut pas jouer comme ça là
c'est trop dur quoi c'est trop dur
parfois faut simplifier tant pis il faut
faire un coup à feu comme ça voilà tant
pis tu au moins tu ok peut-être tu vas
perdre ce pion mais au moins tu fais
jouer un peu tes pièces tu auras fois 6
tu vas prendre B2 déjà tu as ta fois si
tu vas prendre B2 et ok il y a peut-être
un peu de jeu tu vois ça va être plus
simple à jouer au moins à 40 secondes
gestion du temps qui m'inquiète parce
que ça va être injouable après sous
pression du temps ça va être la boulette
et puis et puis voilà quoi c'est je vois
arriver c'est une autre question
d'ailleurs de notre ami dans le chat
on donne le thème et après toujours les
bons coulants c'est facile et là c'est
fini en fait
question n'hésitez pas
merci merci
et du coup elle a plus de temps
d'un V2
il peut jouer tours
alors est-ce qu'on peut jouer tour B7 ou
pas 6 du coup c'est dur
et si on prend ici tu reprends
Terminator
DC1 oh là là que c'est dur à jouer et 14
secondes donc
c'est trop dur peut-être des seins ici
pour pour essayer de faire mal
je sais pas je serais hyper tenté de
jouer des seins comme menaçant le
discret pour prendre cette prends aussi
on peut aussi jouer un coup de damocal
je sais pas un coup de centralisation
avec toujours la même idée
si mal mais en fait avec avec le temps
ça serait bien
et bien sûr Laurent proposer Dame des
dessins pour menacer des choses et faire
craquer l'adversaire que des coups
vicieux tu as vu hein
c'est dès qu'il y a moins de 10 secondes
en jour on joue les menaces en un coup
je vous le dis toujours très simple
paire une pièce voilà et voilà
et il va le voir il va le voir
évidemment qui va le voir tout reprendre
et cette si tu reprends des 7 il y a
tout reprend C8 et c'est jouer tout
reprend des 7 la gaffe et voilà vous
allez pouvoir avoir la tête d'aigle et
elle a abandonné abandon abandon
c'est hyper fort mais là quatre minutes
dans la vue sur 10 minutes c'est trop
possible
et il nous reste encore la dernière
partie entre
unique elle a toujours en train de jouer
toujours une pièce de moins bon elle
s'en sort plus ou moins il reste prendre
la vitrise AGA qui va être probablement
la plus intéressante du coup et
ils ont fini c'est terminé ouais c'est
gagné
c'est égalité parfaite après 8 parties
et bien
Jones intéressant moi pour le suspense
les deux jeunes femmes sont en grande
difficulté c'est normal à la rendre des
points et l'eau mais il faut toutes les
deux elles sont obligées de jouer plus
vite parce que
on voit pas que on voit que ce ne sont
pas des choses de Bullet etc donc sous
pression on voit que c'est trop dur pour
elle donc il faut absolument se dépêcher
pas le choix tout à fait un j'essaie un
truc là non je vais pas trop
spécialiste pour jouer relativement
lendemain en plus
mais faites le taf à ce niveau là c'est
important on va se faire un break a mis
parcours mon cher mon cher keV avec
plaisir et après on revient pour la fin
du match et peut-être le premier est-ce
que tu crois à l'égalité au premier
tie-break et on n'est pas d'accord sur
ce coup-là donc ça pue le tyback cette
histoire c'est possible c'est possible
ça serait bon ça serait très beau on
espère on espère en achetant du mais là
quoi de mieux quatre partout deux
équipes au coude à coude ah merci de
nous suivre restez bien avec nous le
meilleur est à venir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour je te vois plus
Kévin
j'avais vu que j'avais disparu mais je
me suis dit on va aller en live et
peut-être que ça va réapparaître
c'est parti
il faut pas réduire
ça c'est c'est vrai que j'ai déjà fait
cette faute là alors on apprend toujours
un de nos erreurs attends je vois pas
les parties attends je vais essayer je
peux les parties attendez je vais
appuyer sur donc on a égalité parfaite 4
4 sabastonne 2,5
on a chacune nos équipes favorites
Laurent espagnol
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'on a pas de partie en cours
là pour le coup non il attend
bon on attend de voir ça va arriver tout
ça donc on va voir qui là on va avoir
hitorisaga
[Musique]
bon je sais pas je ferai je ferai quand
on quand on les verra allez
ils font des bons petits breaks
astronomiques quoi ça pourrait être
beaucoup plus dynamique ça devrait
le speedcha c'est super à ce niveau là
comme je le disais c'est très dynamique
ils ont pas le choix de toute façon le
format fait que c'est très dynamique et
puis en plus ce sont des gros gros qui
sont là donc on les fait pas attendre
mais là c'est vrai que il y a des bonnes
poses alors que dès le match est fini il
pourrait dire bah on reprend à chaque
fois quasiment directement on laisse un
petit break moi un break au milieu quoi
et après sinon c'est deux minutes et ça
reprend
les gros matchs Zaga contre les Blancs
contre Ito isaga
Santos aussi contre Salem
et pranables doit faire le travail ça
commence allez c'est parti
c'est parti pour la partie entre Gabin
Jones et enfin pas tout à fait partie
mais bon moi j'ai cru que j'y ai cru
j'ai vu un échiquier apparaître j'étais
tout fou
exactement et
est-ce que est-ce que les espagnols vont
faire mal ou pas dans cette ronde
on va voir en tout cas toujours en
T-shirt très très agaçant
il est très sympa aussi
donc on lui en veut pas
salut coco et au 4 c'est 5 c'est 3 ok
une à lapine voilà
globalement donc match par équipe de 4
on le rappelle
tournoi mondial sur surchascom avec les
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui sont
dispatchés dans pas mal d'équipes
puisqu'on doit ne pas excéder 25-50 de
moyenne et l'eau
Magnus Carlsen Fabienne ocarwana
grave bien évidemment demain 16h30
ensuite
Alexander grichu dans la même équipe de
Blitz stream
ouais ça sera ça sera quand même ça sera
du lourd et d'autres qu'on oublie Gabin
Jones qui est quand même pas un débutant
autorisé non plus vous voyez des joueurs
qui sont depuis très très longtemps à
plus de 1600 mais là ça joue très serré
à la pine attention à 4 et on va faire à
5 à 6
salut ouais salut à tous
c'est qui contre qui c'est les ouais
c'est vrai que c'est pas marqué c'est
qu'on le rappelle c'est les Spanish
Maniac schrims contre les Norways normes
alors on voit la tête du Père Noël et
j'ai un petit j'ai un léger souci que je
vais régler on peut pas s'améliore de
jour en jour l'important
Kevin c'est quand même de tu vois c'est
comme aux échecs c'est de faire une
meilleure partie peu importe le niveau
auquel on va finalement on a tous été
débutant mais c'est de finalement d'être
sur une pente ascendante c'est ça mais
faut pas trop tout donner directement si
on veut plus progresser
de réserver un petit peu j'ai bien
commencé du coup
et victoire assuré pour le Blist stream
victoire assuré contraireigazie et
compagnie rien n'est assuré je te le dis
grand Perceval c'est évidemment une très
très belle équipe de bistrime mais alors
comment ça se terminer on sait pas
et c'est ça qui fait la beauté du sport
aussi c'est pas l'avance nous dit après
le fait d'avoir une pause plus longue ça
permet au capitaine de donner des
consignes d'ouverture de stratégie en
fonction des résultats obtenus
parce que pour le dernier match tu as
raison après avant
ouais si vraiment il y a un écart jouer
un peu plus solide mais ça va très très
vite ça se voit très très vite les
conseils
donc voilà on va aller voir les autres
appareils de la ronde sans les caméras
donc ne vous énervez pas dans le chat on
voit Santos mais on ne les voit pas
l'image donc Salem qui joue contre
Santos voilà une position typique de
défense Nîmes the witch où on a on a ce
fou mais en échange on va avoir des
pions pendant qui peuvent être faibles
alors force ou faiblesse c'est toujours
la même question exception pendant bien
sûr
qu'on va essayer de réveiller par le
coup D5 à un moment ça serait vraiment
terrible de le mettre dans de bonnes
conditions pour taper le roi noir c'est
ça mais il est assez en ce qui fait
notre ami Santos vous voyez sur il se
prépare il se prépare
il évite la poussée des seins car en
prenant 6 dessins qu'on prend c'est tout
et voilà
pour l'instant
il défend le cavalier F6 bon position
très très normale d'ouverture on va
aller voir ce qui se passe entre elles
en difficulté
les joueuses dans ce match et on a Laura
unique qui est encore une fois vous
voyez l'élément marquant de ce de ce
début de partie c'est c'est la pendule
la pendule ah non 849
c'est la paire de fou mais comme c'est
une position fermée
ça reste raisonnable pour les noirs très
très honnête comme comme début de partie
va falloir qu'elle joue un peu plus vite
quand même ça tire toujours le Conseil
bien sûr et on a le dangereux preneur
face à un bord de samova il a les Noirs
qu'est-ce qu'il nous fait là il nous a
fait un début de partie
pas académique
c'est fait avoir on a l'impression hein
normalement on joue B4 pour fermer parce
que regarder après ça on fait tourner
une tête tout à fait correcte tour à 7
et des 4 maintenant on va éventuellement
pousser des cinq faux 3 qui peut arriver
qu'est-ce qu'on fait déjà
pas génial cavalier E4 sans doute
en B7 Laurent
je pense que tu as raison pour le coup
mais bon je peux jouer tranquillement je
joue comme ça et pourquoi tu aurais
résolu tes problèmes tu vas faire F5 non
tu es pas un joueur de F5 toi
alors des cinq peut-être tout de suite
mais même comme ça tu es pas encore
sorti de l'auberge je fais un coup de
Tours un peu mieux que je suis d'accord
accordé il a joué D6
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait après des cinq
il nous explique attention
en train de dégoupiller un petit peu
voilà
faut pas qu'il tombe en plus parce que
tu as tout mis tu as mis la maison à
Saint-Malo des cinq jouets puis on prend
des 5 blitzer faut 3 et à regarder mais
il y a assez 5 on peut aussi jouer sur
le clouage
on peut aussi commencer par créer des
quatre par exemple qui est 4 est
intéressant beaucoup mais puis on prend
des 5 simple
3 et sur Key BD7 peut-être alors c'est
ça l'idée
pour les blancs
aussi éventuellement des décises ou des
tours en B7 suite D6
peut-être que son idée c'est cavaliers
B6 mais alors que c'est moche
moi je pense pas que ce soit vraiment
une idée c'est plutôt qu'il subit un peu
les éléments il va faire son possible
en très très dur pour lui il a joué qui
est B7 quand même je pense que va
suivre au cahier des cadres comme tu
l'as dit pour pour s'infiltrer là sur
les cases
ou ça va être dur ça pourrait être une
grosse surprise là
et un tournant du match parce qu'il faut
vraiment que font ça que le match il va
se jouer enfin je sais pas si tu le sens
comme moi mais moi je sens le match il
va jouer sur un exploit peut-être à
cette honte de de Laura nuque ou de ou
de en bas s'il y a une des deux qui fait
un point qui a été en grande difficulté
là une position
très agréable sans avoir quasiment rien
fait donc c'est super
on a gawei qui sont à l'image donc et
voilà une partie un peu bizarre là
donc c'est la fameuse à vapine avec le
pion qui pousse tout du long voilà on a
un pion a est-ce qu'il est fort ou
faible il a fixé un petit peu l'aile
dame maintenant est-ce qu'il en
profitera
bon ça a l'air plus agréable quand même
pour les blancs mais bon les Noirs ont
réussi à s'activer donc c'est pas si
clair cette position
très compliqué stratégiquement
c'est potentiellement quand même dans
les finales il faut le dire ce pion à 7
ça peut être très très dangereux parce
que si on paiera
donc il faut plutôt jouer des coups des
coups actifs mais les pièces blanches
sont quand même très bizarres
c'est pour ça que c'est dur à dire moi
je saurai pas ici si je suis mieux au
moins bien honnêtement bien sûr pièce
blanche bizarre Cavalia 5 bizarre le fou
c'est un bizarre tout à trois Damas 4
c'est bizarre vous voyez c'est pour ça
que le jugement de la position n'est pas
aisé et évidemment on aspire à 6 de
fixation
pour plus tard
salut à toi
hello Yoha
quoi on est on est dominé
d'un coup les Noirs ont réussi à trouver
trouver des bonnes cartes alors pourquoi
tours C8 la jauge chez c'est excité on
l'a vu il y a pas ça
je regardais
cavalier F5 mais cavaliers E6 c'est
peut-être j'ai pensé aussi mais je me
suis dit Dame des 7 et finalement
et alors il y aurait il y aura un coup
intermédiaire
et si on fait puis on prend et puis on
prend mais on a le petit échec
intermédiaire qui nous perdra
contrecoing intermédiaire et ça ça fait
très très mal et ensuite on prend la
dame donc toi
je pense qu'il va le voir il a l'air pas
réveillé
il y a déjà plein soleil
super looping hello magnifique allez
pseudo tweet ça fait rêver quand même il
a pas vu
mais ouais c'est toujours plus facile tu
vois on te le dis tu le trouves quoi
en plus le thème il l'a parce qu'il a
fait de la MA F3 avec la petite idée
d'arme prendrait 5 tout à fait mais il a
pas pensé cavalier prend le 6
il faut regarder tous les échelles qui
est notamment
pranaf contre
sa caméra parce que là je sens que ça
je sens que ça peut être ça peut être un
moment un moment très très important
pour
il a fait que j'ai 4 donc il cherche
à noyer le poisson
des complications
comment je le
fais juste
relief 5 serait embêtant c'est dommage
quand même de donner ce fou non
exactement
mais bon je sais pas trop le mettre j'ai
pas trouvé de tactique
j'aimerais bien ne pas concéder cavalier
prend le 3 dans de mauvaise conditions
attention au temps un Bart sumova ouais
ça c'est ça un prana on l'a vu dans la
première il a joué très pratique
sans se casser la tête tu te rappelles
ces petits coups là c'était vraiment à 4
x 6
un coup à gauche un coup à droite et je
tourne le tournis et puis voilà et je te
rase à la fin parce que tu as plus de
temps
c'était pas beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça
et du coup qu'est-ce qu'on joue sur ce
quel G4
quelle est la solution
je sais pas facile pas facile en train
de découper
pranafrage
au sens de figuré bien évidemment je
fais mal hein
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre en place
le garde mon four
moi je garderai bien mon fou mais pas
faire beaucoup mieux que ça enfin je
peux pas faire beaucoup mieux
c'est ça ce que j'aurais fait en plus
vite dommage que
pourquoi pas faute 4 ce sont des biens
sur le sur le long terme qui est ici ce
peut arriver
noir très vite et dois jouer vite doit
mettre la pression au temps
est-ce que on est dans une équipe oui
alors
kevin est dans l'équipe de Guingamp mais
qui est en division 3 de la prochaine
sleague comme au foot
donc non on n'est pas dans des équipes
juju était j'ai joué pour les les
Marseillais migraines à l'époque et les
normes qui sont en train de jouer et qui
recrutent à l'étranger vraiment ils font
leur marché il faudrait marcher très
opérationnel c'est ça
à l'époque avec Magnus j'ai joué avec
Magnus c’était pas moi je pourrais ça un
peu la légère et Magnus non moi il
demandait des explications sur les coups
jouer
ce qui était un peu
c'est un peu cavalier de sa part
non seulement il faut jouer mais en plus
il faut s'expliquer ensuite pourquoi du
comment on a joué des coûts qui lui
plaisent pas et puis il voit les trucs
quoi tu peux pas essayer de lui monter
un bateau pour essayer de justifier
ta partie qui l'a déjà vu il a déjà
réalisé il a déjà compris ce qui allait
pas et qui te pose de la question
la question pénible voilà
là où ça fait mal
très bonne partie cette fois
dans
une gestion du temps
moyenne je dirais parce qu'elle a
l'avantage depuis tout à l'heure donc
elle pourrait conserver une avance au
temps c'est pas ce qu'elle fait elle va
être précise c'est bien dans l'esprit
après faut qu'elle faut qu'elle aille
jusqu'au bout de la démarche alors
est-ce qu'on fait qui est ici tout de
suite ou est-ce qu'on prend d'abord
j'ai toujours la patronne
est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour des
échiquiers avant les
ultrason
contre Salem qu'est-ce que ça donne et
ça donne
ça avance il est très très bien il est
très très bien Salem ça c'est un bon
point pour les pour la Norvège et on
voit des faiblesses avec ce cahier des 6
qui est un monstre qui attaque ici c'est
c'est très très compliqué là pour pour
Santos de Salem qu'est-ce qui se passe
chez gaët-jones
c'est pas clair chez Gawen je commence à
bien aimer les Noirs là du coup il a
moins de temps
qui vient de jouer il venait de jouer
mais bon
cavaliers des trois ça peut aller vite
ce genre de choses ok donc avantage
Espagne c'est un match très serré
tu gardes tout le monde sous tension
[Musique]
3 pour
égaliser et piquer le cavalier F4
comme ça j'ai moins souffrir
effectivement
il a pas beaucoup de temps en plus donc
peut-être calmer le jeu calmos c'est ce
qui devrait faire
nul quand même plus proche de nul que
l'autre ça c'est sûr exactement et on a
une autre partie avec unique
face à
Ibara et ma foi elle est pas mal
et le temps de 50 toujours un elles ont
du mal
les jeunes femmes a bien bien garder du
temps mais elle a l'air de faire une
grosse partie elle fait une grosse
partie et elle est mieux et ça pourrait
être la surprise à double victoire des
joueuses moins bien classées mais
attention parce que dans le grand zynote
avec les fous de couleurs opposés on
voit bien les petits tricks arrivaient
avec le rayon laser là sur le roi
ça peut
ça peut magouiller encore cette position
on va voir si
bizarre pour dame c'est de ouais ouais
ça ne le fait pas chez vous
qui allez prendre et maintenant on a le
choix c'est ça
le travail je veux bien
il y a des fous des cartes pour deux
est-ce qu'on doit les craintes c'est pas
dit
non mais ça fait réfléchir encore et
comme elle a dépensé pas mal de temps
sur des coupes peut-être qui le
méritaient moins a peut-être qu'on peut
jouer juste dames et dedans pour revenir
parce que ça doit être dur de ouais
je voulais je regardais des kssis des
choses comme ça mais tu peux peut-être
ouais je prends et bon tant pis alors
c'est pas beau hein
mais là faut faire attention il y a un
choix en fait je crois qu'elle peut pas
sauver tous ses pions c'est ça qui doit
la faire réfléchir il faut donner dans
le bonnes conditions
je serais plutôt tenté de
d'un
Masseron mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
ce que j'ai froid pour t'en faire mettre
à tout ranger je vais plutôt mettre la
je vais plutôt mis là la dame en P3 du
coup pour être proche de cette tour tu
vois pour avoir des dames
ça dépend bien des cinq en plus
truc comme ça et là ça enferme et je
masse je me sens
maintenant donc c'est parfait donc la
case de la dame c'est B3 bienvenue et
pas et est-ce qu'elle va jouer vite
surtout
une minute une minute une minute dame
c'est deux
mais c'est sûr parce que vous voyez à la
configuration on avait un petit peu
annoncé à l'avance elle a très bien joué
et là ça devient un peu n'importe quoi
en terme de gestion d'avantage ce que
vous voyez un si la jauge indique que ça
s'est équilibré c'est ce qu'on a donné
un pion elle a décompense mais c'est pas
clair et le problème c'est qu'elle joue
une minute contre 3 minutes contre un
joueur qui est plus fort qu'elle elle a
fait une très jolie partie et la
valorise pas à cause de sa gestion du
temps et vraiment il y a des gros écarts
et là c'est le elle doit sentir qu'en
plus la position lui glisse entre les
mains
et en même temps elle est un petit peu
cherché est-ce que Laura onuque va faire
va faire mieux c'est
on va voir on va voir tout ça mais là je
crois que on donne pas cher de sa peau
en fait
avec peu de temps comme ça un pion de
moi faut trouver des compensations c'est
vraiment pas évident
on les a vu à l'oeuvre yosha là les
jeunes femmes et sous pression du temps
elle elle craquouille et du coup mais
c'est pas fini effectivement mais kf5 là
C5 d'ailleurs mais il y a du calculer ça
pas du tout fini mais c'est compliqué
pour truc comme ça qu'est-ce que ça
donne j'en sais rien c'est le gros bazar
et ça me fait peur bah voilà là elle va
cramer encore
ah non elle a réussi à jouer avec les tu
reprends des six jouer vite ça c'est
bien ça ça en 40 secondes
elle joue vraiment bien et je trouve
c'est dommage
au niveau de la gestion du temps
en pratique mais attention quand même
il y a les rentrer en Internet et après
stable tu as vu sa caméra disparaît ça
peut jouer des tours 20 secondes
ouh là là là tourbé 6 je le feu là qui
prend 4 ah il joue vite je veux dire
parce que voilà bah il met la presse et
là il a fait une partie
c'est assez cochon ce qui nous a fait
pranave
mais là maintenant il va gagner
tranquillement avec son temps en plus je
vois bien deux minutes 20 secondes
12 secondes
il fait bien le taf alors il a fait une
partie vraiment affreuse accoucher
dehors une ouverture surtout en fait non
c'est l'ouverture qui a été vraiment
accouché dehors mais après
il a continué dans la cochonnerie en
mettant la pression au temps plutôt que
essayer de trouver l'ex solution et
chicken il a essayé de jouer pratique
des coups et ça marche malheureusement
pour faire des menaces
trop passif mais en même temps ce cabrer
en défense quand on a plus trop de temps
c'est un grand classique mais bon il
faut essayer de de faire mieux
ça commence à déconner F4 c'est un
affaiblissement et le cavalier 3
qui joue au temps
je vous la montre
on peut pas lui en vouloir
la petite fille elle est sympa quand
même mais bon en plus ce roi est
tellement faible que dame 1 et hyper
tentant
il a pris en direct mais il va jouer T3
il menace toujours tout et c'est
complètement
terminé à mon avis
comme on l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
peut-être tourner vite
du temps mais
j'aime pas il a joué un peu vite je
trouve
et mieux à faire que ça
est-ce qu'on aurait pas un petit
cavalier cavalier 4
et ben oui avoir vu je peux faire ça
pour être fin de
mais bon
sur cavalier 4 pas de bol pour des œufs
MC3 attention il convertit pas bien
notre ami indien là au moins je dis ça
là je l'aime bien
c'est parti il veut faire ça il veut
faire des deux et cavaliers aux quatre
évidemment
tes deux va être joué quasi certainement
cavalier 4 prochain coup et à cette très
compliqué
et moi j'ai deux là c'est peut-être le
moment où elle joue elle joue le mieux
finalement
on a bien la suppression du temps il
faut reconnaître qu'elle a bien joué
5 à 3 elle sait pas trop quoi faire
et 12 secondes ça peut être très très
chaud
et il y a un et demi sur les autres
échiquier Laura unique a craqué et Salem
a gagné comme on l'avait prévu
donc cette partie est très très
importante très serré
ça me deux et maintenant on fait comment
Dame des cinq
là maintenant cavalier
et là maintenant F5 gentiment
après ça ou des perpettes mais quand
même c'est pas mal d'avoir ce cavalier
protégé en E4
pour garder un petit oeil sur le pion g
c'est bien joué tout ça
attention au temps
et il a attrapé il a rattrapé tout
simplement
après certainement allez vite
à la fin ah oui non ça ça marche pas
au minimum ok
j'arrive Damon
tout simplement
voilà c'est fini on va on va commencer à
parler les échecs avec la dame
en plus
abandon ah c'est moche quand ça se
termine comme ça elle a raté apparemment
une nulle donc ça devait être à mon avis
c'est ça
mes deux parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on se prend de la maison
c'est ça
n'a pas l'air d'être nul du tout mais il
y a damasute le mat un peu incroyable
donc du coup
et ensuite c'est quoi la ligne d'un meuf
de roi H3 ici d'un F3 seul coup pour pas
perdre attention
terminé donc il faut jouer tout
reprendre les deux
et là le seul coup pour faire nul dans
ma chambre ah non non ça fait pas nul
c'est F4 ici
pour pas perdre
H2 puis on prend G3 vous avez bien
compris
4 et ça va faire un perpétuel dis non
c'était quand même c'était quelque chose
cette partie
elle était
sympa
tes favoris qui prennent l'avantage au
final dans ce match preneur il a joué de
manière moche et en bas sous Mova elle
était assez convaincante dans son jeu
messagerie du temps à jouer contre elle
dommage
essayez de bien jouer aux échecs mais à
cette cadence 10 + 2 il faut avoir un
peu plus de constance au temps et là
c'est elle est un peu exagérée quand
même un peu exagéré tout à fait bon
après une fois qu'elle a été en crise de
temps elle a réussi pendant longtemps à
tenir mais c'est un peu jouer à la
roulette et où dommage on avait vu sa
position avec le bon pion de plus et n'a
pas réussi à
convertir et même pire encore à la
perdure
donc
on voit elle faisait une bonne partie
jusque là magnifique pion de plus net
mais on l'a tu l'avais dit c'est pas
terminé il y a de l'arnaque normalement
il a envoyé son pion h avec les fous de
couleur oppose et jouer le petit haschi
c'est vrai bah il a fait les petits
trucs quoi
ça va toujours
mais voilà il a eu chaud ouais mais il a
laissé cavalier F4 et les Cai aussi
maintenant donc c'est moins clair
c'est le bordel
la bonne nouvelle pour Karina et Laura
c'est qu'elle joue ensemble à la
dernière partie et donc
elles peuvent se refaire elles peuvent
se refaire et donner même la victoire à
leur équipe
c'est une partie très très importante on
rend des parties très serrées là donc
c'est les échiquier similaires qui
jouent ensemble
donc clairement c'est des parties a
priori sur le papier très très équilibré
un petit rappel pour pour
de pour ah non pas ça ah si oui en fait
donc
édouards
il manque la moitié du truc
tandis que en face qui a deux ennemis ça
doit être Salem qui a deux ennemis
c'est un quiz en fait de le rendre tu
nous fais non
super sympa
alors qui sont les gens des dents mais
non mais il m'a envoyé c'est pas gentil
donc José carrossibara ça c'est vraiment
facile alors
il va jouer c'est ce qu'on a dit contre
il jouait Jones là il va jouer
on va jouer il va jouer Salem exactement
elle va jouer contre
elle va jouer l'autre jeune femme c'est
à dire Laura mais en fait tu l'as tu
m'as montré la pareillement
non précédente
j'ai croqué du coup j'étais gêné là
demain grand grand choc avec cette
équipe indienne MGD 1 notamment emmené
par air gazy face à l'équipe de Blitz
stream donc avec
Alexander chocolat Maxime machine à
gravo 2 au 3 le jeûne mais tellement
dangereux mais le Boyer et au 4
démantèle dolite
nouvellement française d'ailleurs si je
me trompe pas et voilà qui sera très
certainement une des représentantes de
l'équipe de France lors des prochaines
séances internationales donc une
émergeur Française pour sûr et super
voilà et le deuxième deuxième match bien
des ours contre
on n'a pas les rêves au niveau des
équipes on est prêt désolé
c'est Gotham Knights avec Nakamura ouais
l'équipe de
qui a pour capitaine les virement le
streamer qui du coup se ramené par NACA
mais il y aura le coang il y aura fait
d'ocif bortnik donc ils ont une sacrée
sacré équipe
un mètre ou de Word que je connais peu
et Natalia bouskia et salimova comme
comme représentante
dans l'équipe et du coup les
oursons alors les oursons je les cherche
en même temps
ils sont là et pour pendant que tu
cherches
la réponse la réponse attends je donne
la réponse à la question à quelle heure
demain c'est à 16h30 deuxième match à
19h c'est marqué en bas c'est à dire
centrale centrale
européen time donc le
leur centrale valeurs de d'Europe
centrale
alors où on est même Bretagne c'est ça
donc du coup
de deux heures de décalage horaire c'est
parce qu'il fait il fait il fait nuit
avant
et
Pierce berline Beers les
teddyber là du coup
les Allemands avec Antoine corroboff bon
il est pas très allemand corrobof il est
ukrainien
Dimitri Collard
ni classe ou jeune baisse Harry Brown
Frédéric fine et les jeunes femmes
Joséphine annemann et Sarah pape
d'accord mais très belle équipe aussi on
rappelle un petit un petit rappel du
format on voit des tailles breaks qui
peuvent arriver donc là c'est cadence 10
+ 2 une année Léo de 2500 non c'est pas
le bon pardon c'est pas le bon du tout
de 2550 donne-moi une femme genre plus
de 2007 compte comme de 2007 les
joueuseraient 2350 comme des 2300 compte
comme des 2350 et en cas d'égalité ce
qu'on pourrait très bien avoir
aujourd'hui il y a les quatrième
échiquier donc avant de savoir et il
aura unique dans le cas
échéant aujourd'hui qui se rencontrerait
ça peut arriver
c'est qui les Bulldogs et ben les boules
dogs c'est les croashias bouledogs donc
les Croates bon Croates et sympathisants
c'est vrai qu'il y a hanté ça arrive ça
ça Martineau vite mais il y a aussi
[Musique]
bogdaniak il doit être romain je pense
Léon livage que je connais pas
lova et une Roberts donc qui est
hollandaise et il y a aussi Bardia
danachevard qui complète en tant que
maître international l'équipe et ça va
bientôt repartir on a toujours
pranave à l'écran et
aussi
la la joueuse
la joueuse
peut-être qu'on va mettre moi je sens
que ça va se jouer on va changer un
petit peu alors à quoi alors elle est
noire alors je vais essayer d'aller
capturer
Laura et une folie pour Laurent
fin de Sim parce que c'était la dernière
partie du match donc là je suis au bout
du rouleau et puis attention il a prépa
avant la prépa n'a pas duré 10 secondes
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire et oui
grosse prépa pour Laurent
ouais ouais je me plains je me plains tu
te moques de moi
[Musique]
c'est ça ça va être beau
gagne on peut dire qu'ils ont de très
très fortes chances de ouais de
l'emporter voir des départages mais
vraiment après ils auraient plus grand
chose à faire les les gars donc ça il y
a quand même beaucoup de choses qui se
jouent sur cette échiquier féminin du
coup
il faut
il faut absolument se battre et je me
dis en barre sous mon vin elle a
tellement bien joué la partie précédente
remarque aura une nuque était aussi en
position très favorable et AGA fait
mais ça c'est à cause de la gestion du
temps je le rappelle c'est basique mais
en même temps tellement vrai on a on a
donc un appareillement entre deux
joueurs très solides tous les agréable
les blancs bon contre Salem qui peut
être très agressif mais on va voir on va
voir ce qui va se passer en tout cas on
a aussi gavageons avec les Noirs face à
Miguel Santos Ruiz on va voir s'il va
être aussi solide qu'à la première
peut-être il avait été
extrêmement solide Gawen et pris au cœur
risque accepté une nul écoute ma foi
comment je trouvais malhonnête
proposition de malhonnête mais quand
elle acceptée en même temps elle est pas
si mallette que ça finalement quoi que
bon on a le droit
alors là on est tu le confirmes sur
Santos Luis contre Gawen Jones je le
confirme je le confirme on voit les
petits noms on voit pas les visages je
suis pas les je suis pas allé prendre
des visages mais voilà
je le confirme tout à fait standard ok
on peut pas faire plus standard que ça
exactement
avec un 5 maintenant laisse plus les
blancs prendre l'espace allez la dame
et du coup on ferait un petit tour des
ouvertures là and standard pour pour
cette partie est-ce que
on
je suis désolé j'ai un problème de
non c'est moi c'est moi c'est moi parce
qu'en fait j'ai un problème de j'ai un
problème d'oreillette de batterie
je suis encore là au niveau du son et
maintenant vous m'avez en
filigrane c'est je suis ça marche ou pas
c'était magnifique est-ce que ça marche
moi ce que vous entend ouais est-ce que
vous entendez Kevin ouais mais c'est
Kévin le gros souci
ah qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de beau
on adore on adore parce que là j'ai
tellement réveillé tellement de colle
aujourd'hui que voilà
ça se ça s'est déchargé j'ai oublié de
le charger
bon on a est-ce que tu as pas réduit la
fenêtre discord par hasard Laurent si si
évidemment si c'est pas drôle ça je ne
savais pas que ça existait au début et
du coup je me suis fait avoir une fois
tu vois je me dis oh c'est bizarre ça
fige c'est pas bien le truc en fait
vous voyez en technique il y a des
petits trucs à savoir et
ça peut arriver très très vite de faire
la petite boulette
et des 4 a été joué dans
sur les chéquier
féminin
et on a aussi cette dernière partie
aussi entre pranave qui est très
entreprenante depuis le début qui prend
des risques un peu fou
qui est pas très intéressé qui je suis
contente de jouer vite et voilà de poser
problème pratique pas très par la vérité
une Française voilà avec food étroit ok
ouais fous des trois ça lui ressemble
peut-être des éventuels
ça lance peut-être une attaque ou deux
trois c'est lui ça
et oui
les blancs en fait de prendre l'espace à
l'aile dame c'était thématique en fait
si tu veux toi tu voulais faire fouger 4
et en fait même si c'est un joli clouage
sur le papier dans l'italière n tu te
fais chasser ton fou si tu fais des
fougères clouage donc c'était juste
avant voilà il y aura
des H3 et un jour tu auras tout re un
cavalier F1 que j'ai trois comme le
monde Laurent même des fois des G4
peuvent exister donc on ne fait pas
vraiment
ce clouage là en fait on le fait au
départ quand quand j'étais tout jeune
j'ai bien faire ce clouage là et ça
marchait mais c'est vrai que à niveau
amateur plus on ne fait plus le âge là
parce qu'on sait que ça se passe pas si
bien
et pour c'est un coup de thématique qui
peut pas être étrange mais voilà on
menace de d'ouvrir en fait on veut c'est
un coup de prévention pour jouer des 4
du edcd cavalier D
mais malheureusement ça va pas suffire
c'est juste rien on protège tout d'un
coup
parfaite harmonie pour les blancs
intéressant
intéressants ça joue partout et ça joue
ouais ça joue normal tout simplement on
va voir qu'est-ce qui se passe entre
Laura eunuque avant on a une est
indienne très tranquille puis on prend
le 5
des lignes si les Noirs savent comment
égaliser ça va mais c'est toujours un
petit plus pour les blancs cahier des
cinq voilà travaille bien si on prend le
cavalier on aura un pion c'est qui va se
faire matraquer ouais c'est ça
et du coup ce sera pas évident pour
assez un viendra
pour Fd1 voir les tours doublés sur la
colonne C donc ça serait vraiment pas
agréable ouais c'est ça exactement
on va faire des choses comme ça et ça va
pas aller du tout
donc avantage le rendu que je dirais là
dans cette position qui est plus vite le
coup parce que fougères tu peux je suis
pas sûr tu puisses te permettre c'est
toujours des idées comme ça
la structure qui est quand même pour la
structure voilà maintenant
on peut vraiment donc les dessins que je
crois que c'est fou D8 le coup j'ai
regardé ça
il y a longtemps
mais bon on verra
on verra ce qui se passe et ouais il
faut qu'elle surveille le temps ça c'est
sûr et en barre tout mais on va foudre
ça donne pas envie si tu connais pas
mais c'était Mathilde dans cette ligne
donc si tu as travaillé un petit peu bon
tu peux trouver
elle va prendre prendre du temps parce
que si elle est pas sûre
même fouder lui ben c'est un peu plus
dur à jouer si tu connais pas
franchement
tout à fait position n'est pas si
ouverte que ça elle est plutôt ouverte
sur casse blanche à profite plutôt blanc
qui ont trois pièces mineures qui
peuvent naviguer sur les cases blanches
les noirs
pour mettre la pression au temps pour
pour dire à l'adversaire ouais je
connais tout là normalement
ça se passe aux objets je crois que
c'est très chaud chez Ito isaga tu vois
il me fait mentir il tourise AGA il a
joué quelque chose avec H4 très vite
pour faire qui G5 ça fait un peu penser
à la partie népomashi Bacro c'est très
très similaire
et j'ai trois des Olympiades il y a
quelques années de 2018
c'est très dangereux mais petit rock pas
du tout dans l'esprit de H4
avec l'espace pour pour les noirs et dès
qu'on fait fouger 2 il faut vérifier des
trois
du coup c'est une galère ça te pose il y
a les cavaliers B4 aussi suite des trois
qui peuvent arriver enfin bref ça fait
pas mal de d'éléments qui sent bon pour
les gnomes non
tu dis pardon Laurence
déjà mais là avantage gnome sur celle-là
je suis d'accord ensuite on a on a Jones
John se voit pas en train de perdre
comme Santos pour être honnête dans une
italienne comme ça pépère
dans certains cas
et peut-être comme tu l'as dit hein
cette partie qui pourrait se montrer
pour FDA s'il aura une gagne c'est plié
si en bas sous mon vagin ça lance tout
c'est ça
et surtout Fd1 tu vois la joue un peu
moins vite ah si à jouer vite la 9
minutes contre 6 pour avoir ce moment
le coup combien de temps elle a joué
mais non je veux pas j'aurais voulu
qu'elle en fasse plus encore
en jouant extrêmement vite
il y a pas de souci pour pour le niveau
on est là pour tous les niveaux
évidemment
on essaie d'expliquer
l'histoire de Fougères en vrai c'était
plutôt amateur 5 ça peut ça peut être
une bonne idée quand même mais en fait
tous les clouages ne sont pas
bons à faire un peu comme la logique de
l'échec en début quand on est joueur
débutant on adore faire échec en fait on
s'aperçoit que des fois on cache le roi
elle repère
et nous demande on sait juste que le
capitaine norvégien
et je peux presque répondre à ta
question ce que tu voudrais une réponse
et ben je crois qu'il n'y a
pas il y a quand même un norvégien je
pense peut-être tu vas me dire ça
que tu ailles pose la question piège
combien y a-t-il
dans la compétition d'équipe aujourd'hui
c'est ça
non en règle générale dans ouais en
règle générale dans l'équipe et il y a
peut-être Elam abdos j'ai bien prononcé
je pense tu le connais ouh là non pas du
tout je vais voir
je vais voir il est peut-être norvégien
ce joueur c'est possible très très bonne
question il nous régalent avec ces
questions une il nous fait il nous fait
vibrer et oui et l'âme il est
c'est un jeune norvégien un jeune maître
quelque chose effectivement à 18 ans et
il est déjà 2527 autant dire qu'il va
être grand maître très prochainement
d'accord intéressant bon on va revenir
peut-être
sur le direct sur le direct et quelle
partie donc là elle a joué F5 elle a
pris un peu de temps mais
je suis en galère avec mes écouteurs je
suis vraiment désolé donc du coup en
fait quand je suis un gars avec mes
écouteurs on perd Kevin
d'accord est-ce que tu passes par mes
écouteurs mais là c'est bon
la technologie c'est incroyable ouais
t'as vu
et regarde ce qu'il est en train de nous
faire Salem il est en train de
l'agresser complètement là
merci kalflow donc je pense que j'ai
déjà joué contre ce joueur c'est un
jeune joueur qui est très très fort en
Bliss mais il est très très fort en lent
maintenant aussi visiblement
qu'à 18 ans 25 27 c'est pas mal du tout
te dire ça donc un des gros espoirs
norvégiens
tout à fait on fait quoi là avec les
Blancs là on pleure on attend un peu
je sais pas ça fait peur
il est en train de faire du mal
à être saga il est plus fort de toute
façon ça l'aime il a vraiment l'habitude
des grosses grosses compet
très dangereux
il y a que 40 points et l'eau c'est
quand même pas les mêmes joueurs même si
ils trouvent Zaga c'est un champion il y
a pas de souci là-dessus mais salam il
fait des plus gros tournois donc
il a montré pour l'instant il a il est
propre dans ce qu'il propose
donc ben ouais ça va jouer sur les
féminin c'est quasiment sûr
une position
ouais ça tourne au vinaigre pour nos
amis espagnols là ils sont
plus qu'en difficulté là
comme on dit
mais bon ça peut
les Noirs où on voit ce cavalier on sait
pas où il va aller celui-là non plus et
regardez hop j'ai toutes les cases je
peux aussi éventuellement passer par là
ouvrir quand je veux
ça va être
ouais ça va être rigolo c'est ça
exactement ça va être très très
compliqué
et plus ouais
je retournerais bien voir le le duel de
nos jeunes femmes là qui sont à l'écran
pour voir si
il aura ou nuque va réussir à faire mal
à en barre de ce que tu peux nous mettre
ça Laurent bien sûr
[Musique]
c'est pas mal ce qu'elle a réussi à
faire avec
ouais c'est très bien c'est très bien
pour les Noirs là ça est-ce qu'elle
contrôle le temps elle a toujours 3
minutes de moins mais ça c'est son péché
mignon
et il y a rien à faire
mais la réussite à se libérer les Blancs
n'ont pas contrôlé la poussée E4 le fuj2
est coincé ça valorise le Five si tout à
l'heure en jouet sur les cases blanches
là maintenant c'est les cases noires qui
font mal sur l'échiquier et du coup le
fou F6 fait mal à toute la position
blanche il rayonne il faut savoir jouer
comme pranave là on joue vite et on
tient à peu près la position et on
espère des jours meilleurs voilà et puis
quand l'adversaire aura dépensé tout son
temps pour pour nous battre dans les
fromage dans le zaynote voilà comment il
faut jouer
si ça exactement
et puis là elle réfléchit peut-être
beaucoup
elle a rendu
alors est-ce qu'il faut faire E3 ou non
avec les Noirs dans ce type de position
je pense que pour plutôt oui
pour essayer d'affaiblir
3 est-ce qu'on jouerait F4 avec les
Blancs
certainement on va pas prendre parce
qu'après ça ça fait bili roi pour
toujours donc 3 F4
et on essaie de s'en sortir comme ça
mais bon c'est pas c'est pas grandiose
bon ça reste quand même assez solide on
joue autour des 8 ou à 5 à 4 aussi il y
a des plans comme ça
intéressant
je sais pas le résultat des 6
et vraiment
alors là on vous rappelle un concave 8 8
il y a match de partage
tout à fait mais c'est assez improbable
surtout à cause de cette partie moi
c'est ça qui me fait peur c'est que
Salem a une initiative comme ça il a une
position incroyable et trois minutes
contre
diagonale il suffit de dévier cette tour
ça peut être tout de suite fini
là c'est grande difficulté
croquer H4 on peut faire beaucoup de
choses
peut-être un tour assez vite ce qu'on
pourrait jouer tour à C8 tout simplement
pourquoi pas
non j'ai 5 c'est pas pour le joueur
tout simplement
et du coup tout race et 8 avec l'idée de
prendre et peut-être de jouer tour C8
tout simplement voilà donc toi c'est
vite très pénible
et c'est jouer
c'est jouer par Salem qui se fait pas
qui se fait pas prier là
c'est pas encore fait au niveau de la
jauge mais on n'aime pas la position
blanche elle est dur à tenir
très très bien
bon et là est-ce qu'on peut juste jouer
tout reprend C5 et tour C8 Laurent c'est
une proposition
pour
[Musique]
pour faire mal
bon c'est jouable mais la jauge elle
indiqué qu'on était presque gagnant donc
on doit avoir
ton C8 c'est la partie c'était le truc
le plus
[Musique]
menace tours c'est un Dame des 5 c'est
l'idée
on a le roi il va mal vivre
par contre un revenu il y a eu des
petits soucis de son apparemment
j'ai plus j'ai plus de batterie sur ma
montre
pour
pour garder le chat aussi donc faut que
tu me détends streaming difficile
Laurent au bout de toutes les batteries
que je recharge en direct
maintenant sur Tours c'est un fousser un
Dame des cinq Adam B8
et là je pars peut-être Laurent
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas prendre parce
que c'est Matt
son choix de dames avec ce petit
c'est jouer et j'ai pas d'AMS ici
truc comme ça
ou même est-ce que je pourrais faire H5
parce que j'avais le droit de faire H5
carrément
tous les droits
donc rachis c'est le bon coup pour être
raisonnable pas se plonger 5 en ce qui
va faire 35 secondes contre une minute
c'est chaud
c'est très très chaud et réfléchis après
fou français-1 il y a les quatre parties
en cours c'est bouillante ici mais cette
fin de cette fin de match qu'est-ce qui
se passe ici
et bien finalement ça va très
probablement faire nul
donc ce sera pas du tout décisif cette
partie que en poser pranave
au prana il est en train de gagner il
est en train de finir le job pradable et
non ce qui sont en train de gagner ce
match
et ça commence à s'éclaircir moins
un peu en difficulté
qui va perdre ça pourrait relancer un
petit peu
ça dépend de Salem j'ai l'impression que
ça l'aime si il termine le boulot
qui s'est passé
c'était peut-être pas la bonne solution
de cette opportunités attention tous les
deux donc ça peut vriller Laurent on
peut encore avoir des résultats décident
de partout
alors
jouer
et 7 logique
et le pur F4 qui qui en l'air
on a des trois jouets à un moment ça me
prend F4 jouer
alors Détroit il y aurait fougé 5 là
attention
mais ce fou est pas terrible et c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est dur je vais 12
secondes contre 5 voilà mais ça c'est
facile à jouer pour les Noirs donc ça
allait me perdra pas mais il y a des
chances qu'il ne gagne pas non plus et
il se passe quoi sur quatre parties en
cours tu te rends compte ce qui nous
font là on sait plus quoi suivre on a
cette finale de Tour ou les blancs vont
peut-être gagner ça ferait une
égalisation pranave qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce que ça donne chez pranave il
est dans la NASA
c'est quasiment fini chez pranave et là
sans doute nul mais il faut voir
qu'est-ce qu'elles vont jouer
à l'instant
une vingt contre une vingt bon ça reste
ça reste nul très probable mais c'est
pas neuf probablement qui est en train
de gagner la partie décisive là il y a
pas trop de solution
on va voir ce qui se passe mais il y a
eu un bug un match oh là là il pouvait
plus perdre sauf gaffe
incroyable
énorme gave de salé qui relance tout le
match et c'est égalité maintenant si
c'est demi partout alors peut-être
incroyable
pas sûr le métier alors nul signé entre
en bas de sous Mova et ou nuque nul
signé donc ça nous rapproche du
afghan et que Gawen perd
ce qui est pas improbable Laurent un
petit départage ou tout nous mettrait
les cames de manière assez incroyable je
pense je les laisserais comme ça en fait
une seule partie
des jeunes femmes
on se dirige on regarde cette partie
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
salut François
je n'ai plus du tout le chat mon cher
mon cher Kevin donc il faut que tu me
dates des questions bon on peut pas dire
que le chat soit spécialement
actif réveillez-vous
alors il va mater la prendre avant on
est d'accord
j'ai un dame G2 ça fait match à chaque
fois ça fait mal
va ça joue sur ça ça joue sur ça on va
mettre en mettre je vais tenter Express
ça a tout changé
facile et un peu peut-être un peu de
boulot je vais mettre la tour en un fond
de la caisse
ok de grosses de nul
on le voit
oui ça devrait
ça devrait faire nul attends on va voir
parce que les deux jeunes femmes ont à
l'écran donc prena va gagner oh là ça
serait énorme
ou pas encore
et c'est probable arrive à faire nul la
taille il peut la gagner maintenant
c'est noir qui joue pour quelque chose
je trouve c'est noir qui joue et oui moi
je pense ça va faire nul assez
non je me suis enflammé là pour ces
trois tours
petit coup
c'est chaud que c'est chaud je ne sais
plus prendre à gagner il a maté son
adversaire ok ça a gagné cette position
qui était nul huit partout non au match
de partage
il s'est trompé dans cette position il
n'a pas su
on va voir comment c'est terminé
ils sont protégés maintenant c'est
terminé ado
est complètement tilté
et oui
le match pour un homme mais maintenant
on a des partages donc si on a bien
compris Kevin tu reprends
les jeunes femmes on voit
je pense qu'elles sont un peu vertes
particulièrement
je vois la tête de Laura onuque et
c'est pas la sérénité même elle vient de
abandon il fait hyper hyper
elle est complètement dégoûtée elle se
dit je vais devoir jouer le match de
départage
alors attends est-ce qu'on a bien
compris le dommage je les partages on
est d'accord ou pas
on y va directement tu vas nous mettre
le petit voilà le petit screen qui va
bien c'est elle qui joue
moi c'est comme ça que je le comprends
voilà donc Laura ONU qu'on aura donc les
noirs
voilà
ce qu'on sait
OK
bon
écoute
est-ce que
on était chacun pour notre équipe
et oui et maintenant on aura moins
franchement
alors c'est de la faute à personne mais
les norwegnoms viennent de se faire
complètement retourné à la faveur de
Gabin Jones qui avait une finale
difficile qui l'a sauvé puis qu'il a
reperdu et surtout la grosse gaffe de
Salem Saleh qui a été complètement
dominant toute la partie Laurent et en
fait il a boule l'été sa finale après
avoir raté l'avantage
du coup c'est horrible pour lui ça va
jouer très simplement match de 3 + 2
pour les moins bons les moins bons élo
de la team donc c'est les deux jeunes
femmes qui ont
2300 et 2400 qui vont se raconter dans
un match avec les couleurs inversées
tout à fait
mais à moi est-ce que c'est les quatre
échiquiers ou simplement le dernier
c'est ça que j'ai un super classe
honnêtement je suis pas sûr de ce
règlement
faut être vu en anglais en fait en vrai
tu vois ce que je veux dire
parce que si je le traduis il sera pas
la même manche toi ça sera ça sera
tous les deux quoi on fera un match et
puis voilà
donc ça je suis pas sûr mais bon il
avait l'air
il avait l'air complètement sur Nathan
hier moi j'étais pas mais bon
je me méfie je me méfie mais bon
peut-être que j'ai tort
je pense qu'elle avait vraiment la tête
de quelqu'un qui va jouer tout seul pour
toute seule pour son équipe
et pourquoi il reste dans le col alors
ah je sais pas je sais pas je sais pas
on va on va avoir tous les réponses
c'est une bonne nouvelle quand même
est-ce que je peux demander
[Musique]
je pourrais demander
on va voir
parce que quelqu'un sait bon on va on va
trouver
quand vous voyez il y a il y a encore un
plus de suspense d'ailleurs avec cette
fin en trois plus deux quoi qu'il arrive
et c'est mort subite maintenant
c'est à dire que quoi que ce soit
tu vois
c'était ces quatre échiquier mon cher
mon cher à Kévin heureusement que tu es
là je méfier moi la trade la trade la
trade et il change de
échange de couleur tout le monde change
de couleur ok bon celui qui alors
japonais la variante on me l'a fait pas
soit alors il y a deux écoles soit le
match des deux jeunes femmes soit le
match entre Salem Saleh qui doit se
refaire après la bourde astronomique et
on fait ça
un petit sondage on va on va regarder
enfin vas-y on fait voter les gens et
après on décide
alors son match je peux pas faire donc
dites-nous quel est le grand format on
pourra aller voir tous les deux
isaga c'est ça voilà
donc quasiment 2700 contre hit witzaga
26-30 ou alors le match est deux jeunes
femmes 2300 contre 2400 qui pourraient
être aussi décisif
dépêchez-vous
vous nous dites ce qui vous plaît le
plus sinon choisi
oui il vient d'avoir les blancs
les deux jeunes femmes un peu
d'exposition médiatique pour elle la
réponse D
non vraiment j'ai tout changé
qu'on a dit ça ça lève non mais je vais
je mets quoi moi bon je mets elle a quoi
du coup Laura elle est noire ou les
blancs honnêtement
c'est
allez j'arrête le vote
tout de suite et c'est les jeunes femmes
qui l'ont emporté d'accord et elle a les
blancs ou les Noirs
largement il y a même pas
ouais il y a eu quelques votes pour
Salem mais je suis non non je t'ai vu
voter deux fois tu vas pas me la faire
il arbitre
ça m'étonne pas
on sait en faire et Jérôme on n'est pas
sur notre chaîne et
et du coup j'ai pas le tableau de bord
des créateurs à disposition
voilà
voilà tu sais tout allez on a les deux
jeunes femmes avec des couleurs
inversées et je me suis dit si je
demande à Laurent de nous faire un
sondage
c'est l'incident diplomatique il a déjà
un vrai techniquement il va vous offrir
un grand vraiment moi je fais jamais
enfin en tout cas je fais je faisais des
sondages sur chaise 24 je ne suis jamais
enfin je voulais
je sais ce que j'avais envie de faire à
la fin normal
et du coup tu nous as pas changé de
scène je pense j'imaginais un changement
de scène pour le dernier match Laurent
je crois que je vais partir en milieu du
stream tu auras l'air malin tiens je
vais partir au milieu du Blitz non
pas le début
ça serait moche mais là elles sont pas
encore on voit que embarque sous Mova
elle est elle est tranquille bon en tout
cas
beau match ça sent la fin et vous savez
l'histoire c'est que qui refont match
nul un deux
et là à chaque fois à chaque fois on y
va parce que la règle j'ai bien vu après
on est en Manche enfin les règles
étaient pas très bien traduites si tu
vois ce que je veux dire ça va être le
même truc une minute plus deux secondes
ils ont pas indiqué
ils ont pas indiqué de fin normalement
il y a une fois en Armageddon souvent
j'ai jamais vu un truc qui peut
continuer à éternam bon c'est vrai qu'on
a plus deux tu es peu probable qui est
des matchs nuls
de 2 à chaque fois mais quand même
mal traduit ça il faudra faire une
petite note hier on avait dit Laurent
que le 8 8 était quand même un cas un
cas hyper rare ouais mais ça va être de
plus en plus on y est ouais mais ça va
arriver de temps en temps et de plus en
plus au fur et à mesure que la
compétition avance parce que les matchs
seront de plus en plus serrés donc c'est
pas c'est pas une logique non plus
bon après c'est John ça moi j'avais
annoncé John je sortais fébrile tu vois
il a pas eu cette fille de tour il a pas
été très bon sur le coup
avait fait un très beau
Maurane ce soir qui a déçu
d'être là encore
est-ce que tu peux nous montrer un
instant les scores indivent Laurent tu
me chambre pas
trois et demi
qui était très très bien très solide et
prana a fait le job et trois mais top
scorer tandis que
Salem c'est un peu battu tout seul
la seule bourde j'avais dit il peut pas
perdre je l'ai bien passé
il a pris le seul piège de la position
finale incroyable il a pas fait les
vérifications comme je dis des fois au
joueur amateur et les vérifications quoi
c'est important alors le suspense est à
son comble
dans ce match
on va voir ce que ça a donné entre
abarths
nous qui allait souriante mais c'est un
sourire un peu stressé
et ouais parce qu'elle a il faut avouer
quand même mauvaise donc voilà ça ça
fait mal de faire perdre son équipe
jamais très agréable
la grosse presse
a toujours faire des vifs
par contre je vois pas les parties tu me
dis si tu vois que ça démarre parce que
là j'en ai j'en ai 200000 des parties
je pense pas
que ça démarre mais j'ai pas
l'impression vu
l'état de détente des choses non
les parties
mais bon on peut pas faire grand-chose
encore une fois
Vincent je n'ai rien mais des fois ça ça
surprend
on attend avec impatience
le dénouement finalement de de ce joli
stream Laurent ah bah oui on est on est
content d'être ensemble mais là on
serait ouais on est content d'être tous
les deux mais là je crois que c'est un
moment où on commence à on serait pas
mécontent se quitter non plus
en fait c'est juste dommage il y a un
truc
c'est il faudrait que les pauses soient
moins longues hein Laurent là il y a des
pauses qui sont par rapport
vraiment morts c'est à reprendre
j'aimerais bien un petit chrono et hop
ça reprend quoi les postes sont trop
longues et goudinats pas très bien joué
aujourd'hui je sais pas ce que tu en
penses Kevin
moi j'ai pas dit ça
elle aurait pu faire mieux non mais
c'était pas une une bonne journée pour
pour nos féminines là qui sont des
joueuses extrêmement fortes après elles
font face aux meilleurs joueurs du monde
aussi il faut bien comprendre et du coup
c'est c'est pas évident il y a cette
pression aussi tout le monde veut faire
le point et et voilà donc tout le monde
met la pression et prend des risques
plus qu'à l'habitude quoi tu vois des
risques un petit peu alors parfois c'est
un peu trop ma médias
mais bon ça a marché hein voilà on a
failli avoir dès la première ronde
quelque chose de
d'asser surprenant
exact alors on en est où ce qui se met
en place nos amis
on ne sait pas
on ne sait pas est-ce que ils sont prêts
ou pas
est-ce que ça commence à jouer ou pas on
va voir tout ça
on nous demande un petit conseil
pour
générer François qui suit beaucoup et il
me dit
je voudrais un conseil de profs j'ai
vraiment 70% de mes parties rapidement
que je perds en étant gagnant j'ai
l'impression de perdre le fil ou de te
repousser sachant que je suis mieux un
conseil pour gérer oui alors il y a il y
a une pression à Laurent qui se met un
petit peu sur le joueur d'échec
bon surtout si on est peu expérimenté
quand on est gagnant quand on voit la
victoire pointée le bout de son nez donc
ça peut expliquer donc c'est un travail
sur soi
il faut que la tête suive et après
normalement ce qu'on dit avec l'avantage
c'est qu'il faut contrôler la position
et ça c'est pas si évident encore contre
les mais sur la plateforme je mettrai un
petit pack vidéo sur jouer les positions
gagnantes Laurent comme ça je l'ai
expliqué comment on doit contrôler c'est
plus dur c'est le plus pour moi c'est
toujours été c'est le plus dur aux
échecs de gagner partie gagnante ça
c'est vraiment c'est le problème du
joueur d'échec c'est-à-dire que on a
souvent des bonnes positions et
après il fallait gagner c'est très dur
de de le coup le coup fatal apporter
c'est très dur tenir les positions
difficiles ou compliquer les positions
difficiles on n'a pas le choix c'est on
a plus la pression alors que gagner les
positions gagnantes il y a la fois le
côté technique et le côté psychologique
donc François c'était plutôt une bonne
une bonne question à une excellente
question on n'a pas on n'a pas une de
vraies réponses comme tu le vois mais il
faudrait voir des situations de jeu il y
a quand même des choses à faire déjà
normalement c'est pas touchant boulet
normalement tu dois contrôler
l'adversaire stopper le contre jeu et si
l'adversaire s'ennuie en règle générale
ça défense va lâcher
un coup de souris
mais bon ça joue ça joue ça reste un
bide c'est du 3 + 2 là c'est le début
grévitch ce genre d'histoire
donc tu appelles ça le début gorge
pourquoi pas c'est la première fois que
j'entends
à l'époque
ouais
du coup c'était intéressant j'ai joué
une partie qu'on JB sur ce sujet là dans
un brise Masters
je rappelle que j'avais fait une partie
sacrément et j'avais fait une
vieille nulle il était pas content à
l'époque JB j'ai un petit peu j'avais
fait une partie dégueu mais bon
c'est toujours comme ça alors des quatre
par contre elle a pas l'air habitué au
bide sumova regarde de 16
entre deux 45 chez unique alors ça c'est
une grosse faute quand même on peut pas
dépenser quasiment une minute sur les
sur les 10 premiers coups en jouant au
B3 fou B2
à une cause du carter je suis d'accord
regaya tout à fait d'accord mais en
moins bien en moins bien que le fouet en
E2 déjà et le cavalier en C3 bah il est
pas si excellent que cela la formation
noire d'ailleurs ressemble plus à une
cause du carton avec le cavalier en 17
c'est très confortable pour les noirs et
une minute d'avant je crois que unique
en fait elle va tout simplement
et bien essayer de prendre plus que la
nuit parce que là c'est objectivement
équilibré mais déjà on sent que avec
cette minute de plus ça peut être très
vite plus agréable à jouer pour les
Noirs il peut se passer quelque chose
vers sur très réussi pour pour Laura et
les autres je sais qui on va pas on va
pas regarder ce qui se passe franchement
parce que là évidemment on n'a pas le
temps attention vous avez voté pour voir
donc quoi la démocratie
un joue très vite normalement voilà de
jouer
attention ça peut être ça peut être un
petit peu gênant faut trouver un truc à
faire avec cette dame la dame en A8 elle
serait tellement bien c'est là où j'ai
envie de la mettre vous voyez sur la
grande diago mais pas si évident est-ce
que j'ai le droit de faire
d'âme C7 d'un B8 Damas 8 et mettre ma
tour F en D8 tu as tous les droits
voilà je ferais bien quelque chose comme
ça en tout cas la rattrape autant
attention
attention la pendule des deux côtés a
bien contrôler tout ça
elle nous entend
elle va jouer
ça me pose des questions il faut éviter
la jauge aime pas du tout la chose
j'aime pas du tout ça doit laisser un
truc
il faut regarder B4
avec ce vis-à-vis qui est toujours très
dangereux alors je sais pas
huit dame B7
j'aurais vraiment fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour mettre en place une
disposition de pièces très moyenne bon
F3 jouet F3 logique le poids à 8 c'est
très bizarre je préfère les blancs
maintenant
j'aime bien aussi les blancs maintenant
je suis d'accord mais une douce contre
une 30 ça va pas jouer sur ça clairement
ça joue autant Laura décisions et puis
elle se fait rejoindre au niveau du
temps
il y avait du cavalier prend aussi si le
bio
attention à 5 ok ça se stabilise le KFC
c'est bien joué comme ça on a plus ce
vis-à-vis là qui donnait des tactiques à
la prise directe d'ailleurs mais bon on
peut pas tout avoir dans la vie aux
échecs
[Musique]
et maintenant on va faire son mieux ça
ça souffre aucune discussion possible
mais alors
regardez-moi ce fou ça va pas du tout
elle a passé la
en barre tout Mova moi je suis pas assez
de victoire du nuque
ok parce que avant tout mauvais
j'attends beaucoup plus fébrile dans les
dans les États mais bon on va voir moi
je suis allé
regarde ça
oh là là
je sois pratique écoute mais bon
pratique quand même
je dois avouer que tu as 10 derniers
coups je n'aurais pas fait beaucoup très
honnêtement c'était quand même le
dernier non plus mais eux le dernier
peut-être le plus en plus comme ça comme
un coup génial pratique mais
c'est vraiment très mal je sais pas quoi
faire au moins là tu sais quoi faire il
y avait le temps avant de ça faut aller
je trouve que les noirs sont un peu
affolés la mèche bien joué tu as parié
ou non moi j'ai parié en bas de
sous-mouvoir donc c'est Paris Paris
inverse de nos équipes de notre team
ouais mais je sens quoi que je sens de
moins en moins la même après que j'ai 4
je sens que quelqu'un d'autre va le
sentir là il est fou pour F6 qui arrive
et tout mais bon mais bon attention ça
peut tourner le concret il y a le temps
il y a la pression
elle sait pas si elle doit sacrifier
et victoire débarras donc ça veut dire
que s'il y a à votre va fais au moins
nul ça continue ah oui oui ça peut être
aussi
incroyable il sort de il revient de
nulle part il nous faut un retournement
de situation les Espagnols maintenant
elle a filé le pion aussi
on peut peut-être qu'on peut peut-être
grailler
regarde ça F5 maintenant fu F6 je sais
pas non faut C5 c'est bien joué aussi
la gaffe il y a mais surtout
prends C8 on fait tout reprend quel
pagaille 18 secondes contre 21 qu'est-ce
qui se passe sur fou France et oui il
faut le jouer
c'est énorme
ça a été primo mais c'est une gaffe
je t'avais dit qu'il avait tout donné
au niveau du match mais tu as gagné mais
là j'ai senti j'ai senti parce que
malheureusement avec peu de temps on
sent c'est quelqu'un qui se s’entraîne
pas du tout en tu vois et donc
évidemment ça te parle de ne pas rempli
de gagner Laura unique et c'est les
normes qui l'emporte parce que toutes
ces pièces Gawen Jones là aussi emporter
quelle partie ça s'est joué sur cette
partie bon on a bien fait de racine de
cette partie qui est vide bravo bravo
vos temps pour leur magnifique vote
il y a eu de la faute là
une deuxième prolongation on était pas
si loin pas si loin on était pas si loin
mais on va se on va se quitter bons amis
ah ouais ouais tu as trouvé tu as trouvé
la
gagnante de cette partie tu as senti le
sacrifice hein
parce que là c'est ça serait de la pub
mensongère pour le coup c'était quand
même
osé le sacrifice à fonctionner et ça
marche pas tout le temps ça peut marcher
en blitz de temps en temps donc victoire
victoire victoire logique mais à
l'arraché des nord-ouen
mais dominé n'est pas gagné ça failli
bah il suffisait que
unique perde ce Blitz tout simplement et
elle était quand même elle était comme
on dit dans le Sud-Ouest Carmel mou
exactement et si elle bloque mais avec
gambas manger voilà
d'accord c'est mignon c'est mignon on
peut dire ça
ce petit stream du coup tu vas tu vas
continuer toute cette semaine avec avec
stouf maître fils Stéphane Bressac qui
est très régulièrement sur chetcom donc
vous allez bien vous amuser avec des
gros matchs surtout demain à Laurent
c'est ce que tu disais surtout demain
ouais il y a le match à 16h30
de de Blitz stream
face aux face aux indiens mais plein
d'autres matchs à suivre demain et
après-demain 16h30 même heure même
endroit 16h30 après on se lâche plus sur
la chaîne Youtube de chaise 24 en
français la chaîne Youtube de chaise de
chasse comme en français n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner aux chaînes YouTube à la
chaîne twitch vous pouvez sub aussi sur
twitch et voilà sur évidemment le twitch
de
chascom mon cher Kevin on a vu en tout
cas deux deux très beaux matchs et des
départages pour la première fois on a
appris les règles des départages tu vois
mais ça je m'en doute et tu vois ça fait
ça fait 3 jours que je dis on me dit non
non tu te trompes ces derniers chéquier
et bien voilà finalement j'avais raison
aussi Laurent pour la technique la
montée en puissance parce que c'était
quand même ça sera encore mieux c'était
au top tu es au top après il y a un
moment il y a le plafond de verre quand
même faut pas oublier ça c'est toujours
pareil doucement merci à toi Kévin en
tout cas c'était un grand plaisir merci
à tous ceux en coulisse qui nous aide
parce que ils sont là aussi je pense à
Vanessa notamment qui nous aide Nathan
évidemment que lesquels on est en
contact très régulier qui nous aide
beaucoup pour la technique et
merci au plus important finalement à
ceux qui nous ont regardé tout
d'aujourd'hui et ce qui nous parle ce
merci
c'est important bien sûr facile quand
vous posez des questions donc n'hésitez
pas en tout cas et on vous retrouve sur
notre chaîne dès demain avec Laurent et
stouf bonne soirée ciao ciao salut à
tous bye bye